foreign
testing one two
this is your one minute warning the
okay well good morning everyone and
welcome to the first meeting of the
science technology and energy committee
for the general court session of 2023
and 2024.
I'm going to explain what will happen in
this morning's meeting in just a moment
but first I'd like you all to stand and
join representative Lex barajny as he
thank you and once again welcome
everyone to our initial meeting we're
going to spend the first hour
of our session here this morning
on organizational matters we're going to
get to know each other and we're going
to re-familiarize ourselves with the
rules of committee procedure in the
house
as most of you have figured out by now
we have
14 returning
Representatives I'm sorry 13 returning
representatives to the committee and
seven new representatives to the
committee
I'm representative Michael those I'm the
chair of the committee humbled to be the
leader of this committee again after
last sessions leadership opportunity to
my right is our vice chair
representative Douglas Thomas of
Londonderry to my left is our new
committee clerk representative J.D
Bernardi of Northampton so yep
never get those Civil War issues
straightened out anyway uh so in just a
second I'm going to go around and ask
every member here to uh introduce him or
herself and give us maybe about a minute
of information you think we need to have
to know about you so that we can get to
know you a little bit better but before
we get to that I want to explain the
rest of the day
starting at 10 o'clock we've asked the
department of energy to do a
presentation on the department
what its functions are what its mission
our original schedule called for the
Public Utilities Commission do it do a
similar presentation from one to three
or one to two thirty
however yesterday I was informed by the
chair of the commission that illness has
struck the commission and so if they
have asked for a rescheduling so we will
be here hearing from the Public
Utilities Commission at a later date I
don't know the exact date at this point
in time we have to come up with a
reschedule to fit them in
once I discovered that I asked the
consumer Advocate if he could move up
from his position at 2 30 to 1 o'clock
and he uh being a a great gentleman
agreed to that and so we'll be hearing
from the consumer Advocate after lunch
and he will be our final presentation of
the day so we'll actually be
actually be wrapping up our activity a
little early today compared to what we
originally planned
and I will remind everybody that we do
have additional sessions planned for
next Tuesday the 17th of January the
Department of Environmental services
will be here the joint utilities will be
here to make presentations and then on
Thursday the 19th we'll also have
presentations by ISO New England
by the New England power generators
Association and the granite state
hydropower Association
and then we will have further
presentations in subsequent weeks
as necessary
so with that being said I'd like now to
uh
give each member here an opportunity to
introduce him or herself and I would
like to start with our vice chair
representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair and good morning
everybody happy to be back here happy to
be representing Londonderry which its
own district 16 out of Rockingham County
I'm starting my fifth term here
everything has been with the Science
Tech and energy committee and
um just a quick background I'm a retired
military Air Force I was a Munitions
maintenance officer so I'm a little
familiar with some of the
types of weapons that the Air Force uses
I was also in safety as well so I'm a
little familiar with safety Concepts and
so forth and I spent when I was out of
the Air Force I spent 29 years as a
support contractor program manager and
logistician over at Hanscom Air Force
Base in the acquisition field
um I've
done a few
local committees for the town and I've
been involved in you know various
projects elections and so forth
so um that's my basic background and if
any any questions I'll be happy to
answer them after the fact so I'll turn
it over to the next person
uh thank you before we go to our next
person I want to point out to everyone
that you have a microphone and a speaker
in front of you when it comes your turn
to speak press the button to turn on
your microphone
and then give us your introduction and
then when you're done speaking please
turn off your microphone
and we'll go next to the ranking member
of the committee representative Kat
McGee of Hollis
cat thank you Mr chair yes as the chair
said I am Kat McGee of Hollis and I'm
entering my third term on science
technology and energy
um I really wanted to serve on this
committee as many of my colleagues here
did because I was interested in energy
policy and making sure that we make good
decisions moving forward so that we can
make sure people uh in the state have
reasonable rates and also that we're
making progress uh on the on the issues
that I noticed when I first started
paying to attend paying attention to
energy policy in New Hampshire uh you
know trying to make strides on the on
those original policies that we make
gains on environmental issues
um as well as modernizing and keeping
our grid reliable so all those issues
matter a lot to me I've learned a lot on
this committee my background is in
program management software engineering
program management specifically an
enterprise-wide project management so my
background's in software technology and
also in sort of managing teams so I was
hoping to bring those skills here and
volunteer for the state and make some
things happen so thank you
thank you representative McGee
representative muns
thank you Mr chairman uh yeah my name is
Chris muns I am from Hampton this is my
second term
representing Hampton I served previously
between 2012 and 2014. I was on the the
Commerce Committee during that during
that session
this is a committee that I've always
been very intrigued and interested about
because of my interest in in energy
environmental issues so I'm I'm thrilled
to be here
um
early in my career I worked for a new
hampshire-based company wheeler braider
Technologies which is a developer and a
owner and operator of refuse burning and
wood burning power plants
I was the control of the financial
controller of one of our larger
operations in New York and then was the
regional controller for the six plants
that we had in New England including two
here in New Hampshire
so I'm hoping that I can bring that
experience to bear I spent the rest of
my professional career working in a
variety of Financial and HR management
roles and then spent five years working
in the non-profit sector
before retiring
thank you and welcome to stne
my name is Lex berezny I represent
Alexandria Grafton Hebron and Groton
I've been a software developer for 20
years and I'm excited to be in this
committee for my second term
thank you representative barajny
representative McWilliams
thank you chair Vos my name is
representative Rebecca McWilliams I
represent the Concord South floterial
District Wards one two three four
five six
um it's a pleasure to be here on my
third term all of my terms have been
served with stne so I'm getting to know
some new people this year and that's
kind of exciting my background is early
on in my career I worked on wind in
Rhode Island I was involved in getting
the very first wind turbine installed in
at Portsmouth Abbey in Rhode Island in
the early 2000s
then I was also involved in several
lease deals with school rooftops for
solar power in Massachusetts
um
I've worked as both an architect and an
attorney I'm licensed to do both in
Massachusetts and New Hampshire right
now I'm doing more architecture than law
but it's helpful as a legislator to have
both
right now my focus is really on
bipartisan Solutions so I'm looking
forward to working with all of you my
colleagues to come up with a kernel of
agreement on most of the bills that we
will see this year and I'm really
thinking that this is the year we come
up with some solutions for tricky
problems so thank you for having me and
I look forward to working with you
thank you representative representative
Summers
thank you Mr chairman my name is James
Summers I represent Rockingham County
District 20. that is Plaistow Newton and
Southampton
um prior experience I was in the
military Navy nuclear Submariner and
electricians mate as far as uh worked in
the as
28 years in the I.T field network
engineering mostly and currently I'm a
founder and CEO of a network engineering
company in Newton New Hampshire and I'm
happy to return to the science
technology energy committee I served on
here 2010 to 2012.
thank you and representative Summers
welcome to sdne
representative Kaplan
yes hi uh I'm Tony Kaplan I represent
Merrimack 8 which is Henniker Bradford
and Warner it's my second term my first
term I served on the environment
agriculture committee
my previous experiences I started out as
a wire service journalist after college
working in Central America doing a lot
of political news also did a lot of
financial news for the Associated Press
kind of shifted into activism worked for
friends of the Earth as a climate and
energy campaigner in the early 90s and
then I moved back to the states with my
wife and got into public school teaching
I'm a Spanish teacher for 20 plus years
retired now started the Henniker energy
committee so I've had a long-term
interest in energy and climate issues
and looking forward to serving on the
science technology committee and and
working as as my colleagues have said
towards bipartisan solutions to the
thank you representative and welcome to
St e representative Doug Thomas well
thanks George I'd like to make a comment
uh for the benefit of our new people
here that came to science to take we all
have new equipment here this year with
um microphones if we could please uh get
closer to the mic and maybe talk just
over it so that we have a clear a lot of
people have soft voices and we'd
appreciate if we could hear you a little
bit better thank you
thank you now we'll hear from another
representative Thomas representative
Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um I'm representative Wendy Thomas I
hail from the town of Merrimack this is
my second term although not concurrent
the last time I served on resources
my science background one of my degrees
is in medical biology and I worked as a
clinical microbiologist for several
years after college then I moved to New
Hampshire to start installing computer
systems in hospital Laboratories
uh from there I moved to digital
Equipment Corporation deck where I
worked as a tech writer then I was
trained and became a course developer
and ultimately
um I ended up as an instructional
designer
because of that I've taught graduate and
undergraduate classes in Tech writing
and instructional design
with regard to energy I've been working
for the last year and a half in the
Energy Efficiency field
and I have a journalistic background as
well
um I'm I'm a better journalist than I am
a reporter
um but that's I'm very pleased to be on
this committee thank you
thank you representative next is
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman uh Ned Reynolds
I'm here representing the city of
Portsmouth
three out of the five
Awards of the city of Portsmouth the
floaterial district
I served three terms on the Portsmouth
City Council in my 21 years of residence
there
I guess I'm at least the third military
veteran on the committee here uh we
haven't heard from everybody yet but I
went to the Coast Guard Academy and uh
served eight years on active duty
including a stint at the scene of the
Exxon Valdez uh before uh leaving active
duty went to grad school in public
policy and I'm really pleased to
have a seat on this committee because
I then had a 25-year career in the
Energy Efficiency and and renewable
energy field in starting out with a
couple of non-profits uh that folks
probably know Northeast Energy
Efficiency Partnerships uh and then
later the union of concerned scientists
where I I worked on the implementation
of among Reggie
back in the 2006 to 2009 period and then
I went on to a couple of uh moved over
to the business side of things and
worked six and a half years for Johnson
Controls
with a team that installed Energy
Efficiency and renewable energy projects
across this across the region Northern
New England and then a few years with
revision energy uh working on solar
projects so I'm really pleased to be
here on this committee
thank you representative Reynolds and my
apologies for mispronouncing your name
at the beginning
representative closure
thank you Mr chair
I'm Tom plushie
I have a lifelong career in EMS mostly
as an EMT
my schooling was a degree in chemical
engineering
though my work career is analytical so I
was in mostly spectrometry and
microscopy
um
from my working career I've been on Town
boards
and I represent the citizens of Center
Harbor and New Hampton and this is my
thank you representative closure next up
is representative Corman
thank you Mr chair I am Tom Corman I
represent Lebanon Ward 3. which is
Grafton 15. I don't have excuse me a big
background in energy but a big interest
in energy my background is in technology
I have a PhD in computers science and
electrical engineering from MIT
and I recently retired as a computer
science professor at Dartmouth I'm now a
Emeritus Professor I retired about a
year ago I am co-author actually lead
author on a book called introduction to
algorithms which is only 1300 Pages it's
the number one textbook in all of
computer science and it's actually sold
over a million copies and is in 15
different languages fourth edition just
recently came out so I know a little bit
about technology I taught the
introductory computer science course at
Dartmouth 25 times I taught courses and
algorithms and also software design and
then a few other courses and I also was
the first director of The Institute for
writing and rhetoric at Dartmouth and I
even taught a section of freshman
thank you and welcome to St e
representative Noel
thank you Mr chair my name is Henry Noel
I represent Berlin co-was District 5.
um Native of Berlin born and brought up
there I went away to school and when I
came back to work I went to work in the
mill where I managed the railroad for 16
years until the Mill sold it after which
time they gave me the opportunity to
take get a take a hand or take charge of
the wastewater treatment facility which
became a the remainder of my career with
the city of Berlin
uh after my retirement from running the
Wastewater Plant I was asked to run for
state representative and was successful
in getting elected in 2018
uh and at that point I served on the
resources committee
uh did not succeed in getting reelected
but in 2020 but to have just recently
been reelected but there is another
representative sitting on the resource
committee from Berlin I didn't want to
duplicate and so I put my name in for
Science and Technology my interest in
science and technology is that we have
formed an ad hoc committee that has been
active now for a little over a year
interested in developing renewable
energy projects and taking an interest
in encouraging the city to to become an
energy an energy provider and my
participation in the committee would
would help me to reinforce that
thank you excellent well welcome aboard
representative lewicki uh thank you Mr
chairman my name is John lewicki I
represent currently Hillsboro 36 which
is Brookline Mason and Greenville
um this is my third term
um and my will be the beginning of my
second year on science technology and
energy
my background has been in startup
companies primarily but I've also worked
at a few big companies mostly in product
development electrical and systems
engineering and
also as uh you know was on a school
committee for a while done other things
within my town and within my school
district and now I am mostly retired
like most of us I also do have a
military background but I kept it as
great thank you
next step is representative murder
thank you Mr chairman uh my name is Troy
Myrna I represent kawas district one
from I'm from the town of Lancaster
represent Lancaster Northumberland
and Dalton
that's it right yeah because I could
redistrict this year it's my fourth term
fourth term here I am also the selectman
for the town of Lancaster I am also the
county delegation chair for cause County
and I'm also for the 23 unincorporated
areas which include the mount wash
balsams and Etc I am also the planning
board for that all the unincorporated
areas so I have a vast interest in the
North Country I'm retired from the
Building Trades and
that's about it look forward to
continuing the workout
thank you representative notter
thank you Mr chairman um I'm Janine
nodder from the town of Merrimack I'm on
my seventh term this is my fifth term on
science technology and energy I do have
a great interest in energy and
Communications we've gone to many
conferences on the subject
I've been a freelance writer and had
other jobs but the one I'm most proud of
are the six kids that I raised and I
worry about how they're going to afford
energy their electric bill and putting
gas in the car so I'm happy to be here
as a conservative boat for them thank
you
thank you and now our clerk
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman yes JD Bernardi
Rockingham 36 which is Hampton Falls
Kensington Southampton Newton and
Plaistow the southeast state line of
New Hampshire uh I'm a biochemist by
undergraduate training then did uh
Navy nuclear engineering
did a refueling overhaul parts of the
Naval Shipyard that's brought me to New
Hampshire
um went to Franklin Pierce lost law law
school
and then diverted my career into
Pharmaceuticals pharmaceutical
development and quality assurance
quality assurance uh did that job for
about 38 years
Town wise I've served as as the chairman
of the of the zoning board for the last
10 years uh and with respect to uh
Science Tech and energy this would be my
second term
um I am very interested in ensuring our
electrical grid is reliable and cost
effective if it doesn't meet those
criteria I'm not interested
okay thank you representative Bernardi
so I'll wrap up this introductory
session representative Michael Bose from
the town of Epping that's Rockingham
District Five
I'm in my fifth term in the New
Hampshire house and my second term as
chair of this committee I got after a
40-year career in computer software I
began my public service career in the
1980s serving on the budget Committee in
Peterborough
that I took a Hiatus from public service
for a while and
became a library trustee in Epping in
2012. I now serve on the planning board
in Epping and I ran for
the New Hampshire house in 2014.
and I'm happy to have all of you here
and I'm really looking forward to
working with everybody we do have one
more person
as representative Bernardi just pointed
out to me and that's representative
Harrington Michael would you introduce
yourself please
sure Mike Mike Carrington represents
Stratford 18 which is now made up of
Middleton New Durham Stratford and
Barrington it's a kind of a new district
for me I represented Stratford and New
Durham in the past uh this will be my
fifth uh time on Science and Tech my
sixth term in the house I'm a nuclear
engineer a member of marriages of the
American nuclear society which I've
actually been a member of longer than
I've done anything else including my
marriage of 44 years
um as stated before my concerns is the
price of electricity and energy I
realize it's limited to what we can do
but we want to make sure what we do do
doesn't make things more expensive and
we shouldn't be looking out for special
interest groups the only special
interest groups we consider are the
voters and the rate payers because they
get the short end of the stick most of
the time because they can't spend a lot
of money on lobbyists to come up here
and try to get people to vote money into
thank you representative Harrington so
now we all know who the players are
and so let's talk a little bit about
what the game is uh involved with
we're going to do three quick
presentations here myself I'm going to
talk a little bit about ground rules and
the organization of the committee
representative
Thomas Douglas Thomas is going to talk a
little bit about public hearings and
then representative Bernardi is going to
talk a little bit about how we can how
we will make our final decisions in
executive session
so let me start about by talking a
little bit about some of the
the administrative basics of the
operation of this committee
we will be meeting on Mondays and
Tuesdays
throughout the coming year
that does not mean we will meet every
Monday and every Tuesday but those are
the two days that have been
given to us for the use of this room so
those are the two days that we will meet
most often
we will start at nine o'clock in the
morning
and we will run until five o'clock in
at the current time there have been 13
bills assigned to this committee but we
expect by the time the
house clerk has finished and the speaker
has has finished assigning bills that we
will have somewhere between 32 and 35
bills to pass judgment on between now
and the crossover deadline in early
April
foreign
we'll be using a single email account
for legislative business that's the
house science technology and energy
email account
all of you have been uh put into that
account so anybody who sends email to
that account it will go to everybody on
our address code
such as it is is business casual
and we would encourage the men to wear
ties
unless you have a medical situation that
food is not allowed in the committee
room we do allow water
but food is not allowed if you need
to have a a snack for dietary reasons
for health reasons we will take periodic
breaks during the day and you can do
use of electronic devices
we've spoken to the speaker of the house
and the speaker of the house has asked
us to advise all of you
that laptops and
iPads or tablets are not allowed on
committee tables
the only electronic devices that we're
going to allow on committee tables are
iPhones and other uh
types of phones
you're discouraged from using your phone
except for
um
minimalist tasks like responding to a
text that you think is important or
responding to an email that is critical
for the most part however we would
appreciate you don't look at your phone
the reason for these
prescriptions by the speaker are that it
is disrespectful to the people who are
testifying and presenting before the
committee
for members to be distracted by their
electronic devices
so the speaker
urges us all to refrain from using those
electronic devices
unless
there is a critical need to do so
you can always take your electronic
device and leave the committee room
and do some work outside in the hallway
but we want you to be respectful of the
public be respectful of the people who
come to present before us
by paying attention to what they have to
say and not losing
track of what's going on by being
preoccupied with your electronic devices
representative McGee did you have a
question yes I did thank you Mr chairman
um I am just questioning the decision
for the science technology and energy
committee to not be able to use
technology in our hearings because I
think
whether folks are paying sufficient
respect and attention to those that are
testifying
would come down to a Personnel issue if
someone really wasn't paying attention
in the hearings I think that's a
different issue than actually having
access to technology
in what what are full days for us here
in Concord so I would I would like to
push back and even speak with the
speaker's office if I could about
having an exception for the science
technology and energy committee I mean I
think many of us here have laptops and
devices today that I used just this
morning to let you know that Dr creation
was unable to attend because of an
illness
um and we got that as a late breaking
note to the committee so I just think
there are many reasons why people would
want to have technology and I think that
this committee should advocate for that
rather than
um you know take it that we uh do not
need technology in order to perform our
job sufficiently
thank you for that comment
representative Harrington
thank you Mr Speaker and listen close
because you're not going to hear this
too often but I 100 agree with
representative McGee
um I think that that is a silly Rule and
I think we should push back on it I use
reference to uh Vice chair Thomas's uh
email that was sent out that said we
should be familiar with the 10-year
energy plan and the department of energy
so forth uh do you expect this to print
these out or all copies of these going
to be printed out in the of to
distribute to the entire committee so we
can look at them or otherwise we could
just simply pull them up on our computer
uh I really think we should push back on
this and say this I don't know what his
point is to thinking people being
offended uh if someone's acting
obnoxiously then this chair could just
simply say can you kind of knock it off
you're not paying attention to anybody
all you do is stick your nose in your
computer but to say that if you want to
look up something and when you're like
talking to the Department of energy
about the 10-year energy plan until
referring to page 22 this line I have a
question on it we won't be able to do
that unless we all print out paper
copies and if you're reading a paper
copy is that any more obnoxious than
reading it something like a computer I
just don't get this it's no there's no
sense to this whatsoever
and I think we should push back to the
speaker's office on it thank you for
that comment representative Wendy Thomas
thank you
um I'd like to know if there are any
medical accommodations for laptops in
this committee um I have arthritis in my
hands and I can type far easier than I
can write with a pen
thank you
all those are are good comments and the
root of this policy is decorum it's
being
attentive to and polite to the people
to do that
it's likely going to be necessary that
you if you have a tablet or a laptop
that you keep it
concealed to the best of your ability so
that the people who are speaking to us
will think that they have our attention
now that doesn't mean you can't use your
device between speakers
or
during breaks or take it out into the
hallway and use it whenever you feel you
need to
but we want to discourage
the ongoing use while people are sitting
before us testifying and presenting of
these electronic devices if you need
them to take notes
then
use them
but do it in a way that
is respectful of the people who are
making presentations to us
don't do it in a way that makes them sit
there and wonder
what's this person doing are they
listening to anything I'm saying
that's the the basis for this policy
it's not that we're
luddites that were anti-technology which
would be ironic for a committee such as
ours
it's that we're being respectful to the
people who come before us they have
important things to say to us and they'd
like to be assured that they're being
heard
did you have a comment representative
Reynolds yes Mr chairman thank you I I
agree with you and I think I don't think
anybody on the committee would disagree
that
we should all be respectful and
appreciative of
folks who come to testify before us and
present to us and I think that
when someone's using technology
to either take notes
about what some what somebody is saying
or to look something up for reference
and perhaps ask a question based on it
and someone sitting there
doing email all day typing typing typing
typing so I hope we can
um
honor the speakers intent while also
you know as the Science Tech and energy
committee uh
demonstrate that technology is something
that enhances our lives and is not a
mere distraction
okay thank you for that comment let's
move on we'll be keeping an eye on this
as the year develops and hopefully we
won't have to deal with any
significant
violations of the basic precepts of this
policy
one more quick comment
representative Gorman
thank you Mr chair uh I taught as I said
the introductory computer science course
many times and I had to deal with this
issue of students using their laptops
and not paying attention I tried various
policies and all I want to say is I
would like to think that the
representatives on this committee are a
lot more mature than college students
and a lot more responsible so I would
hope to to think that we would all be
using our laptops for the correct
purpose and not shopping and not
watching basketball games
okay thank you all right let's move on
um next item on my list here is each of
you will be given a drawer in the little
office off to the
behind that second clock
um where you can keep the materials that
you'll be getting during the course of
our business over the next few months
and you'll be getting a lot of it you'll
be getting a lot of written testimony
submitted by people testifying on bills
you'll be getting a lot of illustrative
materials you'll be getting copies of
all the bills so you're going to have a
a need to find a place to put all this
stuff so you'll have a drawer assigned
to you in that back office and I urge
you to use it and
um keep it neat and keep all your
materials together so you can access
them easily
the
end three seats over here on this on my
left in the committee are assigned for
security notifications so I'll be
talking to the three representatives
there about security issues should they
as you probably are well aware by now we
have
a partisan balance on this committee we
have 10 Democratic members and we have
10 Republican members
I have chosen a seating arrangement for
the committee
that
I think will work for us
the speaker has requested that we
alternate Republicans and Democrats
wherever possible this year
and so I've tried to do that
within the constraints of having the
leadership group here together up at the
the kinds of build topics that we
typically get in this committee are
mostly energy topics we don't get a lot
of raw science or raw technology kind of
bills it's mostly energy
that may require at some point in the
distant future a a change of the title
of this committee I don't know but for
now it's primarily an energy committee
representative Thomas in a few minutes
is going to talk a little bit about
second committee work and subcommittees
calendars and notices all of our
meetings will be noticed in the calendar
at least three business days before the
date of the meeting
so that is your your first point of
reference to find out when we're meeting
I will try to keep you informed
at the end of a current meeting I'll
I'll mention when our next meeting is
scheduled
but you should
always rely on our calendar for the
final word on when uh we'll be meeting
the files that you put together on
individual bills are supposed to be kept
in this building they're not supposed to
leave the building
and
with those Basic Ground rules in place
I'm going to turn it over to
representative Doug Thomas to talk about
the public hearing process so
representation excuse me Mr chairman
could I give us a comment I'm a little
confused by one of your last statements
there we're not allowed to take stuff
home with us I mean this is some I've
never heard this I've been my sixth term
never heard you were not allowed to take
information home with you I mean it is a
rule of the house that Bill files are
not supposed to leave the building I
I've never heard of it either but
representative Thomas has more info
right well I I believe that refers to
the official files that the uh that are
assistant has that that is kept here
your own notes your own notes and then
and and copies of bills obviously can be
taken home I believe that's what this
refers to it's poorly worded I believe
thank you for the clarification I
I guess I'm on thank you Mr chair uh
I'll hurry on because we're running out
of time here uh just uh
on public hearings on the scheduled
hearings if we have an unexpected large
crowd that comes to this room uh we will
contact our assistant and they have a
protocol set up to move us to a larger
place
on that day however if you happen to
know because
you have an end with
the internet that there is going to be a
very large crowd here it would be
helpful to know that in advance just to
avoid wasting some time
um
and of course on any any recesses that
are called for public hearings will be
rescheduled to a date and time certain
so that we know when we're going to be
reconvening again I'd like to talk a
little bit about the uh organizing the
speakers and I believe this topic is
very important this year and I think
we're going to try and hold to it just
as closely as we possibly can
the famous pink cards
the pink cards are really important to
be turned in
as soon as you come into this room
they should be given directly to the the
chair
and they should be filled out uh don't
be wordy but it should they should be
filled out so that we know who you are
who you represent and what your topic is
but the main point I'll talk to now is
we may have situations where we may have
a large amount of ping cards everybody
will have a chance to speak
we want to allot a fair time to
everybody to speak
if we only have 45 minutes then we have
two pink cards we know how much time we
can give each speaker if we have 30
speakers we're going to to drastically
alternate that time per speaker so
everyone has a chance to speak
if someone comes in late or if they
decide they're going to put a pink card
in later after we decided how much time
to give each person to speak they are
going to be subject to time remaining
uh they their time to speak could be
much less so please get your cards in
early so we can have a fair opportunity
to a lot naturally if a topic is that
that
deep and developed and we obviously are
going to need much more time the chair
may make a decision to recess to a Time
certain so we can have more time to
discuss the actual bill so please get
your pink cards in early and please tell
your internet friends to do the same
thing too if they're going to come here
to speak
we'd appreciate that yes representative
McGee
thank you representative Thomas my
question is if we will know in advance
that a particular Bill might be more
controversial than another will we be
scheduling additional time or will they
all be uniform regardless of whether we
can anticipate that they might be more
well attended than others
I think there'll be a question for the
as we've done in the past we'll try to
give more time to build subjects that we
think will be will be controversial yes
moving on um and uh as we've come as
we've covered before in the past
sponsors are generally recognized first
to speak and introduce the bill
um followed by other representatives and
um
uh let's see uh and we will try to the
best of our ability and depending on who
is coming in to speak we will try to
alternate between pros and cons speakers
if they so designate on their print card
or even if they're neutral will it will
alternate
we will announce a lunch break depending
on the type of Bill and how much time we
think we have uh it will depend on the
exact time of the lunch break
um I'd like to take a little bit about
we're following some rules that we're
given here in our training it says we
ask people to remove stickers or buttons
as they come in here that show advocacy
so uh so please inform your groups they
should be doing that we know that we do
not allow any signs in the committee
room
they should be kept outside if at all
possible they certainly shall not be
held up displayed in any way while we're
um let's see we covered the drinks thing
we covered the time testimony that's
good
um oh questions from committee members
again
this year we are going to be very formal
now that we're coming back to normal
times after the pandemic
this is a Science and Tech committee
we expect that both testimony and
questions should be factually based so
therefore our request to our members is
to ask questions that are for
information or for clarification on what
is being testified and I think a fair
question would be if someone is
expressing an opinion then a fair
question might be where did you get your
opinion from do you have some reference
point as to uh as so we can check the
facts on that so we will not be allowing
any
would you believe
questions
and or any questions that would be
leading the the testifier this is not a
courtroom and unfortunately we are on
streaming so we don't want any show
voting uh with certain uh types of
questions they are for information and
and for facts we can better make
decisions on each of these bills I think
we're going to try our best to uh you
um written testimony should be given to
the to the clerk after your testimony
and please if you have written testimony
we do not want you to read your written
testimony it uh for time purposes please
just summarize it for us please or if
you have new information that's not in
your new testimony in your written
testimony
um
Let's see we talked about security oh
yes uh co-sponsors or sponsors of bills
co-sponsors and sponsors that are
members on this committee
can testify and they will be allowed to
come back and sit in their seat but they
will not be allowed to ask questions on
uh testimony is not accepted by email
only paper copies of testimony letters
or other documents that are delivered by
hand or U.S commercial mail are required
to be included in the public record
for official files
yes representative McGee yep I just I
just uh would like to take exception to
that and wonder whether we can vote on
any of these rules because the idea of
not allowing electronic testimony seems
uh antithetical to being a science
technology and energy committee I think
a lot of people do present their
testimonies that way and it's a
convenience for the public to be able to
express their positions so if we don't
allow it uh it's really discouraging
people from participating in the process
where maybe I jump in here we're not
discouraging electronic testimony we're
just discouraging email testimony we
have a established process within the
house about how to submit electronic
testimony and we're asking people to
follow that assistance so that will
still be allowed yeah yes okay okay
great thanks thank you I I was going to
come with that on my next sentence
saying that the online testimony
submission tool may be used to submit
testimony
yes representative Harrington uh maybe I
misunderstood you or maybe I'm just
confused you said something about
co-sponsors I thought we had the rule
now allowed a co-sponsor to make a
decision they could either speak in
favor of the bill or they could stay at
their seat and then ask questions but
they couldn't do both
the way you put it is like if you're a
co-sponsor you can speak and that's it
well I'm going off the training that we
have here on what we were supposed to
present to the committee I reversed my
memory I believe that rule or subject
was brought up at the last session but
did we vote on that in favor of that I
thought we did but I could be wrong
we need to check that because I thought
it was I thought you had the option
a really quick uh subcommittees uh
nothing really changes here
um
we just want more more timely action if
we form a subcommittee please meet
within a few days get information and
report it back to the committee here we
don't want to drag on for weeks
um
work session Administration the first
name member will serve as the
subcommittee chairman the worst citizens
will will be posted in the house
calendar whenever possible
um
we you you'll you you must have minutes
and we must file paperwork
um uh with with the bill that's It's
associated with and the working
committee assistance will work with you
on all of those types of endeavors
are we about done yes thank you
representative Thomas we have more
information to share with you about
committee procedures
but we're going to
um
defer sharing that information for now
because we have reached the end of our
organization meeting scheduled time and
the department of energies put a lot of
time and effort into preparing their
presentation this morning so we want to
make sure we don't shortchange them time
wise so what I'm going to do right this
minute is call a three-minute
recuperate a little bit from the
organizational session and we'll call on
the department of energy in just a few
minutes but for right now we're in
thank you
the only thing I heard
okay everyone please take your seats
like to get started with the
presentation by the department of energy
I mentioned right before we broke for
recess that we had more information to
share with you about
our operational activities as a
committee so what we're going to do
since we
had a cancellation by the puc for their
presentation today this after the
consumer Advocate finishes his
presentation and we've wrapped up all
the questions we're going to go back
into organizational mode and talk a
little bit more about the
operation of the committee particularly
uh executive session and clean up any
other questions we have so that uh the
next
time we meet we can hit the ground
running and know exactly what the rules
so with that I'm going to turn the
meeting over to the Department of energy
or their presentation you've just
received a handout from
Mr robarge who will take over the
presentation and get us started good
morning Mr robersh
good morning members of the committee uh
Griffin Roberge I am the state energy
program manager at the New Hampshire
Department of energy I will be a
frequent face to all of you as I will uh
regularly be representing the department
when it comes to discussing pending
legislation so look forward to working
with all of you over the next few months
um
I was at the department has been asked
by this committee to present an overview
of what the department does as well as
on a few areas of interest to the
committee as you'll see our presentation
includes just a short introduction by me
then we'll have an overview of the
department by our commissioner Deputy
Commissioner followed by an overview of
retail utility issues then an overview
overview of our division of policy and
programs
renewable portfolio standard net
metering consumer services within our
department how the department and
federal funding and then the closing
with a summary of our state energy
strategy
there are several hyperlinks in our
presentation that the committee may wish
to take a look at but please know we
will be sending along an electronic copy
of the presentation following today's
meeting so you'll have that accessible
to you before I do turn it over to the
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner I
do want to share with you some points of
contact in case any of you have any
energy related questions over the next
few months as I mentioned I will be the
one regularly representing the
department to this committee so please
feel free to reach out to me anytime I'm
certain I'll have conversations with
many of you over the next few months the
other one I wanted to encourage folks
maybe reach out to obviously you folks
represent various constituencies those
constituencies will certainly have
energy related questions whether it's on
utility bill energy G policy Etc
any type of those consumer services
issues please feel free to reach out to
our director Amanda Noonan she's the
director of consumer services and her
and her staff work every day with
citizens around the state of New
Hampshire to address a lot of these
questions so please feel free to reach
out to her as well with that I'll turn
it over to commissioner Jared ducoin and
Deputy Commissioner Chris Elms to take
off their part of the presentation thank
you
foreign
thank you Griffin good morning thank you
chairman Vos for the opportunity uh an
invitation to speak to the committee
today my name is Jared chicoine I'm the
commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy and I'm joined here
by Deputy Commissioner Chris alms
the New Hampshire Department of energy
is is New Hampshire's new estate agency
at this time two years ago the
department did not exist in the previous
budget governor sununu and the
legislature created the department to
quote provide unified direction of
policies programs and Personnel in the
field of energy end quote and to make
possible increased efficiencies in the
administration of energy related
functions of the executive branch
given the recent energy related
challenges that have uh bubbled up in
the United States and New England and
New Hampshire globally the legislature
and the governor's move to emphasize
energy in state government was quite
timely
the reorganization
moved most of the staff of the Public
Utilities Commission and the office of
strategic initiatives formerly the
office of energy and planning to the
Department of energy
the office of strategic initiatives was
dissolved and streamlined and the
streamlined puc was administratively
attached to the department as was the
Office of Consumer Advocate and the site
evaluation committee
part of the intent of the legislation
was to allow the puc to focus on their
regulatory adjudicative responsibilities
and to make clear the separation between
the state's regulatory advocacy role and
the impartial role that the puc plays
the department of energy is a large and
diverse set of responsibilities next
slide
in our mission statement we try to
illustrate State government's focus on
energy and in the Department's
responsibilities
our mission statement is this the
prosperity and security of New Hampshire
and its citizens require an affordable
Innovative reliable and sustainable
energy economy the department of energy
is committed to achieving that goal and
will provide a unified direction of
energy policies responsible and
practical programs principled regulation
and skilled representation and energy
related proceedings of New Hampshire's
public interest
the department of energy will serve the
people of New Hampshire in an honest
transparent
and effective manner
the next slide shows some of what our
role is in state government
we have a wide variety of
responsibilities at the department we
provide the regulatory advocacy and
record building role at proceedings
before the puc we administer Assistance
programs and other energy related
programs we provide support to Consumers
and take in consumer complaints against
utilities
we have a substantial role in utility
safety and enforcement of the state's
law states laws rules and regulations we
also have a strong policy role you'll
see our staff at almost every energy
related public hearing that this
committee holds and we'll provide
technical support information and
assistance as needed
please never hesitate to engage with our
staff
if you have any questions as Griffin
emphasized at the beginning please reach
out we're here as a resource to all of
you
will also in some cases see us advocate
for or against certain policies
depending on how they align with the
policy direction as laid out in the
10-year State energy strategy which our
department crafts
the department has four divisions
regulatory support policy and programs
enforcement and administration most of
the staff were puc employees before July
2021 and many came from the office of
strategic initiatives which was
dissolved and we'll just take a minute
to look at each of those divisions
we obviously have the commissioner's
office here are email addresses in our
office please never hesitate to reach
out to either Chris or me
we have a division of regulatory support
this division is led by director Tom
Franz and many of you know Tom and
you'll hear from him later this morning
the department of energy is an automatic
party at the puc and helps build the
record in those proceedings and
advocates for the public interest
the division of policy and programs has
a large set of responsibilities Josh
Elliott is the division director and he
will speak after Tom and give you an
the division of enforcement enforces
compliance with safety related laws
rules and regulations applicable to
Electric utilities and Natural Gas
Utilities and pipelines the division
directors Paul Casper and includes the
Department's safety audit and cyber
security staff the cyber security
position I would just add was created
um
in the budget in the last budget that
position is now filled and we're excited
about this new role that we have at the
department the division maintains a Gis
for critical and major energy and
Telecommunications infrastructure and
participates in emergency preparedness
and response
so when there was a recent uh winter
storm that created
many outages our team obviously works
with the utilities as the state agency
to monitor the status of those outages
and restoration
finally we have the division of
administration which is led by director
Rory Patterson the division convinced
consists excuse me of the legal staff
who participate in puc proceedings and
provide legal support to other divisions
the division also houses our business
office and grants compliance staff
we briefly mentioned the administrative
attachment of the puc office of the
consumer Advocate and site evaluation
committee to the department through that
attachment our business office provides
back office support to those agencies
and that's essentially what that is
we don't tell those agencies what to do
we just help them pay their bills
process invoices and provide other types
of back office support
so that's the department structure
before we turn it over to to Tom Franz I
want to just take a few minutes to touch
on some of the Department of Energy's
particip participation in Regional
activities uh particularly related to
electricity
a lot of what we'll touch on will make
more sense after you hear from ISO New
England and we'll be happy to follow up
after that of course when it comes to
electricity it's it's very important to
note that New Hampshire is closely
connected with our neighbors each of the
New England states is part of the same
electric grid that is operated by ISO
New England
uh ISO New England has a three-part
mandate operate the grid plan for future
electric power requirements and design
and administer the wholesale electricity
markets ice and New England will talk
more about the electric markets but the
markets are the way that most of the
electric electric generation New
Hampshire uh gets its Revenue excuse me
New England gets its Revenue
uh the the decisions of one or a few
States impacts the whole so there's a
great deal of discussion coordination
and negotiation between the states the
New Hampshire Department of energy much
of this happens at the New England
states committee on electricity Nesco
where each state is represented of the
New England states New Hampshire has
been the most Market oriented
we have supported well-designed markets
and the competitive outcomes that they
provide
we have advocated for policies that
allow Market principles to drive
investment and oppose policies that
distort markets and inhibit price
signals
we have opposed Regional efforts that
unreasonably shift costs to New
Hampshire rate payers and we will
continue to do so in fact we have a
statutory mandate to do just that as you
New England is facing
um some very real challenges both in
terms of reliability and cost
we've all seen our electric bills
increase over the course of the last
year and ISO New England has warned that
a severe enough winter could lead to
electricity shortages
so let's talk briefly about reliability
over the last decade about 7000
megawatts of electric generation have
gone offline many of which might be
considered to be more reliable resources
many of the resources needed for
reliability-based Market uncertainty
despite their necessity to the grid
this is in part because of out-of-market
actions that other states have
undertaken to meet their decarbonization
goals and have introduced distortions
that affect those resources that require
Market revenues
to stay economical
there's another problem that underlies
many of the issues we deal with
regionally
New England is reliant on natural gas
but for a variety of reasons has limited
supply of domestic domestic natural gas
because of pipeline constraints I'm sure
many of you have heard that in the news
in the last couple of months
this has led to more dependence on
liquefied natural gas for our peak times
than other regions of the country have
had so it's it's a very uh it's a
problem that's unique to New England
um the problem has only been exacerbated
by global natural gas prices being
driven by
extreme um or excuse me by International
factors such as the invasion of Ukraine
and the economic effects coming out of
the covid-19 pandemic
next slide this slide that we borrowed
from my ISO New England is illustrative
on how closely the wholesale price of
electricity in New England is tied to
the price of natural gas it also shows
both historical prices and makes clear
some of the volatility in the markets I
thought they'd be a very helpful slide
for all of you
um this this next slide also from ISO
New England gives you a sense of scale
of the New England Electric market 2022
will probably look a lot uh or look more
like 2008 than previous years
um
okay
I'm gonna stop there
um
please visit our website we have this
slide here it's up to date we try to do
our best to make sure that the
information is up to date and relevant
for consumers and of course for policy
makers with that we'd be happy to take
representative Thomas is recognized
Douglas Thomas is recognized for a
question
thank you Mr chair I'm I'm the taller
one
um
uh thank you for your testimony I just
just kind of curious could you give us
just a little more insight on
how Nesco can affect the residents here
in in New Hampshire
sure so the New England states committee
on electricity uh it's essentially
um we represent the governors our
respective Governors and um we
as a group we discussed the challenges
facing the region as it relates to to
electricity and the regional grid and
markets and um
you know although we are not voting
members of of Nepal
um are uh
our position
we represent the states the governors
um that position is whatever position we
take on any issue
uh regionally you know that is taken
into consideration by ISO New England
and and other uh you know Market
participants so I think it's very
important
um for our state where we don't have we
don't share some of the same goals as
our neighbors it's a very important
um
platform for us to
to emphasize what New Hampshire's
policies are as it relates to
electricity and and to advocate for
ourselves
um with our with our neighbors and and
we do that in a way that's um respectful
and uh collegial at it's it's uh it is a
good group
um but again we have differences with
our neighbors and we do our very best to
represent our interests there
um so positions that Nesco takes on a
variety of issues
um we make sure that if we're not in 100
agreement the state of New Hampshire
that that is noted in any policy
statement that's issued by the group at
times you'll notice there are footnotes
um to letters that that Nesco issues
with a particular statement
um and there may be a footnote that says
New Hampshire has this particular
position that differs from the other
states so it is uh the the participation
in that group is is very valuable I
believe to New Hampshire and its rate
pairs
follow-up uh uh thank you really quick
do they have a binding uh
set of rules that or can they directly
affect our rates here in New Hampshire
for our our residents and and industries
Nesco
that's cool
not it not as an organization no
um
sorry no it's it's um again we we take a
position as a group uh typically we're
all on the same page as States
um but uh you know I I guess I would say
that if we were to
advance a policy support a policy that
had impacts on the Region's rate payers
um yes I guess that could be the case
but generally speaking though
representative Harrington
uh thank you Mr chairman um I'm going to
ask the the nasty question I guess given
the what's happened uh over Christmas
day we went into an op4 event we came
close to blackouts uh we're looking two
years in the future the two Mystic
plants are going to close their RMR
plants right now and probably District
gas is going to go away as well at least
what's the plan to make sure we have
sufficient LNG uh two years from now
when those two plants close and there's
no you know there's just a gas it loses
60 percent of their Market
I know it's a tough question that's a
great question
um
you know the the there is an inventory
to energy program that will roll out
next winter
um that that may provide
um some security there
um
the Mystic agreement last through next
winter it's it's that's it
um
I I don't know
uh it's it's a real challenge
um as I'm sure all of you are aware uh
it is very difficult to when it comes to
Natural Gas to expand pipeline capacity
into the region there are a number of
regional and local challenges to doing
that so we will be reliant on liquefied
natural gas for some time
where it all lands in a couple years I I
don't know
um but it is it's a serious challenge
for the region quick follow-up well if I
just may continue on that representative
there are a great deal of conversations
and analyzes happening you know looking
at topics from uh you know increasing
energy storage in the region or or
reserves to you know looking at
different Market mechanisms that might
help so when we say we don't know
there's no easy solution but there are a
great deal of uh resources and and
conversations
um efforts being undertaken to find
Solutions right and we are working with
the federal government
um on what's the most solutions could
look like but obviously that takes time
and it would have to work its way
through Congress if there was an
appropriation needed and follow-up uh
representative thank you chairman just
on that same subject with the minimum
offer price rule being going away in two
years uh and the fact that we looked at
the the last week of the year here where
sometimes we had 40 of our electricity
being produced by oil and those plants
rely on capacity payments is there any
effort now to suspend that getting rid
of that minimum offer price so those oil
plants will be around when we need them
five years from now
with the current composition of of ferc
I I don't think bringing back we did we
did not support elimination of the moper
um but with the the current composition
of ferc
um I I don't see the moper coming back
and just uh sorry to to continue on that
there are obviously a lot of
conversations related to other Market
changes
um in light of the mocha elimination
that that might be able to more
effectively you know keep keep places uh
plants online
representative muns have us a question
thank you Mr chairman and Mr
commissioner thank you for your service
and thank you for being here
um I had a question
um on page 14 of your
um uh presentation
um you made a there's a comment about
New Hampshire is the most Market
oriented of New Hampshire States
um markets are characterized by risks
and Rewards
um so I would assume that as the most
market-oriented State
we may be more
um
susceptible to those risks and rewards
can you can you characterize how
New Hampshire compares to other states
in terms of you know prices Supply
Etc
sure I'll take that if you don't mind
um one of the benefits of sort of the
market oriented approach is that
um with the restructured electricity
markets right now generators would bear
the business risks in participation in
the markets by relying more on wholesale
markets that allows the states to shift
that business risk to generators rather
than rate payers when States take out of
Market
um you know solutions to try to
encourage other generation you know
again outside of that market that risk
gets transferred to rate payers uh and
and so New Hampshire's market-oriented
approach is actually one of the benefits
is is keeping that risk off of New
Hampshire's right payers to to the
follow up yeah thank you Mr chairman
um I I guess what I was thinking about
more was
um the the
susceptibility that New Hampshire
um
uh gets exposed to or the issue the risk
that New Hampshire gets exposed to
um when there are uh dramatic shifts
such as what we're seeing right now in
the international markets where you know
Supply is a a challenge I mean Are we
more at risk because of our Mark our our
more Market oriented approach than other
states New England
so so right now I mean and that's a good
point um on the uh on sort of the
volatility that we might be exposed to
um what we've seen is that all all the
New England states are experiencing that
volatility a lot of the out of Market
um you know uh solutions that other
states have pursued for other policy
goals uh have sought attributes other
than reliability or cost they've been
more focused on either environmental
goals or Economic Development goals
um and and where the costs come in are
are sort of at those peak times you know
times during the winter uh where the
attributes uh that are are necessary for
reliability
um the resources that that are best able
to serve those are
um something that that each state still
has to procure so uh each state has has
had exposure to the uh volatility that
we've we've seen recently
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh quick question
for you now this is about reliability
um myself being from Texas known hugots
National Gas field is one of the largest
natural gas fields in the U.S and with
plentiful gas in Pennsylvania but the
tech the gas can get here from Texas
because the Jones act from what I
understand and Pennsylvania it's blocked
because of New York and Massachusetts
not allowing pipelines across their
states are we completely Reliant as of
right now from getting our LNG from West
Indies
all right uh yes yeah there have been uh
severe uh citing challenges and trying
to get
um natural gas pipeline capacity to New
England
um that's that's been continued that's
likely to continue
um there there is certainly not enough
uh infrastructure to make sure we have
the natural gas to meet the demands of a
system that is pretty reliant on natural
gas the Jones act does uh present a
hurdle
um you know there are no Jones act
compliant vessels that would allow us to
get American liquefied natural gas
um so our current right now I think it's
uh Trinidad and Tobago uh is is where we
get our natural gas but it has been a
foreign
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner for
being here today
um my question is about I'm listening to
you talk about these limitations but
um I can recall a time when we were
managing a portfolio pie that showed us
the various places that our energy was
divided up into and we had plans around
each of those sectors of the energy
economy if you will in order to lower
demand over time and so my question is
rather than being reactive does the
department have any positions around how
to be proactive in order to lower Peak
there we do have options for doing those
things and it doesn't have to be a
political position it could be more
economic keeping the dollars the energy
dollars in the state basically
um to allow people to do more with local
energy
sure
um so
as I'm sure you've seen in our tenure
State energy strategy
um it's technology neutral right we
believe that's important
um that state government doesn't favor
any one source of energy over another
um and that there are
a few barriers to that type of
development
um
you know we have an RPS which I'm sure
you're aware of and um you know I think
that um
you know from a policy standpoint uh if
you look at the 10-year State energy
strategy we focused on
technology being technology neutral
um cost effective energy sources
um one other challenge would be uh even
if we want to build
other types of generating Assets in New
Hampshire whether that be solar wind the
expansion of a of a gas pipeline those
are challenging in this environment and
even for us to pursue
um
those types of energy resources to split
that pie up more right or give us a more
diverse uh portfolio of energy resources
that would require
um
some streamlining of our citing process
um as a big part of that so
again I think if we can address some of
those issues that could help
um with development of those those
resources Mr chair me a follow-up
follow-up I I feel I feel like when you
were answering the commissioner that it
was sort of a chicken egg thing right
because there are aspects to the
operation that could be streamlined but
then there's also defining where you're
going to help figure out what the
streamlines are so I just would put that
out there is that my concern is that the
doe
not just identify items in the plan that
are our goals but also to maybe be a
little more ambitious about saying what
are we doing so that businesses and
everyone else can understand what the
state is pursuing representative I would
remind you and the other members of the
committee that were here to ask
questions to gather information and not
to debate or express our opinions yes
thank you I'm not trying to debate I I
think I just was trying to make the
point that the presentation that you
gave us seems more reactive than
proactive and I just want to okay you
made your point thank you
representative closure has a question
and thank you Mr chairman commissioner
in one of your slides you had mentioned
that amount of
production was taken offline to meet the
carbon reduction that we needed to do my
question is
the production that was taken offline
was it reliable and would it still be
online available if we did not have to
make the CO2 carbon reduction thank you
uh yeah thank you that's a very good
question
um so to clarify the the 7000 or so
megawatts that have gone offline or will
soon retire over the last 10 years
um that is in in most part been related
to economics the plants that are just no
longer economical uh in the market
um though those generation sources have
mostly been coal oil and nuclear
Generation
Um you know uh so they they are do tend
to have a higher reliability Factor
um
but but a lot of what's come offline has
been sort uh Gone offline because the
price of natural gas generation has
um made those resources less economical
representative Nutter has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um you didn't mention nuclear is there
any chance that we can bring that
reliable energy
so um with with deregulation right and
restructuring of of the market
um you know generating assets like
nuclear would either need to be a
merchant project or or the state would
need to
um essentially do a procurement to
incent that type of development here
um
you know I I would probably leave it
there we have Seabrook nuclear uh
station which is 1200 megawatts of
generating capacity
um
uh it would like every other
generating asset uh you would need uh
there would also be issues around citing
something like that so the same
challenge that applies to other types of
generation would apply to nuclear as
well
well thank you representative Douglas
Thomas has a question
uh thank you Mr chairman I um
I let me make a statement first uh to my
question but getting back to the nuclear
issue
um I believe that there is a commission
that we're going through right now uh
and I think the term nuclear uh
in what what we're thinking of in the
future is far far smaller and safer so
as the public not to get the idea that
the question was involving large
buildings of nuclear such as Seabrook
and so forth but getting back to my to
my question
um
I think New Hampshire has a lower
electricity rate than Massachusetts does
for its electricity given the current uh
rate request that just went in I think
by eversource in Massachusetts is New
Hampshire basically
um lower electrical rates and the rest
of New England or how does it compare to
the other New England states
so uh and this is something that I think
Tom Frantz will touch on sort of kind of
what goes into
um you know the bill there are different
parts of the bill uh right now we saw
that Massachusetts rates for um their
various Electric utilities have exceeded
what we've we currently have uh and and
um you know there will be some
reductions that go into effect soon for
uh New Hampshire repairs but Tom will
touch on a little bit of the differences
between
um you know the parts of the bill
uh I apologize for being ahead of myself
here yeah
well thank you uh Commissioners uh for
being here and making that presentation
to us uh I guess we can move on now to
good morning Mr Franz
good morning chairman Bose and members
of the committee
it's a pleasure to be here this morning
it's nice to see
some familiar faces and meet the new
faces of the committee
I'm Tom Frantz I'm the director of the
regulatory support group at the
and I'm going to at talk today about our
regulatory group who we are what we do
uh
commissioner chicoine gave a good
overview of that I'm going to dive a
little deeper but I'm still going to be
at a level that we're not going to go
real deep into the Weeds on regulatory
issues and and rate making uh but I do
want to discuss what we do
and and who
who are the key people that you may see
before you uh so I'm gonna first start
with the division regulatory
we're and I think I need to
images
okay
I'll just press over yeah there we go
so
we're division a small division
of Highly technical professionals with
very different backgrounds uh if you're
smart inquisitive uh like to ask
questions
like to dig deep into the details
and have a background in engineering
economics business math accounting
but
we'd love to talk to you it's the kind
of division that we we look for those
type of people because they are
analysts and and have that kind of
trust but verify mind
and so we have a sewer and water
division
so these are all subdivisions of
regulatory and of course gas and of
course electricity
and with me today are uh the directors
of the electric group as well as the gas
group Liz Nixon Dina riff
so what do we do
we basically looked at all regulatory
filings that go before the Public
Utilities Commission if it has to do
with rates we're going to review it
analyze it and make recommendations at
the puc
and and we will also uh as part of that
ask a lot of questions and a lot of
dockets are opened at the puc as you
well know if it has to do with rates it
has to go to the puc for approval to
change rates which are part of a tariff
so if a utility wants to change its
default service rate cost the gas rate
distribution rate
uh the Energy Efficiency rates all those
go and are filed by the utilities at the
Public Utilities Commission we get
copies of those filings we are a group
that will take a deep look at those
filings and participate fully at the
Public Utilities Commission in those
proceedings
so
lots of lots of proceedings as if you
looked at the public utilities
commission's website you'd see that over
a course of a year there are hundreds of
open dockets
and probably 60 to 70 percent of them
are electric another 20 25
are probably gas and and then water and
and Sewer
so mergers and Acquisitions lease cost
plans
and then of course uh rate cases which
are massive dockets and we seem to have
one or two of those a year those are all
filings that we will participate in
fully and by fully also I mean that we
will
uh ultimately for many of these
proceedings and all the big proceedings
file testimony pre-filed testimony
and then testify
at at the hearing on on the issues
so
and Regulatory also supports
other divisions within the department of
energy
as well as works with groups and state
agencies
other state agencies
so if you have questions as I go feel
free to just jump in and ask them I'm
happy to go
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question
thank you thank you Mr chair can't see
you but um I'm over here
um I I just want a clarification on the
Water and Sewer are you at all concerned
with biosolids or is this simply rates
concerned with biosolids in water and
and Sewer or is this just rates uh
mostly it's economic regulation yes the
reg the environmental regulation
obviously affects the overall
determination of what is a used and
useful or prudently incurred uh rate
that customers will pay so
if if it's but we don't mandate we're
not the environmental Regulators we are
first and foremost economic Regulators
uh quick overview yes representative
representative McGee has a question how
are you Mr France fine thank you good to
see you
um so my question was whether your group
it sounds like you're a group of subject
matter experts so you're providing uh
input to the public utilities
Commissioners and I was wondering if the
recent uh docket that was resolved on
the value of distributed energy if that
was something that your office was
involved with creating economics on or
our group was involved with it but uh it
was actually led by someone you'll see a
little later Deandra okay so and you're
going to talk about value Dr
so
well and and we can chat about it too
so uh back to a quick overview of the
regulated Gas Utilities in New Hampshire
for those who are weren't uh been here
before you know this but perhaps the new
members don't we have two regulated Gas
Utilities in New Hampshire uh
Energy North
and and Northern northern's an affiliate
subsidiary of Unitil and Energy North
with Liberty Utilities and you can see
their service distribution area is
basically the areas that are highly
populated in the state of New Hampshire
the Merrimack Valley Corridor and then
the Seacoast are the areas where gas is
uh where there's a pipeline has been
built out deliveries there so Energy
North is a larger gas utility in the
state it's about ninety six thousand
total customers and northern's about one
about one-third of that
so
uh still major industry
one thing I want to mention about gas is
that the utilities purchase long-term
contracts for gas and that has an effect
on electric rates
uh as as some of you know
the priority for
gas first goes to those who are
contracted for it and then the energy
generators that use
natural gas the combined cycle plants
that make up a large group of of New
England
for the most part they buy off the spot
market so in fact gas is already
contracted for they don't have gas
available in the really cold days to
generate electricity so I just want to
that's a high level overview of the gas
electric
interconnection in New England and it's
an important one because those
contracts provide for heating and for
for the customers of the of the retail
Gas Utilities
but that makes less gas available than
and then a similar
slide for electricity
we have four franchised electric
distribution companies
the largest of course is eversource
as we know Public Service of New
Hampshire
then of course Unitil Liberty and the
co-op which is minimally regulated uh in
the state of New Hampshire
it's a member owned cooperative and it
can change rates basically overnight
without coming to the Public Utilities
Commission depending on what kind of
rate that is that it's changing but it
doesn't come to the puc for changes in
default service doesn't come to the to
the puc for changes in distribution
rates it does have some regulation with
uh stranded costs and with Energy
Efficiency though
we have five municipal
Utilities in New Hampshire also and this
is a big business
I kind of like to put these numbers in
there utility regulation touches
everybody in the state and it is a very
significant economic business for New
Hampshire
we have
1.9 billion dollars of annual retail
sales
uh
a lot of megawatt hours are sold
and
everybody's happy if the rates are low
and the lights always stay on and
everyone gets upset quickly when the
rates go up and the lights go off so uh
and that is nothing new to anyone in
this room
so how do we regulate
what do we do
what is the basis for it
uh I'm sure others perhaps Mr crease
will talk about the legal issues
associated with regulation
but
at the heart and I'll just mention them
quickly uh
utilities
must
and we look at this make that their
Investments are prudently incurred and
that they are used and useful those are
really nice words that come from the
courts but uh we take them seriously and
we look at all the costs when they come
in and ask for a rate increase we look
at their Capital costs we look at their
expenses we look at what they're
spending it on if it could have been
lower and so all that gets thrown
together in what we call determining the
revenue requirement and the revenue
requirement is a very simple formula
with a lot of details and about a foot
of
information that goes behind it
so the Reverend um yes
I keep forgetting so the revenue
requirement basically we look at the O M
costs
and then depreciation amortization
depreciation of poles wires conductor
things like that
and then of course taxes are thrown in
there
and then one of the highly controversial
aspects of any Revenue requirement in
the rate case is the return on
investment
and the returns basically the overall
cost of capital which is a combination
of the cost of debt short term and long
term
uh that's pretty straightforward they
have to file
at the puc
for an approval of a financing for for
debt issuance so that's well known uh
but also then the return on Equity what
should investors get for their return on
on this company's
operations and profit and that is always
controversial so
we've in New Hampshire always we have
always been
in the lower end of that return on
Equity range although most people think
it's still way too high if you ask
someone uh but it's not just pulled out
of the air there's a lot of economic
theory that goes into determining the
return on equity and we uh
have a lot of decisions to make on that
and I won't get into the details but
we've approved return on equities over
the last
literally 20 years that have been lower
and
and currently are in the low high eighth
very high eighths to load to uh middle
nine percent return on equities
now I want to mention something that I
hear a lot and I want to correct it
that's not a guaranteed return
it's a return that is reasonable at the
time based on the economic conditions in
the markets and that they have the
opportunity to re to actually earn that
return but it's by no means guaranteed
uh representative Doug Thomas has a
question for you yes representative yeah
thank you Mr friends thank you for
coming back here I always enjoyed your
presentations and thank you testimonies
um so I'm a little bit confused now uh
when you say that the return on
investment is not guaranteed
and the utilities are regulated so could
you just go and maybe dive with just a
little bit deeper into what you mean by
that and but isn't there some isn't
there some rate of return that they
expect to get because being regulated
that's why some people invest in these
companies because they can they can
almost get a certain an expectation of a
certain rate of return uh you use the
key word there representative Thomas
expectation yeah expectation versus
guarantee
and and that's the key so at the time
the utility makes the filing
they'll have a certain level of Revenue
they'll look at what their costs are uh
all the aspects I had in that Revenue
requirement formula and then they'll
file that and say this is what we should
get we're at 100 right now we think that
we need a 10 increase that's 110 for our
Revenue requirement and it's based on
all these all these costs the capital
and then the depreciation rates but the
return we expect should be let's say 10
percent
and
we'll look at it and we might fight over
it and argue about it and finally settle
on some number but once we settle on
that number in the revenue requirement
things change
you know at that time that's a
reasonable expectation of what they
should earn
and it's
certainly transmitted to the markets to
Wall Street to investment firms everyone
covers those things but
conditions change
they may not be in for a new rate case
and change the return on equity for
another two three four five years and so
they may
have costs that go up
they may see market conditions that for
sales that decrease or they could go the
other way and they could have higher
returns we still monitor that we have
them file with us we look at it on a
quarterly basis so we want to make sure
that it's reasonable that it stays
within that that
reasonable Bend because we know it's
going to fluctuate weather will make it
fluctuate uh economic conditions a
recession could make it fluctuate all
kinds of things can change that actual
return versus the expectation of that
return
and and if it gets too low uh
they may come in earlier than we
anticipate and if it gets maybe too high
some phone calls are made and said we're
looking at this return and we may call
you in to lower your rates because your
return is too high based on what it was
approved or the market conditions that
existed at the time
does that help yes follow up thank you
the
on a private a firm that's not being
in an industry that's not being
regulated uh their rate of return could
be much higher depending on how well
they do and the economy in this type of
Industry then
um there's probably a certain range that
that they're not going to go above like
you wouldn't expect them to get 15 20
rate of return uh just because they're
regulated and because of how they affect
the public and the rates and so forth so
isn't there something I'm here I know
isn't there something today expectation
that there is a just a narrow range that
they can go up up and down excellent uh
yes and
there's an incredible amount of
arguments and fighting and discussion
about what that range should be but in
general for a regulated utilities
the range for the return on equity
currently is between about
8.4 percent and probably 9.6 percent
representative
Summers
thank you Mr chairman a quick question
for you on the the graph that you had
and thank you for providing this
um with my constituents seeing their
electrical rates go from Seven cents per
kilowatt back in last March to now where
it's over 25 26 Cents more than tripling
over the last year
um is this 100 caused by the default
energy cost ah
yes I mean we've had some other changes
but by far the key driver of the large
increase in electric bills
is is the change in default Energy
service and I'm going to spend some time
on on why that is and how how it's
the commissioner and Deputy Commissioner
mentioned they talked about the
wholesale markets they talked about gas
prices LNG those are all the obviously
Ukraine Russia War those are all
affecting these wholesale markets and
the wholesale markets then affect the
retail markets so I'm actually going to
get get into that but when you look at
this chart and you see how large that
one part of the pie is for default
Energy service and that this is a
typical 625 kilowatt hour eversource
customer residential paying now 141
dollars just for that energy not not for
the delivery of it not for the
transmission and distribution the
delivery part of it not the trading
costs some other things have gone up by
50 cents or a dollar or two dollars you
know but this this piece actually
uh depending on how far back you go a
year ago it was it was in in the eight
to ten Cent range a year and a half to
two years ago and the bill itself was
about a hundred and
ten to twenty dollars two years ago
and almost all of that's driven for the
most part by the massive increase in
default service
representative Reynolds has a question
yes thank you Mr chairman
um earlier the commissioner made a point
of
saying that New Hampshire among all New
England states was the most Market
oriented
our system our rules the most Market
oriented would you say that
looking at the graph and that recent
explosion of of retail rates is that
translate to making New Hampshire's
customers the most vulnerable to Market
fluctuations and the price
of the energy that supports our system
so
customers
are affected by these wholesale markets
and and so let me take you back if I may
for just quickly to talk about what it
was like before we restructured the
electricity markets
because that's important to this
question
um I'll do it very quickly so
for most of the history of regulation of
of utilities and electricity
it was what we called vertical
integration the generation the
transmission the distribution we're all
owned by one company
um
the transmission was regulated by the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission as
it still is
but distribution and generation were
regulated by the state commissions
and the utilities either purchase power
through long-term contracts with
companies that own generation
at at prices that were then
uh approved by commissions
and and or they owned the actual
Hardware
the actual generating plants and a great
example of that of course in New
Hampshire was Public Service Company in
New Hampshire owned a lot of the
generating plants in the state
Merrimack station
owned a large piece of Seabrook
uh Newington Chiller and we essentially
set the rates for generation
as restructuring came about and the idea
was that these are there's no Monopoly
in generation other companies can run
these plants they can do it perhaps
better cheaper more efficient and more
importantly the risk would be on those
generators those owners
now that sounds simple and it sounded
pretty good and New Hampshire was one of
the first states to actually move to
deregulate the generating plants uh and
make them competitive and we divested
for the most part A lot of it back in
the late 90s and early 2000s
but
there was some stability to owning
generation there's no question about
that those plants were not those prices
weren't set by the market they were
regulated based on a cost of service
model
and there was stability to that the
problem was
they were also perhaps not as well run
perhaps as a market would be not quite
as efficient
and was very much out of step with most
of New England that had divested all its
generation
and so over time we'd finally finished
the visitor of New Hampshire's
generating Assets in 2017 early 18 with
the sale of the remaining fossil hydro
plants that PSNH owned
and if you
this will be illustrated by the
differences so when the wholesale market
prices in New England were low as they
were for much of uh
the 2000
sixth well actually even before this
slide going back to 2000 five six seven
with low gas prices and then
then there was a polar vortex where you
see the big increase in around January
of
2015 that's the wholesale markets
reacting to cold weather and difficult
getting gas
and they reflect it quickly in the
market a very efficient market and it
indicates
how that market Moves In step with
weather and and
natural gas and LNG prices
but the yellow line pretty much goes you
know
straight across and that was ever
sources
cost of default service because almost
all of that was based on their
generating assets they did purchase from
the market but that was mostly their
generating assets and for quite a while
it looked like it would stay much higher
than actually the purchases for the
market
so you see the yellow line above
the problem with that was because more
and more customers would leave default
service for eversource and go to what we
call third-party competitive energy
suppliers
and that's the retail aspect they don't
have to stay with the default service
customer we have
companies out there that will sell and
you don't have to stay with your default
service utility
that just makes it even more difficult
to recover those costs from fewer and
fewer customers
so we divested it was this it was a
state decision I was part of the
divestiture team there's other people
here that I've seen that are also key
members of the divestiture team and the
fossil hydros assets for PSNH were sold
and after they were sold
eversource then became like Unitil and
like Liberty and really like the co-op
they solicit power
uh entrances every six months and so
they go out to the wholesale Market
their wholesale Market participants who
bid on it and they take the risk of the
sales they take the risk of the quantity
they take the weather risk the fuel risk
and so
uh sometimes most of the time
it's
less than what it would have been if
PSNH eversource had kept those assets
today's probably not one of those times
but the risk belongs with those
suppliers with the folks that that bid
on default service and that's probably
where it belongs and and I think it's a
model that overall works I think we see
the efficiency as far as markets because
when when input prices change the their
prices change so customers certainly see
and right now it's high as you can see
it's not as high as it is in
Massachusetts or potentially in
Connecticut but these are markets across
all New England and so uh we're not
immune we share a lot of the same pain
and we share a lot of the same benefit
it also depends on when you go out to
get default service and by the way the
Public Utilities Commission has a docket
open on procuring default service and
and whether it should be changed in one
way or another and we're actually
looking at it too uh our group and
Regulatory had a really nice
presentation from a consulting firm
about descending clock auctions instead
of sealed bids and things like that but
but so we're always trying to see is
there a better way to get it uh just a
little bit
cheaper
representative munz has a question for
you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
friends
um
you talk about the risk being
transferred to the um
the distribution companies the ever
sources of the world yeah but is there
the risk for default service that energy
piece right being transferred to a third
party bidder for default service but is
it really transferred to them because
don't the rate payers ultimately absorb
the cost well they absorbed the price
that's actually uh been approved by the
commission and and that was submitted by
the bidder and so there are bidders out
there that get a nice little packet from
all the utilities every six months that
says we are looking for uh
six months of power
and you take you essentially take the
those risks and then they
they bid on that and say well I'll
based on
gas prices based on my weather
forecasting folks back in Houston and
somewhere else and I'll bid you know 22
cents right now for the next six months
power now they may make
some real money on on that six months at
22 cents if they are well hedged and
prices go down or something like that
but if a large customer leaves or a
number of customers leave or if the
weather is really bad and their prices
go high that price doesn't change for
the customers that default service price
is locked in it's fixed and and it and
it goes forward so
I guess it it's a little bit like you
know what do you mean by the risk well
they the the wholesale supplier takes
two types of
risk when they bid and and are selected
they take a quantity risk that they
expect let's say the
it's about three million megawatt hours
for the first six months that of
eversource so they're going to supply
all the power that's needed
and if that power is a lot higher and
and it goes up 10 because a really cold
winter
they're going to have to sell more
megawatt hours but they're going to have
to find those megawatt hours and they're
going to have to still Supply it at the
price it's been approved
or if a large customer leaves now
they're going to have to uh or if a lot
of uh the weather is really warm they
may have Excess power that they now
won't be able to sell in default service
that they'll have to find a customer for
or a number of customers in the market
then then sell that Excess power
which may be at a lower price than they
had expected from the default service so
when I say risk they're taking a
quantity and a price risk for that
thank you continue on please I I will
I'll try to speed this up so as I
mentioned you don't have to stay with
your default service supplier you don't
have to stay with ever source and get
the power for those prices that are
approved by the puc
um
you can go to a competitive energy
Supply
supplier and we have a number of them
that are registered uh in New Hampshire
and you can go to the website there and
check out prices and a lot of people do
the large commercial industrial
customers moved away from default
service to competitive suppliers early
on and have stayed there there's there's
you can see that in this
especially in the next slide
where you can see that for the cni class
for eversource 87 percent are with a
competitive supplier
but only 17 percent of residential
customers
the nurse is a tough thing so but with
these higher prices I think we're seeing
that it's increased somewhat there were
uh there was a lot of discussion just
even three four months ago that you
could get a 14 15
maybe 16 Cent rate which is certainly
lower than the default service rate and
so customers you know to the extent we
let them know that and and others do
representative Harrington has a question
for you thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question Tom just right on
that subject I've run into it personally
trying to educate people on this and I'm
wondering if the department has any type
of an outreach program you try to tell
people go to a competitive supplier and
I was trying to tell people when they
were getting 12 cents and every Source
was 23 cents and there's this built in
fear that somehow they're going to if
they lose electricity no one will come
and fix the wires uh that they they
won't they'll have to get multiple bills
and there'll be no one to call if they
have a problem and how do we get over
that is is a department have some type
of a like web page or some kind of
Outreach to people so that they can uh
be more uh you know be assured that
that's they think they're taking this
big risk and there's no risk at all no
you're right and and the men in newnan's
worked on this for years and years and
years and has done a great job of trying
to educate customers and and get over
the get them over the hump this fear of
that if I switch from my default Service
Company they're not going to come fix
the wires we can always probably do more
there's a whole list of discussions
about that and and you can click on that
and and there's questions and answers
um
helps reassure them for some of their
questions Ms Noonan we can't really hear
you so I'm going to ask you to come up
foreign
I could speak loudly enough for you all
to hear me
um what I just wanted to say is you all
feel please feel free to direct any
constituent calls to the Department of
energy My Team Works closely with
customers regularly I can hear them on
the phone walking people through the web
pages the prices what to look for what
to consider before they make a choice of
an energy supplier reassuring them to
representative Harrington's point that
choosing a competitive supplier doesn't
mean you leave your utility that they're
not going to restore your service that
you're going to have outages that you
wouldn't otherwise have so please feel
free to refer folks there we do have a
lot of information on our website and
it's up to folks to go in and read that
if they want but they can always call
and my folks will walk them through all
of that
so thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
friends uh I live in Lebanon and we are
going to be having Community power
relatively soon I'm in the 94 percent of
Liberty residential customers still on
default service do you have any idea as
to what sort of change we're going to be
well the promise of community power is
that you'll see lower rates
um
there's other
benefits reported also I I really can't
answer that I think that's going to
depend on when you go out to the market
who you get how long the contracts are
uh
so I probably say the best person to
talk to up there is is Cliff Clifton
below
and certainly in knowledgeable person
about Community power
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um in this chart
um do you have any specific numbers for
municipalities
or is that absorbed in another category
oh on the percent that have switched to
competitive suppliers yes yes I don't
have it broken down by community
and and we don't get the data that way I
I guess we could ask for it but we
essentially get it by residential
commercial industrial customers okay
thank you representative uh Reynolds has
a question also well actually Mr
chairman it's kind of a question for you
my my colleagues mention of community
power
which is a significant development in
the in this world that we're discussing
this morning
um
it brings up in my mind a request
apparently since we've had to reschedule
the public utilities
commissions presentation to us would it
be possible to include on that perhaps
on that rescheduled day a briefing from
someone representing the community power
perhaps Clifton below himself and an
expert so that we could understand how
that significant development is going to
affect you know what we're doing yes
that's an excellent idea I will make
sure that that happens thank you thank
you
um
mindful of the
speakers that are still to come from the
Department of energy as well as from The
Office of Consumer Advocates so I just
only have one more slide it's a overview
slide of Energy Efficiency which is
always a major topic and of interest for
this committee it just really gives a
detail of the history recently in in the
Energy Efficiency world as we moved away
from an Energy Efficiency resource
standard to an Energy Efficiency charge
uh I will say that the most important
aspect of that is that a new three-year
plan will be filed by the utilities
okay thank you very much Mr Franz good
to see you again and see you thank you
appreciate you taking our questions
and next from the Department of energy
is
good morning Mr chairman uh members of
the committee for the record uh Josh
Elliott I am the director of the
division of policy and programs at the
department of energy
um I do realize that we have a couple of
other speakers left and it is already
quarter after 11. um I know you've had
the rescheduled for the Public Utilities
Commission so I just wanted to offer if
the need be
um to the termination of the committee
if they'd like us to come back after
lunch we can continue the presentation
if we find we are running short on time
by the time we hit 12 o'clock
thank you thank you for that offer we'll
have to negotiate that with the consumer
Advocate but he's been very flexible so
far so I think we can probably work
something out
fair enough
um so the division of policy and
programs has a wide policy portfolio as
you can see on your screen here um the
have the staff that work on the regional
market issues which I know we've
discussed in detail we also have the
office of offshore wind industry
development uh sustainable energy office
fuel assistance program the
weatherization assistance program the
electric assistance program which we
participate sort of a halfway in between
if you will we also manage the emergency
benefits uh program that was established
by the legislature in the last session
in House Bill 2023
we also have the consumer Services Group
which Amanda Noonan has previously
mentioned runs and then the state energy
program that Griffin Roberge runs as
well as some of the federal funding
coming through the bil or and the IRA
so Regional markets I'll just leave this
slide up I know we've discussed this
extensively and I know we're short on
time so I'll just continue on here but
um again we're the staff look to ensure
the interests of New Hampshire rate
payers are being protected at the
regional level
uh the next one this is a very popular
topic uh the development of offshore
wind in the Gulf of Maine
we have been tasked with the uh having
the office of offshore wind industry
development
um so we have one person in there
currently and she works with either
other state agencies primarily Des Bea
fish and game as well as our federal
counterparts um and other interested
constituency groups whether it's labor
organizations Fisheries Etc
um on working through this offshore wind
process as you can imagine it's very
very complicated I'm dealing with lease
areas out in the Gulf of Maine dealing
with various different constituency
groups you have to make sure that
certain Environmental Protections are
taken into place you know you're not
going to have these wind turbines cited
in um
travel lanes for shipping or in
particular uh sensitive environmental
areas so as you may know Gulf of Maine
is very attractive for offshore wind in
the case of it has very high wind speeds
off the coast very high consistent wind
speeds which is good for electric
generation the drawback is the waters
are very deep so you can't actually put
a pylon onto the surface of the ocean
floor like you would off sort of say the
Long Island Sounder of Martha's Vineyard
so you need floating technology which is
still being worked on to being developed
which adds some additional complications
sorry Mr chairman have a quick question
from representative Harrington but thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question while we're speaking of
offshore window I wonder if you could
update us on what's going on with the
Massachusetts projects because they have
active offshore wind projects I
understand that the prices are being
renegotiated this talk about delays due
to supply chain problems and can you
just give us an update on where that's
at now because it's an active one being
built yes sure um so I can provide just
a little bit of overview of that and I
can get you a more detailed answer
afterwards um as you may be aware
um they have gone out
um
I believe it's Avant grid and I
apologize if I have the the name of the
company incorrect for several of these
offshore wind uh turbine facilities
um off the coast of Massachusetts
um there were ppas in place purchased
power agreements to
um uh buy various utilities to acquire
this
um electricity generated by these
offshore wind farms one of the
developers came back through the
Massachusetts Department of Public
Utilities Commission process essentially
saying that the guaranteed PPA rate
wasn't enough for to make the project
economically viable
um there were some negotiations went
back and forth um essentially the dpu
down there said uh either you go forward
or you don't um so the project is going
forward however I remain skeptical that
it actually Will based on the developer
saying that they can't make any money
doing it so I don't know what the next
PATH forward is for that developer if
they sell their interest in the project
um if they find some other means of
getting out of the project I'm I'm not
privy to what their uh their path
okay continue please
oh
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman this is actually
to follow up or fall Tale on
representative herring's question
um my understanding is
well I actually have a question about
why are they looking to negate or uh
remove uh offshore
um and Nantucket Sound I know that's
ties in Massachusetts as well but I know
nantucket's looking to negate it or
removed as well
in terms of do you mean that to remove
it as a as a potential lease area or
trying to get out of the
um
the purchase power agreement trying to
get out of the purchase power agreement
yeah um oh I'm sorry my understanding is
purely economical if the the developers
looked at the uh the math based on what
they expect from revenue from the PPA
versus how much they expect to actually
develop this offshore wind farm and they
don't think it's economically viable
anymore so it's the high cost of it
correct yes yes that's my from the
developer's point of view again I'm not
an expert on what's going on in
representative McGee has a question as
well thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Elliott for being here today my
question is back in New Hampshire
um you mentioned that there was one
person in the office and it sounds like
it's a very complex thing to undertake
this successfully so is there any plan
to expand based on the work that's
required or is this person so competent
that they're going to be able to handle
it so um we have uh Erica horn um she
has a tremendous amount of expertise
actually she's used to work for the
ports with Naval Shipyard so she's very
familiar with Maritime issues
um where we are currently at in the
process in terms of developing offshore
wind we feel confident that having the
the one staff person
um is is sufficient for now if that
changes of course we'll be here
um to make that need uh known thank you
thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um how does this re uh the developments
in the offshore wind relate to the
current highest ever
um
rates would seem are they basically
ignoring that or even at these rates can
they not make money
I would say I don't know all of the math
that has gone into
the developers decision to pull out of
that PPA so I I they have cited uh
inflationary costs and other costs in
developing offshore wind I can't speak
to the specifics of how they came to the
conclusion of why they came to the
conclusion even given that the with the
current high cost of electricity
okay
continue please
um next slide are sustainable energy so
the department also uh and the division
I should say uh manages the uh oversight
of the compliance of the renewable
portfolio standards so in statute
there's a requirement that both the
provider's electricity I.E the electric
distribution utilities as well as the
competitive suppliers procure a certain
percentage of their electricity from
certain renewable resources those are
class one which um it's a sort of
various different types of sources
including wind Class 2 which is solar
class 3 which is biomass and class 4
which is small scale Hydra so all those
combined come to 24 in 2022 will come to
22.5 percent of the um total so there is
uh and I should say um uh one of my
colleagues Deandra peruccio who runs the
sustainable energy group um some of you
may remember Karen Crampton she is the
new Karen Crampton if you will
um we'll go into more detail about this
but this is just sort of an overview and
then she'll she'll dive into the details
um so the way that the uh the energy
suppliers can comply with renewable
portfolio standards is they can do one
of two things they can purchase or
acquire which are called renewable
energy certificates so essentially it's
the renewable attributes of energy
generation
so they can do that they then retire
those certificates which then count
towards their RPS compliance they can
also
um do what is called an ACP or
alternative compliance payment if they
are unable or unwilling
um to acquire renewable energy
certificates they can essentially make a
penalty payment for lack of a better way
of putting it to the state in order to
make up for those renewable energy
certificates they weren't able to
acquire the rate for acps is to set in
statute while and then indexed for
inflation
um Rex renewable energy certificates
um there's an open market for those so
there are market prices that will drive
those
um prices either higher or lower
depending on supply and demand and
availability
um so where I'll do all those ACP
payments that come in go so they go into
which we have is the renewable energy
fund so these are funded through those
alternative compliance payments and they
go to provide for a myriad of different
resources but mostly they go back out to
rate pairs in the form of Grant programs
so we have two rebate programs
um actually gives me two residential
rebate programs two commercial rebate
programs as well as two competitive
Grant programs
um you can also oversee net metering
which I know in the interest of time I
know Deandra can get into the more
details I know that is a common uh
subject before your committee and she
can do a much better job of explain it
than I can so
uh next uh just a brief overview of the
assistance programs that are run by the
department uh Amanda Noonan who runs
consumer will be up here to go into a
little bit more detail but essentially
we have a number you can see that those
Assistance programs on the screen
whether it's for fuel assistance whether
it's for weatherization assistance
whether it's for electric Assistance or
it's for these new um emergency benefit
programs that were established by the
legislature
the most important takeaway for this is
if you have constituents or your
colleagues have constituents and they're
looking for help on these areas I know
with the price of electricity price of
fuel home feeding oils are very high
contact your local Community Action
Agency so they're broken up by County
Amanda Noonan we'll go into a little bit
more detail but that is the best place
that they can go in order to get help
there's one intake process they figure
out where they're supposed to go which
programs they are
um which programs that they're eligible
for and if they meet the income
requirements but it's
um essentially it's up to 60 percent of
Stadium median and income for the
regular programs and then it's 60 to 75
percent for the uh new emergency
programs
representative Doug Thomas has a
question uh thank you and uh thank you
for taking my question so just what you
just said so in other words the the
Community Action
um agencies they actually do the leg
work to to find out who qualifies before
they come to you yes so we are um they
they function as the subgrantees so we
receive the the money from the federal
government either it's from HHS or doe
um the we then subcontract out with the
Community Action agencies who then do
all of the intake work so they will get
folks who will come in they offer a
variety of other services other than
just these but they have a lot of those
touch points with this sort of the same
um
population so as they come in they can
say okay you were only interested in
this okay we can also you know you can
you're eligible for these programs if
you're interested they could always
decline if they're not but
um they act as a subgrantee so we don't
have any interaction necessarily
directly with the
um folks coming in to apply for these
programs that's all done at the
Community Action Agency or they're also
okay continue thank you
so uh consumer services again um Amanda
Noonan uh runs this group they help
assist consumers dealing with regulated
utilities as you can imagine trying to
call a utility might be a bit of a
daunting task or trying to set up a
payment plan things like that if
someone's behind on their bills
um they can uh she has a very capable
staff down there who know all the folks
the utilities they can help the
consumers to get the best possible
outcome
as they're dealing with utilities they
also as we mentioned earlier help
provide some education experience uh
resources for
consumers uh competitive suppliers a
perfect example of that there's a lot of
information available on our website
about what to think about as your may or
may not be going uh over to a
competitive supplier how you may want to
do that and lastly and again this is
sort of very broad overview but they
also participate in the regulatory
processes that Tom Franz mentioned
earlier to make sure that there are
certain things for the consumer that are
taken into account when maybe new
methods or new processes are being
considered as part of the
uh utilities uh regular course of
business
finally this is a very hot topic Federal
funding for the Department So currently
we have our standard program which is
sap State energy program that Griffin
Roberge who will come to know and love
if you don't already manages we uh part
of that money pays for staff at goe uh
New Hampshire doe we also run our seed
program which provides grants to school
districts to do Energy Efficiency
projects
I also do the 10-year State energy
strategy which given our time here I'm
not sure if I'm going to be able to go
into detail but I'm always happy to come
back the two biggest things in terms of
the federal funding that we're looking
at um is the bipartisan infrastructure
law it's either referred to as the bil
or the iija they're both the same thing
as well as the inflation reduction actor
the IRA Griffin is going to go into more
detail about the specific programs for
each of these but I realized that there
I've heard that there's a rumor out here
that we are the New Hampshire doe is not
going after some of the home of Energy
Efficiency rebate programs that are
provided for in the ira I can tell you
that is not true we are going after
those funds
um not sure where the rumor started but
I can assure you those are formula funds
and we're going after those funds
um speaking of formula funds would be a
good point to discuss the difference
between formula and competitive funds
that are coming through these both of
these bills formula funds essentially
there's a formula at the federal level
that determines the allocation that each
state will get or in some cases counties
or or individual local government units
um essentially the federal government
has said based on population various
Myriad of other factors New Hampshire is
eligible for this amount you can apply
for it if you want to you don't have to
but you really should so those are
formula funds there's an application
process we have to make sure that our
application conforms with the guidance
that's provided by the federal
government
we then apply for the funds and then we
in theory if the application is accepted
we then receive those funds and then we
go through the regular State processes
whether it's governor and Council on
fiscal approval to accept and expend
those funds there are others that are
competitively awarded and usually for a
specific type of project whether it's
the hydrogen hubs or if it's carbon
sequestration
um you know those will come um uh
probably further down in the line in
terms of uh when they'll be noticed for
availability for funding
um just in terms of the processes um it
is a very long drawn out process if you
imagine usdoe has got a lot of programs
to set out in a very short amount of
time with
um not a lot of staff to do it so
they're uh
um they're trying their best
um and we are we're working through
those processes
very good uh representative Harrington
has a question for you thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question you mentioned the hydrogen hubs
I've been seeing that there's been some
activity with some other states I think
Wyoming was one of them to try to work
with other states to come up with a uh a
a proposal to get one of these hydrogen
hubs because there's literally hundreds
of millions of dollars involved is there
any type of movement in New England to
do something like that uh yes so there's
a regional one right now it's headed up
by New York
um they're looking at a couple of states
in the Mid-Atlantic as well as New
England um to be part of a regional
hydrogen hub
so New Hampshire would be part of that
then oh possibly I need to be careful
about how I talk about this but we are
well looking through the uh the rest of
the handout that you uh the department
gave us earlier it looks to me as if I
should have devoted the entire day today
to the Department of energy rather than
just two hours
and we have about
28 minutes left until our traditional
lunch break so I'm going to suggest that
we do the net metering component and
then come back after lunch and do the
rest of the components of your
presentation is that acceptable to the
department I'm going to look to the
people behind me who have to also press
and present okay I'm getting thumbs up
yes okay
Mr crease is that acceptable to the
thank you but that's what we'll do then
we'll have
a presentation on net metering then we
will take a lunch break and we'll come
back for the rest of the presentations
uh in the handout so thank you very much
perfect thank you Mr chairman um and
then with me is uh Deandra perusio who
runs the sustainable energy group
um oh um so I will let her take over
from here
morning
thanks
uh so yeah some of you may have known
Karen Crampton uh who's moved on those
are big shoes to Phil she was a very
knowledgeable resource I'm sure uh I was
an analyst under her and I've stepped up
into the position as the administrator
for the sustainable team
so in coordination with the regulatory
division consumer affairs we are
responsible for implementing
uh some of the rsas including net
metering and the renewable portfolio
standard so we're gonna focus on net
metering first I'm I'm gonna go pretty
slow on a very basic understanding so I
apologize for folks who this may you may
already know all of this but it'll be
hopefully a good reminder
so net metering how does that work
you're basically putting some solar
panels on your home technically this can
be any distributed generation resource
mostly in the state we see a lot of
solar especially at the residential
scale
those that that generator is creating
energy at your home or business that's
then converted from the panels uh to the
the type of power that your house uses
if your house is using power at the time
that generation is occurring or your
business is using power at the time that
generation is occurring the power will
be used by you know you have a TV on
you're running a washing machine that is
behind the meter usage so that power is
never seen by the the electric grid it
gets basically used on site and is is
behind the meter usage if however you're
not home and you're you're you know it's
a sunny day and your system is producing
a lot of energy that excess generation
if you are eligible to net meter in New
Hampshire if you meet the requirements
to interconnect to the electric grid
that power is then uh exported back out
onto the electric grid and that is net
metering that is um for systems in New
Hampshire up to one megawatt you're
allowed to net meter in New Hampshire
and partake of this particular tariff
although it also five megawatts of your
Municipal group host and we'll talk in a
little bit more detail about how that
works but General customers one megawatt
is the capacity limit
there are two different types of
customer generators so there's a large
customer generator and these are defined
in the statute large customer generators
and small customer generators small
customer generators or any any systems
up to 100 KW in size a typical home
system we're seeing like 10 KW or so so
this would small customer generators
could be both residents and then you
know businesses up to 100 KW
and they have a specific tariff in place
uh if you think back to Tom's slide of
the different portions on your electric
bill
this slide here goes over which portions
uh of those credits are eligible for
customers that are exporting excess
generation
so one important point is that for
four net metering this only covers
volumetric charges so it's it's kwh
charges so you're not you're not
avoiding a customer charge or if you're
a business you're not avoiding a demand
charge you can't avoid those through
that net metering
for small customer generators
oh and the other important piece here
you'll see that there's an M1 the
standard net metering tariff and M2
which is the alternative tariff the
standard Tariff was in place when the
net metering was put in into statute
originally there was since that occurred
there's been a docket that reviewed the
Tariff the Tariff was changed by the
commission 2016.
so the alternative tariff is the Tariff
that went into place starting September
1 2017 so any systems that are going
online as of September 1 2017 are under
this alternative net metering tariffs
that's what I'm focusing on it's you
know new systems coming online since
2017.
and oh so sorry to those customers those
small customer generators are eligible
to receive 100 of the energy Supply
portion so if you think back to Tom's
chart that was you know the bulk it's
typically the largest portion of your
bill so uh folks are compensated 100 for
that
25 of the distribution portion of your
bill uh and then 100 of the transmission
there is a set of costs referred to as
non-by-passable charges uh customer
generators are not compensated if they
export power they are not compensated
for non-bypassable charges and they also
pay
uh the costs of non-bypassable chargers
for all power that they import from the
grid
one big difference between the standard
tariff and the alternative tariff a
change that occurred there was a
previously credits were kept on people's
bill as a kwh credit and carried forward
month to month credits now under the 27
2017 and on under the alternative tariff
are calculated each month as a monetary
credit based on this tariff So based on
these percentages they calculate if you
did export how much was exported times
these values and you get an actual
monetary credit on your bill that then
carries forward throughout the year you
have an option to cash that out once per
year as long as that credit on your bill
is over one hundred dollars
so those that small the tariffer small
customer generators
and then we have large customer
generators so these are systems anything
over 100 KW and up to a megawatt except
for the new Municipal group hosts can be
up to five megawatts but all of those
facilities would be considered large
customer generators and fall under this
tariff one important item to note is
that for large customer generators in
New Hampshire if you are not you you
have to use 20 of your power behind the
meter so on site like I was describing
at the facility or you are required to
become a group to be eligible to net
meter in New Hampshire so you either
have to use 20 percent of that power
behind the meter or you have to register
as a group and act as a group host and
for these generators and potentially
groups the credit the Tariff is the the
energy Supply portion
so they receive just that portion of
credit for uh compensation for exported
power
some of the basics for group net
metering so this allows uh
renewable energy facilities they can
share the proceeds from net metering
projects of their excess generation with
other electric customers have to be in
the same utility service territory so
the customer generator in a group uh
what
would question me
representative Harrington do you have a
question
yes thank you Mr chairman uh just before
you leave the slide on that metering on
the last one I guess you were on
um under the small ones you give uh we
give full credit for transmission
whether under the old tariff or the new
tariff yet when they get larger one
there's no credit for transmission why
is there a difference
uh that is a decision that was made by
the Commission in determining the Tariff
uh I don't know that that particular
item changed from 26 from the original
legislative net metering tariff to the
new one
um
but the Tariff values and you know which
are basically effectively a percentage
of each type of charge uh was a decision
by the commission and I think it's order
26029 and 2017 thank you that's it was a
so group net metering so the basics here
is you have your facility your customer
generator that's the the solar the hydro
uh that is the host that meter is the
host meter these can be again up to one
megawatt or if you are a municipal group
host which is a newly enabled type of
group those can be up to five megawatts
uh and as I stated previously large
customer generators you know if you're
not using more than 20 behind the meter
you have to you are required to become a
the programs that we offer under group
net metering these are all enabled
through statute so we have the
admissible group Host this was I believe
2021 House Bill 315 that enables
Municipal group hosts uh these are four
political subdivisions as defined in the
statute I think I have another slide on
that that I'll go over that in a little
more detail and they can be up to five
megawatts in capacity
we have LMI Community solar projects we
refer to this informally as the LMI
Adder groups
uh this was 2019 SB 165 that enabled
these projects they have to meet a
number of requirements that are defined
in the statute and then are therefore as
a group eligible for an additional two
and a half cents per kilowatt hour for
the exported power that they generate
and then newly in 2022 SB 270 is an
additional LMI Community solar project
type of group Arrangement which focuses
specifically on the electric assistance
program and customers that are eligible
for that program and we are currently
I won't spend although we will be coming
back so I guess maybe we do have some
time but uh the municipal group hosts
projects so these are effectively
designed to support towns I believe in
state government
um facilities so all of the members are
required to be political subdivisions
which is outlined in the definition in
the statute
the host itself the host could be a
private developer it could be a town or
government entity and
if it's a new facility it is required
that the the host project be in the same
municipality as all of the members and
then the members are you know
effectively need to be Town entities or
state entities it's it's outlined their
political subdivisions so folks would
comment again they apply to us any folk
any people that would like to register
as group hosts and create groups in New
Hampshire they register uh they submit
an application to our department we
review that in coordination with the
utilities and we would approve it so we
would review all of these items to make
sure they're meeting the requirements
and
um prove their projects
the LMI Adder it is designed to create
additional credit for low to moderate
income residents in New Hampshire so
there's the addition of two and a half
cents per kilowatt hour for these for
excess generation for these projects
should they meet all of the eligibility
requirements which are outlined within
the statute uh
a number of different requirements on
load and generation but probably one of
the most important is that you have to
have a group of at least five
residential end user customers of which
the majority of those need to be low
moderate income as defined by the
statute
and then the new uh Eep
LMI Adder projects this was enabled
through SB 270 just last session 2022
that establishes a similar two and a
half cent They will also be taking
advantage of the LMI Adder this focuses
specifically on a set of customers that
are either already on the electric
assistance program are eligible for the
assistance program which will be the
list will be developed by the utility up
to six megawatts per year can be
selected and deemed eligible as projects
for these this type of incentive
and
it will enroll customers on an opt-out
basis so folks will you know members of
the Eep list will be notified it will be
opt out they will be notified that they
are you know being signed up for this
program they will have the option to
talk to their utility and opt out at any
time but it is meant to reduce some of
the administrative costs and burden of
trying to have to go out and recruit
customers so that
will be an opt-out option
stop you there for a second
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony uh the six the six
megawatts per year is that a Statewide
maximum
that is a Statewide cap yep so it'll be
we're looking we're currently working on
the details of how this program would be
implemented based on the statute I think
we're actually written comments from
stakeholders we're doing a stakeholder
processor due today by the end of today
we're currently proposing that that is a
you know a cap across the state and that
um potential projects will submit
proposals for an RFP that will be
reviewed by the department to distribute
those six megawatts based on as is clear
is clear in the statute the highest
credit to the LMI participants thank you
very much Mr chairman I think I jumped
ahead of the line for misrepresentative
lewicki
a representative lewicki uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question you may already have answered
this but what is is there any uptake on
this low and middle moderate income uh
provision or is it not yet in place uh
enough to for anybody to actually be
taking it yep
and are you is this for the Eep
yep so we did the LMI Adder which I
think became effective out of 20 19 we
have a grant program that was also
enabled through that statute and we've
had a few projects come online we have
one group net metering project that is
taking advantage and has registered for
the LMI Adder so relatively new we did
actually
submit a report to the legislature I
believe this past October giving an
update on specifically the adder but we
also talk about the grant programs that
we're running focused on LMI as well so
I think I have a link a little bit later
in the slides on that but it's
definitely new and then the Eep program
we are taking final comments on the
proposal for implementing that hoping to
then submit a formal proposal for
approval by our commissioner to run that
program this calendar year so we are
hoping to have an RFP out and be able to
administer that program
uh for this this year hopefully first
upcoming fun things with net metering
um you may be aware but there is and I
think we did get a question around the
value of distributed energy resources
so there is a new docket opened at the
commission
22060 that is an investigation into the
net metering tariff structure other
matters related to to net metering for
customer generators
the value the vder value of distributed
energy resources study that study was
ordered as part of the commission order
from the 2016 docket
so 2016 the commission changed the
Tariff to this alternative net metering
tariff they also ordered a number of
studies and pilot projects to inform a
future review of the Tariff so over you
know the past few years we've the
commission we were at the commission
when this was ordered now the department
we have had two studies completed one is
the locational value of distributed
resources and then also the the value of
just regenerative energy resources which
is the system-wide value study so both
of those were completed and submitted
into the the new docket for
consideration to inform both meant to
not necessarily provide a number but
provide additional data to inform the
conversation about a tariff regarding
you know
um the the
avoided costs that are being achieved as
well as rate and Bill impacts which look
at Cost shifting and magnitude and
so we look forward to participating the
pre-hearing conference was just this
week and we look forward to being
involved in that docket as it proceeds
SB 270 the LMI Adder program the Eep
program specifically we were working on
implementing that and then the New
Hampshire administrative 900 rules which
are oversee all of these net metering
items we are looking at updating those
rules based on some of these statutes
that have come in so that they are up to
date
wonderful that's almost like a a perfect
place for us to uh to take a break here
so uh excellent presentation from the
Department so far this morning and with
everybody's uh without objection from
everybody we'll come back at one o'clock
and start again with the renewable
portfolio standard continue on with the
rest of the doe presentation and then
immediately following that the office of
the consumer Advocate will present to
the committee so for right now we're in
this is your one minute warning we'll
start the proceedings again in one
minute
okay let us resume our activity for the
day
just to refresh everyone's memory this
is the science technology and energy
committee and we have a presentation
ongoing by the department of energy and
we stopped the presentation for lunch
at the end of the net metering portion
of their
presentations and I will pick it up with
the renewable portfolio standard and
turn the microphone back over to Mr Josh
Elliott good afternoon Mr chairman sorry
um again for the record Josh Elliott
director of the division of policy and
programs um picking up at the end of
deandra's uh presentation as the
chairman mentioned talk about the
renewable portfolio standard so see the
next slide here on the renewable
portfolio standard was enacted in 2007
and requires uh a certain percentage of
a electricity providers whether it's a
distribute distribution utility or
competitive supplier to procure a
certain percentage of their electricity
from
renewable resources and those renewable
resources are divided up into classes
there's class one which is sort of a
catch-all for a lot of other different
Technologies so it's easier to find it
as what it's not rather than what it is
class 2 is new solar class three is
biomass class four is small scale hydro
and again going back to class one it's
wind geothermal some of the other
smaller Technologies aren't necessarily
fit into the other three classes
so how do does a
provider electricity actually comply
with immobile portfolio standards so the
best way I've heard this described is uh
is you cannot track a single electron as
it's moving through the system right so
the best way I've heard it described is
you take a glass of water you dump it
into a swimming pool okay I want my
glass of water back right you can't you
can't find it you're never going to find
it
so what renewable Technologies produce
are called renewable energy certificates
or wrecks essentially it is the
renewable attributes of the electricity
generation
as you can imagine with any other uh
with electricity generation it goes to
wherever the demand is so for example I
live in Goffstown chances are if I were
to actually figure out exactly what's
coming in through my meter it's probably
either solar that's in the neighborhood
natural gas from Granite Ridge or from
uh the hydroelectric Dam at Glen Lake
so in order to actually be able to
um sell and trade those renewable
attributes because I didn't pay for
those specific renewable attributes
um the generator create or mint what are
called Rex and those are certified
through the department
um that if they meet the certain
criteria that they're eligible to Mint a
certain type of class Rex so it's either
class one class two class three class
four
so the providers of electricity the
distribution utilities or the
competitive suppliers then have to
acquire these renewable energy
certificates in order to meet their RPS
compliance so they have to get a certain
number to match their megawatt hours of
energy sold electricity sold excuse me
to match up for each of those classes
so they can do that in either the way
that I just described here's a little
sorry there's a chart makes a little bit
easier they can either acquire those
renewable energy certificates or they
can do something else called making an
alternative compliance payment or an ACP
essentially if there are not enough
wrecks available in the market for
purchase they can make one of these all
of this alternative compliance payment
now uh most of the time the alternative
compliance payment is again is a set in
statute it's set at a rate higher than
what would normally trade on the market
for a wreck so there's a financial
incentive to go out and procure these
renewable energy certificates and this
is meant to sort of as a backup option
if for whatever reason the wrecks are
not available on the market or there are
other distortions
um
these racks are publicly traded you can
acquire them they're bought and sold so
it's just General market the price goes
up and down depending on the supply the
demand as well as obviously different
state policy decisions
um
so when it comes to these uh renewable
energy certificates again they there's
this active Market that's trading back
and forth some of the competitive
suppliers for example if they have a
very small load rather than going
through the hassle of going out to
procure a very small number of wrecks
they'll make the alternative compliance
payment just because they're they're not
doing as much their book of business is
not large enough to actually warrant
going out to actually get them
so where does all this Revenue come from
where does it go so these um alternative
compliance revenues are deposited into
What's called the renewable energy fund
um so we do a couple of different things
um actually I'm going to go back to my
last slide there we see the green circle
um a small portion of it goes to pay for
the administrative costs of actually
managing the fund ensuring the
compliance as well as
overseeing the proper minting of those
removable energy certificates
um
and then the balance goes into two
different programs it either goes into
the residential rebate programs or it
goes into the commercial industrial or
cni rebate and Grant programs so on the
residential side we offer rebates for um
photovoltaic or solar or wind um based
on a per watt basis uh it is currently
one thousand dollars per installation
um we have a solar water heating rebate
program which that is currently closed
and then we have a residential wood
pellet program so this up offers up to
ten thousand dollars with additional
benefit uh
um uh bonus payments depending on the
size of the actual
um
it's not a tank but it's a container
where the wood pellets sit in the
basement
there's an Adder based on the size of
that that container
um and these are these are programs
available to regular residential reg
payers for example the uh wood pellet
with the increase in oil Natural Gas
Propane Etc has actually seen a strong
uptick in demand of people swapping over
um
to move off of fossil fuels we also have
the LMI competitive grant program I know
there was a question earlier about that
we offer grants to folks who create
these uh essentially solar arrays that
the benefits then go to
um
benefit low and moderate income uh
residential rate payers as Deandra
mentioned in her presentation there's
some difficulty administrative
difficulty in trying to track down those
folks which is what was Senate Bill 270
is seeking to rectify but I don't know
if any of you happen to live in the
Dunbarton area or go up and down Route
13 between Goffstown and Concord there's
actually the latest grantee Oris has a
solar field that they just completed off
of Route 13 and Dunbarton
on the non-residential side we also do
the same similar programs where we have
a solar rebate program for businesses
and again the same similar for
commercial industrial customers for if
they want to swap over to wood pellet
programs we do the final program is a
non-competitive excuse me is a
competitive program essentially if it's
something that's not solar or not
a biomass type of project for a business
um it's sort of a outside the box
project if you will we offer funds
available on a competitive basis to do
uh to do these types of projects so
we've seen everything from schools
coming in to do different projects a lot
of them are actually uh um upgrading and
refurbishing existing hydroelectric dams
in order to get either greater output or
bring them back online to actually
generate electricity and generate those
wrecks
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chair
um this is a question regarding the Rex
is there a finite number that's
available at any time
um the only thing that um oh there you
are okay I'm by apologies um so the only
thing that determines there's the only
limiting factor on the number of
available wrecks is the number of
generators creating them so there's not
there's not a cap of say a million
wrecks and that's all that can be
produced in theory it's infinite it's
just the matter of how many how many
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um my question is around I've seen a lot
of signs around now for people wanting
to do geothermal people are trying to
convert their homes in that way and I
was wondering whether there are
I don't think the current statutes cover
that in terms of this funding for
renewable but is there Federal funding
or is there any way for people to get
any offset on that because I know I have
people in my community that are looking
into that that is something we could
certainly look at doing um because
geothermal if I recall correctly would
be eligible for class one as a renewable
resource
the department has a certain amount of
latitude in terms of what we can and
can't use the the renewable energy fund
for in terms of setting up new programs
it's sort of it's um particularly
circumscribed in the statute but that is
certainly something we could we could
look at doing I am not aware of any
specific Federal program that helps in
terms of Beyond sort of like tax rebate
sort of program to actually provide
actual funding for it I'm not aware of
anything off the top of my head but um I
can do some digging and get an answer
back for you thank you
representative mom uh Summers is
recognized for a question
thank you Mr chairman
um quick question for you you mentioned
on here about Rex and I'm curious we
talked earlier about how rates of for
electricity have increased recently due
to supply issues and with Rex being
traded at a premium how much of the rate
of the cost of Rex is being passed on to
those residents that do not provide
their own power and how much does their
bill increase over that period of time
sure um that's a very good question and
actually reminds me of something that
Tom France as he was leaving mentioned
make sure you mention this when you're
talking about Rex and I had forgotten so
thank you for for that prompt
um so the cost of compliance with the
renewable portfolio standard whether
it's the making those acps or acquiring
those wrecks is passed through to the
rate payers it is of that pie chart that
Tom Franz had on his slide it is baked
into the default service so it is part
of that number that you see on the uh on
that excuse me that you saw on that pie
chart I can no I was gonna say I should
have grabbed this number ahead of time
we do produce an annual report that has
the exact breakdown of how much the RPS
compliance costs
um I don't have it right at my
fingertips and off the top of my head
but while someone else is doing a
presentation I can get that figure
thank you follow up follow-up okay uh
yeah I'll ask excuse me I'm being
prompted from the audience um last year
was roughly 55 million across Statewide
55 million so with that incremental
across if we went from one megawatt to
let's say five megawatt generation would
that multiply quintupled
uh no because that would just be um in
terms of
um generation when quintuple that
because that's those are all the wrecks
and the RPS compliance outside of net
metering so that is everything including
biomass small scale Hydro things like
that that are may not necessarily be net
metered
representative Kaplan has a question
yeah speaking of thank you Mr chair and
uh uh speaking of costs is there any uh
calculation ever made of uh the cost
savings produced by the renewable energy
uh program and and it's uh you know
Allied uh end uses is there any
calculation made of the demand side
savings
so the only way we would be able to
quantify that would be through
the programs I guess that we have sort
of the the development that has been
incented through these those acps
um that would be the only firm number
that I could think of off the top of my
head because we wouldn't necessarily
know okay are those you know renewable
sources are they cited somewhere else
would they have occurred otherwise you
know would they have occurred only
because of this program would that money
have gone somewhere else and so there's
I suppose it would probably require a
larger economic analysis rather than
what I have at my fingertips follow up
yeah follow-up question thank you Mr
chair
um is the what is the budget for the
acp's uh year by year is that bit going
up or is that it it varies um I was
going to say is there a slide in here no
there's not
um it varies from year to year so it
largely depends on what the larger Rec
Market is doing for example other states
have uh different policies that will
impact what does and doesn't count
um for their um
uh for their wreck so unfortunately a
class one in New Hampshire isn't the
same as a class one in Massachusetts or
Connecticut or Rhode Island
um that it varies and different ones
have different eligibility for example
recently Massachusetts has decided that
they're not going to consider biomass as
a renewable energy resource anymore so
it's not eligible to
um those wrecks won't be eligible to
meet Massachusetts as RPS compliance so
you imagine all of those wrecks have to
flow somewhere else the price is
probably going to drop there'll be more
of them available so the sort of all of
those outside market dynamics no matter
what we do what we we could do something
here in New Hampshire another state
could do something else and it would
representative Nutter has a question
um thank you I was writing down my
question was representative Summers was
asking his so I think it may have been
the same one but I missed it so
um do you have like a chart or something
a rundown of how much the biomass
program I'm sorry biomass RPS program
um cost to run including salaries
overhead all that and then compare it to
I guess it would depend on how you Quant
so we have financial data yeah so we
produce an annual report every year that
shows how much we got in ACP Revenue
where it came from who paid it and then
we also show the opposite side of you
know what it went out what I went to go
pay for staff and salaries what it went
out to go for all these rebate programs
that I just mentioned
um as far as sort of a larger economic
analysis I am not aware of one has been
done to say okay does the cost benefit
you know that economic analysis that
you're looking for I'm not aware of one
that has been done I'd be happy to stand
follow-up well this is a different
question
um do you know why Massachusetts dropped
biomass from
consideration
um I would I it would be conjecture on
my part I think there is a certain
school of thought
um within sort of um
how to put it environmental circles as
to whether or not biomass is truly a
renewable resource because it still
emits carbon dioxide
I think that's I think that's the Crux
of it so rather than you know uh um a
hydroelectric Dam or solar or Winder etc
etc that biomass is still emitting
I'm not taking a position on that I'm
just assuming that's what what somebody
continue please
um so here's uh here's a breakdown of
the um what we've outlaid since
Inception of the uh of the various RFP
or excuse me ref program rebates
um so you can see the number of solar
residential solar hot water uh
residential wood pellet cni solar as
well as cni wood pellet programs as well
as the
um you can see in the second to last
columns the aggregate applicant
Investments so we see how much the the
state has put in how much other
investment that has drawn
um again there's the economic analysis
of that's very basic economic analysis
but in terms of okay would that
development have happened otherwise it's
sort of it's hard to say without an
actual economic analysis the very last
column um you do have the
um total number of generation that has
been brought online that is at least in
part attributable to these programs
next slide um this is just an overview
of the competitive grant program
um so for example there's a couple of of
examples on the right hand side there
Fountain Fall Mountain excuse me
Regional School Districts for wood
pellet boilers
um uh as well as a couple of other
different school districts Plymouth
wastewater treatment facility as well as
a high mowing school and again I
mentioned Orris which is a
program that benefits
immigrants new immigrants to the United
States especially in in we're working on
working in the agricultural sector like
they're trying to get their own Farms up
and going that's the latest one of the
oh excuse me I'm sorry I'm mixing
programs this is a competitive program
um the
um some of the latest ones have actually
been upgrading hydroelectric facilities
uh there's one out in Dover I believe
there's a couple around the state of
where they're uh you know either
bringing them back up online replacing
Valves and things like that to make them
actually
um eligible
um
to generate racks and that's sort of the
underlying premise behind the the uh the
ref and how it funds programs in theory
it should be incenting additional
development of renewable energy
resources which then creates more
renewable energy certificates which in
theory makes more available drives down
the price reduces the need for ACP So in
theory it should be a self-fulfilling
cycle that goes further and further and
essentially Works itself out of
existence because at some point no acps
would be needed because you'd be able to
acquire all these wrecks to the open
market
um again this is the this is a slide on
the LMI um competitive grant program
um you can see the number of applicants
the awardees the amount of money as well
as the number of participants um last
year was a little bit of a tough year
where we had two applications
unfortunately neither of them were
eligible based on the
um uh eligibility criteria however we
have gone out again we've heard from a
number of folks who are interested so
we're hoping for to have a robust round
this time in terms of that program
because that's really a program geared
towards folks who can't you know think
of the LMI Community they can't afford
the 10 15 20 000 to put a solar array on
their roof this is a way that they can
benefit from from that energy transition
um
so there's additional information on the
LMI program available on our website
that's the 2020 LMI competitive Grant
legislative report um that Deandra had
mentioned earlier
um and as well as the 2020 LMI adder and
Market status
um legislative report so with that I'm
representative lewicki has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking the question
um just looking at the numbers I see uh
nine total awardees for uh one and a
half million dollars that's roughly a
hundred thousand dollars per
um you know figuring on by energy
consumption I could probably heat my
house for 50 years on a hundred thousand
dollars this does not look like a wise
investment
I don't I'm sorry I can't really
formulate it as a question it's just a
simple arithmetic
okay
representative McWilliams has a question
just to follow up on that question I do
have a separate question after this one
but to follow up on representative
lewicki's question can you just tell me
of these previous awardees what type of
applicants they were were these like you
know multi-family housing what are we
looking at for people that are getting
awarded an LMI Grant yeah so the um the
best actually the best example is the
one that I know the best
um is that the most recent one that I
mentioned in Dunbarton so it's an
organization that works with
um
recent immigrants to the country who are
looking to get into the agricultural
sector so they have uh land available in
Dunbarton that they've been able to put
up a solar array and then those the
benefits of that solar array
um so the reduction in electricity costs
then go directly to anybody who is LMI
so that would be really depending on how
you uh the the m is a bit difficult to
the the middle income is a bit difficult
to actually get Target the benefits to
but low income is much easier because
there's other benef similar programs if
you're eligible for other sort of
assistance programs it's easy to say
you're eligible for this but the
benefits of those solar arrays and that
energy generation goes to reduce if not
eliminate the electric bills for those
participants
follow-up follow-up
um so just going back a little bit when
we talked about the competitive grant
program and you've got a this is slide
53 you've got a list of a bunch of
different looks like schools
Fall Mountain Regional School District
historic Harrisville holderness School
there's Plymouth wastewater treatment
plant and high mowing school
it sounds to me like some of these are
public entities that are receiving a
grant would that be accurate yes so yes
school districts towns any sort of
component of of local government are are
they are considered commercial based on
their meter and how much electricity
they're using they're considered usually
commercial customers so they're eligible
for this grant program follow up
follow up so for these public
brand recipients
is part of their calculus for
determining whether or not they're going
to do the project do they consider the
value of the Rex when they choose to do
this for a municipal project for example
yes I don't want to speak for every
single entity but yes that goes into the
financial calculation I imagine for some
if they decide not to retain the racks
themselves
okay seeing no further questions we
thank you for that portion of the
presentation welcome looks like we're
going to move on now and here once again
from
welcome again
thank you good afternoon everybody
um it's a pleasure to be here today and
as Tom said earlier see some familiar
faces and meet some new faces so
um
as Josh had mentioned earlier the
department oversees a number of
different programs which I'm sorry
that's okay which provides services to
Consumers throughout the state through
res for these are primarily residential
consumers
um Josh had mentioned a low-income home
energy assistance program or what we
call fap fuel assistance program in New
Hampshire it's a federally funded
program through the U.S Department of
Health and Human Services and the state
receives a block grant each year to
provide assistance to low-income
households within the state the income
eligibility level is 60 of the state
median income in New Hampshire and
there's a chart that shows you for your
household size what that upper income
limit is
for the current program year that we're
in right now the state received close to
34 million dollars in a block grant for
fuel assistance for customers within the
state as was mentioned earlier
application eligibility determination
and benefit determination is all done by
the Community Action agencies there are
five Community Action agencies
regionally within the state covering
either one or two counties or in the
case of Tri-County Three Counties so
they they provide services in five
distinct Geographic areas throughout the
state of New Hampshire customers go in
there kind of One-Stop shopping they
fill out one application and the
Community Action agencies determine
which programs they would be eligible
for and what that that benefit amount
would be
for fuel assistance
the the benefit determination is
targeted to households with the lowest
incomes and the highest energy costs so
we'll look at things such as household
income but also your energy type and the
cost of that energy the degree days how
cold it is within the region that you're
located in your housing type and so
forth to determine the benefit
the benefit range for this program year
is between three hundred dollars and
just a little over three thousand
dollars and the average we'll see at the
end of the program year what the average
benefit to consumers in the state
actually is
the program's been open for eight weeks
now typically opens on December 1st of
each year given the high energy costs
the volatility and the energy markets
the department opened the program on
November 1st this year so a little more
than eight weeks but when I looked at
statistics that we were eight weeks in
and what we've seen this year is a
considerably higher volume of
applications and appointments at the
community action agencies than in past
years for example week eight this year
versus week eight last year there were
more 3 000 more applications had been
received this year than for the same
time period last year
appointments were up
5100 more appointments week eight this
year versus week eight last year so the
need and the interest is out there and
the
um
Community Action agencies are doing the
quick highlights from last year the
state received about 28 million dollars
in the regular lie Heap block grant so
we received more in the block grant this
year than we did last year there were
some error funds received last year 35
and a half million dollars received last
year
25 well 24
400 or so households received benefits
the average benefit was in the Thirteen
hundred dollar range
as part of last year's program for the
first time in part due to the arpa funds
that were available a one-time cooling
credit was provided on electric bills
for customers who had been enrolled and
received a benefit in the fuel
assistance program so they received some
help on their electric bill this summer
to help cover cooling costs during the
the weatherization assistance program is
another federally funded program through
the U.S department of energy and it
provides weatherization services to
low-income households in the state
focusing on those most vulnerable to
high energy costs and without the means
to make the cost-effective improvements
on their own
um there the funding for this is in this
year 1.9 million dollars was received at
the beginning of July for the program
year that will run through June 30 2023.
um we anticipate or well we don't
anticipate we've received additional
funding through the bipartisan
infrastructure law which
will over the course of five years
ending June 30th 2027 provide New
Hampshire with an additional 18 million
in weatherization assistance program
funds that yes representative Thomas has
a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh just uh as
examples what types of weatherization
programs do you sure uh qualify or uh
you know
doors windows
um you know addicts you know uh things
like that yeah absolutely so when a
customer applies and they're found
eligible and energy auditor goes out and
does an energy audit of their home
and they identify all the things that
can be done for Energy Efficiency
improvements and then they prioritize
those based on the ones where they're
going to get the most bang for the buck
so to speak because
there's a
average cost per unit cap Statewide so
when we're done at the end of this
program year the average cost of
weatherization Services provided
Statewide
is a little over eight thousand dollars
I think it's eight thousand and seven or
nine dollars
and so the energy auditor will identify
the most critical ones to do that will
yield the most savings and it would
include things like attic air ceiling
attic insulation if there's no
insulation wall insulation if there's no
insulation air sealing insulation of
basements crawl spaces it could include
the replacement of a door if the door is
very
drafty and ill-fitting but it would be
specific to each individual applicant's
circumstances and what the energy audit
finds to be the most important
improvements or the most effective
improvements to make
I just follow up follow-up uh thank you
um so um
I know I had a constituent that had used
he actually had to put blankets over his
windows to keep the snow from coming in
there it was in that better shape yet
when he had the energy audit done the
windows were did not qualify to get
assistance from that so I was just
wondering if there was a limit or uh or
or do you have to go back and reapply
again to get more work done how does
that work
um so we're I believe you can reapply
for weatherization services but there's
a time limit in between receipt of that
benefit
I can't speak to why in his particular
circumstance work wasn't done on his
windows without
having our weatherization
assistance program director look at the
audit and what work was done and what
you know whether there were bigger
issues that were addressed within the
limited spending that they had for that
particular
individual okay thank you representative
Nutter has a question
thank you Mr chairman this is actually
on the fuel assistance because I got it
a message just today from um the
constituent she said no word on my
application for the fuel assistance I
bet I don't get it I did apply you said
three you had three thousand more
applicants so do you respond to every
applicant or just the ones who are
granted assistance so the Community
Action agencies take the applications
and do the certification to determine if
someone is eligible or not and they
communicate that to every single person
who's applied whether they're eligible
whether they're not eligible whether
they fail to complete their application
the Community Action agencies are
resource constrained like many
non-profit businesses or small
businesses in the state they struggle
with the low unemployment rate and
keeping and maintaining staff so they
work as best they can with the staff
that they have and do a great job taking
care of folks as they come in but there
is a bit of a backlog in the
applications certainly folks can call
the Department of energy you could refer
that customer over to us and we'd reach
out to the cap and say where is this can
you unstick this or you know figure out
what's going on
foreign
what is the number just so I could
oh for the Department of energy yes
um it's in our slides somewhere our main
number is
271-3670 and the 800 number is
800-852-3793
thank you slide 67.
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair
um I was wondering how many do you uh
use independent private contractors to
do this weatherization work or do you
have your own staff and how many people
do you employ or how many businesses are
involved in this program
sure sure uh Josh Elliott division
director
um so it depends on the area so for
example Tri-County has their own staff
and their own Crews that go out to
actually perform the weatherization work
um as far as I'm aware I believe they're
the only one that has adopted that model
um the other for the balance of the
state um they go out with private
contractors to do this work so they'll
do what's called a pre-qualified list
essentially rather than going out for an
RFP or um
or have to respond for uh you know put
out to bid every single last project
they'll get a um a group of contractors
who meet the qualifications and then as
each job comes up they'll sort of parcel
them out
um one by one one youth contractor but I
will say um this is uh certainly an area
if you know of any contractors are
interested in getting into this work
there's always demand for them
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair I'm wondering are any
measurements done in terms of the
weatherization uh do you uh determine uh
the Savings in in terms of uh air
raw throughout the weatherization yeah
per unit so you know you can actually
measure with blower door tests what the
what the overall effect is and from that
extrapolate actual dollar savings
so there's two versions to the low
income weatherization assistance program
there's a federally funded piece and
then there's the piece that's funded
through the Electric and Gas Utilities
Energy Efficiency programs and I believe
the answer is the same for both which is
when the work is done there is another
blower door test done to measure the
efficiency improvements and then that
could in turn calculate savings and
payback for the customer and that's I
believe part of the whole audit process
particularly for someone that's making
their own investment to let them know
what the payback period would be thank
you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chairman the the block grants
that come from the federal government
are those specific Are there specific
requirements that they be used for fuel
assistance and weather
um weather weatherization programs or is
is is that how we the state have chosen
to use the money that the federal
government has given us
are specific to those programs and there
are guidelines for each from the federal
government and then states have some
flexibility in customizing it within the
state but there are specific guidelines
that the federal government sets out
thank you
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman a quick question
this morning we've talked about
electricity and we talked about the flow
and how we were able to receive it and
what the delays or the restrictions were
on getting it as per uh and what I
understand about authorization how it's
important but as far as heating oil goes
the majority of the homes in New
Hampshire are with heating oil who's
responsible for or who actually monitors
the supply and demand curve of heating
oil how much is how much is in Supply
how much is in demand and how it's being
used and if we have enough to be able to
make it through one season two seasons
in there
sure yeah
so uh the department of energy
um participates with our other New
England states it's called the shop
program of where we have Regional calls
um with um
other uh New England states to determine
inventory so where that's something for
example home eating oil right you
wouldn't want to figure out the last
minute there's none left in the region
there are weekly calls during the winter
heating season to determine um with uh
with other states with regional Partners
as well as Federal authorities figuring
out okay or do we have Ships coming in
what's the inventory look like I know
you will probably hear from at some
point during this
um during this legislative session on
Bob Scully who is the uh runs the oil
and propane Dealers Association although
I think he's handing it off a little bit
going a little semi-retirement um you
know we have frequent calls with him he
lets us know if hey we're looking at
supply issues here in New Hampshire Halo
we're looking at driver issues hey we're
looking at et cetera Etc
um
so that is something that the department
is actively engaged in and actively
monitoring through the winter heating
season
follow up Mr chairman follow-up and so
as as represents on this committee how
can we or where can we find the
information to find where the current
Supply is if we're running close to a
shortage and if there's a risk being
shortage for this winter sure so we have
on our department of energy website we
do um as part of that program we do
calls around to vendors we do basically
do a survey of vendors across the state
of asking about different prices for
different types of deliverable fuels
we've also
um
um we've added additional questions I
know there's been a discussion earlier
this uh year about
um uh kerosene where there have been
issues with kerosene that issue seems to
have abated somewhat it's still very
expensive but there's at least there's
the supply there
um I don't know if we necessarily have
the exact Supply figures on our website
but that would be certainly if we
um in those internal discussions you
know with other states and whether
stakeholders realize hey you know in a
couple weeks we're going to have an
issue that's certainly something we
wouldn't be sitting on any information
we'd be communicating that to folks
um I will say the best thing if uh to do
um for con for your constituents as well
as just anybody generally at large who's
concerned about home heating fuels this
winter is to be rather than a um a
will-call customer to be a regular
customer with a particular fuel vendor
it helps them plan you get in their
system they know exactly how much fuel
to procure they know exactly how much
and when you're going to need it it
helped helps them do planning in terms
of procurement but if you're stuck
somewhere you know there's something you
said about you know bouncing from from
place to place to get the best deal and
the best amount for um for your home
heating
um but especially this this winter
um to make sure that you're with a
specific supplier that you're on a
regular cycle
um because if you know if you're running
low on fuel and you're with a supplier
that you haven't dealt with before
you're going to be at the back of the
list versus customers that they
regularly have so I would just encourage
if anybody's listening to to to to do
that as well
thank you you're welcome
representative closure has a question
yes uh director Newman
um going back to what what isization
program
um is there the information that the
committee could have on
um the estimated BTU savings per cost
of the work done
on these applications
sure I can I I don't know that the
answer to that question I'll check with
our weatherization assistance program
manager and see if he has that
information available unless you know
offhand Josh I don't but that there must
be some Metric that we can have we can
provide the committee yeah thank you
thank you chairman
uh
my question is about well first I want
to compliment you on using the cap
agencies as you were pass-through
agencies seems like a genius idea in
order to be able to get down on that
level in the community could you tell me
right does New Hampshire save
utilize the cap programs in the same way
are you aware of that could you
for their low for their low income
um for the weather so the federal
weatherization program coordinates
closely with the utilities for their
home energy assistance program which is
for low-income customers and the
Community Action agencies are the driver
for the application and eligibility
determination for both those programs
the utilities May
they're not experts in low income so if
you were to call them they would tell
you they can't determine your income
eligibility they don't know how to do it
and they would send you to the cap who
could but essentially they're both being
administered in the same fashion so
there's no chance of redundancy of
both Services correct thank you
I would remind members that
when you want to speak to the committee
you have to get the permission of the
chair so please uh let me know if you
want to say something additional
all right I guess we're done with
questions there you can continue on with
your presentation thank you
okay
um
so this is just a quick recap of the
weatherization assistance program year
that ended
well note that that's in process right
now so it runs from July 1 2022 through
June 30 2023.
um It's On Target to provide benefits to
approximately 150 to 160 homes I
mentioned the close coordination with
the utility home energy assistance
program as part of New Hampshire saves
in the Energy Efficiency resource
standard so in total we anticipate
um
A Thousand Eleven Hundred homes would
benefit from weatherization assistance
the electric assistance program is a
state-funded program not a federally
funded program it's funded through a
charge on customers electric bills
through the system benefits charge it is
legislatively capped at 1.5 mils per
kilowatt hour for the average customer
using 625 kilowatt hours which is
whether it's truly the average it's how
we Define the average it's a 94 cents on
their bill
it provides monthly bill assistance for
customers with incomes at or below 60
percent of New Hampshire State median so
you've seen fuel assistance
weatherization assistance and now
electric assistance all these folks go
into the cap it's the same income
eligibility level there's no confusion
for customers they do one application
and they can get benefits from from the
programs
she said it is monthly bill assistance
so unlike weatherization where it's just
uh not sorry I'm sorry not
weatherization the fuel assistance
program where it's just during the
winter months for heating the electric
assistance program is a monthly discount
on your bill for either 12 or 24 months
and that's determined by
um if you are have all members of your
household are age 65 and older and on a
fixed income it's a 24-month
certification period
the discount percentage applies to the
first 750 kilowatt hours of usage to
incent some conservation by consumers
and the discount ranges range from 8 to
76 percent
and this is just an overview for you by
household size and discount tier as you
can see that the highest discount the 76
percent discount is targeted to those
in the 2021-20 representative Thomas
Douglas Thomas has a question thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
um I'm curious uh on my electric bill
there's an option if I want to they ask
if would you pay one dollar towards
electrical assistance fund or whatever
it is is that part of your program
it's not depending on who your electric
utility is if you're a customer of
eversource Liberty or Unitil they all
participate in the neighbor helping
neighbor program and that's where you
get the envelope in your bill that says
do you want to make a donation to The
Neighbor helping neighbor program if
you're a New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative customer they have a pro a
program called project care and it's a
Roundup function on your bill where if
your bills you know
69.12 she rounded up to seventy dollars
and that difference goes into the
project Care Program those are neighbor
helping neighbor helps customers not
otherwise eligible for assistance
programs typically so if they wouldn't
be eligible for fuel assistance they
could get a this season up to 500
benefit from neighbor helping neighbor
on their electric or gas bill and
project care is run a little bit
differently they have a project care
board that reviews the application and
makes assistance grants to its members
for the co-op
um so for the program year that ended
this past September for the electric
assistance program there were about 14
million dollars in benefits provided to
customers
average enrollment was slightly under 30
000 households and the average monthly
benefit was forty dollars or four
hundred and eighty dollars for the year
to date this year with higher Energy
Service prices that we've talked about
this morning the benefit level was 44
percent higher in October and 66 percent
higher in November current enrollment is
a little over a little bit higher than
what's on this slide it's now 29 391
customers and the legislature did
approve those seven million dollars in
supplemental funding for the electric
assistance program to ensure continued
benefits throughout this program year
and the income eligible eligibility
guidelines by discount tier oops sorry
I'm going backwards on my slides the
state emergency assistance programs that
were approved by the legislature in
September those two programs one is a
emergency fuel assistance program one is
an emergency electric benefit or
supplemental electric benefit they it's
for households that typically don't
qualify for other low-income programs
like fuel assistance or the electric
assistance program
so households greater than 60 percent of
New Hampshire State median income but
less than 75 percent of New Hampshire
State median income
the emergency fuel assistance benefit is
a one-time credit of 450 dollars
the emergency electric benefit is a
one-time credit of two hundred dollars
it's important to note that this
electric emergency electric benefit is
also for customers of Municipal Electric
utilities those customers are not
eligible for the electric assistance
program because the program is funded
through regulated utility customers
through the system benefit charge on
their bill
um applications and eligibility are
being done by the Community Action
agencies I'm happy to say that benefits
started to flow in December the end of
December while we were able to leverage
some of the existing infrastructure for
the fuel assistance application and the
electric assistance program application
there were enhancements that needed to
be made to the software to accurately
track benefits
funding reporting all those things that
are separate from the federally funded
fuel assistance program and so those
those
as is always the case software
enhancements take longer than we'd like
them to but we did see benefits flow to
customers at the end of September
December
and that this is 75 percent of New
Hampshire State median income if you're
wondering what that is is broken down by
household on this last slide
representative Nutter has a question
since you're here may I ask because I
was asked by a family in Manchester
where did they go where exactly do they
go to apply for this um
a state emergency assistance program
they go to the Community Action Agency
so someone in Manchester would go to
Southern New Hampshire services
we do have a list of all five Community
Action agencies on our website their
phone numbers links to their websites
but Southern New Hampshire Services
would be the Community Action Agency for
someone in Manchester
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman how many how many
times can someone apply for this
one-time credit and within let's say a
fiscal a calendar year once okay so if
they someone applies now
to to get a credit to offset the
increase in prices as the prices go up
again in six months they're have to wait
this is so this program is a one-time
not just a one-time credit but as we
understand it a one-time program a
one-time allotment of funding for these
two programs for this winter heating
season and any funding remaining lapses
back to the general fund on June 30
2023.
so they can apply once if I will say if
their circumstances change and they find
loss of a job uh some other catastrophic
situation they could apply for the
federal fuel assistance program and they
might then be eligible for that if their
okay thank you continue
uh one last thing I just wanted to
mention is
um we talked a little bit earlier there
are some questions about competitive
Electric Supply I said you know please
feel free to send them over to the
department and we can assist
constituents we've talked a lot about
energy this morning but I did just want
to briefly mention that um
gas water uh well we talked about gas as
part of our energy But Water and Sewer
are also under the purview of the
Department of energy my team's there to
help customers with not just electricity
and gas natural gas but with water
questions and Sewer questions for their
regulated utilities
um also for on some limited basis for
telephone services particularly for what
we think of as the former incumbent
telephone companies we still we have
relationships with them and some small
role in overseeing their relationships
with their customers and any of the
larger companies that have been around
for a while such as Comcast or now
Breeze line we can often help customers
with those and we also have a
Cooperative agreement with the cellular
telephone industry Association to help
with wireless just basically escalating
that into a higher level so it's not as
frustrating for folks to have to
navigate their way through person after
person to get an issue resolved so it's
more than just energy and we're happy to
help whoever needs assistance with their
okay great thank you all right and with
now we're going to move on to
Federal funding infrastructure
investment and jobs act and inflation
production act Mr Roberts
um uh we're afternoon good afternoon
members of the committee
um again Griffin Roberge
um State energy program manager at the
New Hampshire Department of energy
um today I wanted to walk you through um
what the department is doing in
regarding uh regarding some of the
federal funding opportunities coming out
through the infrastructure investment
and jobs act also called the iija you've
also heard it uh referred to here today
as the bipartisan infrastructure law
it's interchangeable there and the
inflation reduction act my presentation
is largely going to focus on the formula
funding opportunities coming down
through these bills uh Josh had
mentioned the difference between formula
and competitive uh funding opportunities
in the former slide so just uh to
mention we're just going to be focusing
on the formula today
so to start off I'm going to talk about
the the iija as you all might know this
bill was signed into law by President
Biden in November of 21.
um the legislation provides some 1.2
trillion for infrastructure related
projects uh including energy related
initiatives for our purposes here for
energy related stuff
um the bill allocates some 62 billion
dollars to the U.S department of energy
over a five-year period this funding
does a variety of things such as
reinforcing existing programs expanding
others and opening up some new funding
opportunities and again depending on the
opportunity it may be formula based or
competitively based
so to start off in my role as the state
energy program manager I manage the
state energy program Grant this is an
annual grant that comes down to States
from the U.S department of energy the
department gives the U.S department of
energy gives States a great deal of
flexibility and how these funds can be
used they really defer to States as the
decision maker and using these funds to
achieve various energy State energy
initiatives or policy goals so there's a
great deal of flexibility there in our
annual Grant we get roughly between 450
000 to 500 000 per year depending on the
level of the federal allocation that's
given out the uses for that largely fall
into three categories every year as we
use it to fund staff at the department
including myself
um an mou between us and the New
Hampshire Department of administrative
services is we work closely with their
state energy manager's office to
complete Energy Efficiency improvements
in state-owned buildings and then
finally we use some of the money for our
seed grant program that stands for
school Energy Efficiency development
grant program which I'll get into
briefly into the next slide
on top of that the infrastructure Bill
appropriated about 500 million more into
this program
unfortunately with the 500 million
dollar allocation the U.S department of
energy decided to shave off 75 million
off of that figure to withhold for
technical assistance so it only leaves
about 425 million left to disperse so
that's leaving New Hampshire with about
3.5 million to spend down over a
five-year period our initial application
uh proposed to the U.S department of
energy to use portions of that money to
fund staff in the department given the
additional
influx of federal funding into the state
through this bill in the ira we'd like
to use some of that funding to staff up
in order to develop these programs using
that funding we're also going to use
some of it to reinforce our existing
seed grant program and then some money
potentially to use for an outside
consultant for our state energy security
plan which is a plan that is required to
be submitted to the U.S department of
energy every time we wish to apply for
set funding every year next slide so
briefly uh the seed grant program this
is a program that was excuse me before
you move on yeah representative Thomas
has a question yes thank you Mr chairman
thank you for the question uh going back
is is that a continuous uh funding
program uh
the the state energy program we're
talking about right the S so if you look
on the slide on the left side you'll see
annual sep that is usually an annual
allocation that's given out to States
every year we apply for that money in
three-year increments so this past year
at the end of the last fiscal year we
closed out a three-year period so we
applied again and so we do that every
year going forward for the next three
years and so that's where we receive
about that 450 000 to 500 000 allocation
follow up
yes I I guess uh thank you uh my point
is that usually some of the money for
your Staffing so your Staffing here is
dependent upon that Federal money coming
in every year yes okay thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you um thank you Mr chair
uh if somebody if an entity uses you'll
need to get up I'm just gonna well no
I'll get up after after I speak okay all
right
um if an entity uses uh some of this
grant money for Energy Efficiency do
they still qualify for NH saves uh yes
so for example and I'll get into it in a
second but um our New Hampshire
Department of administrative Services uh
to the extent that they can will often
leverage rebates from New Hampshire
saves uh this helps kind of extend the
money that they receive from us so
they're leveraging other funds and we
often see that in our seed grant program
is where we have public schools also uh
to fund the project in its entirety will
leverage New Hampshire saves rebates and
couple that with it
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chairman
um I'm I'm sorry if I'm math challenged
but um I didn't understand the uh the
3.5 million that New Hampshire has to
spend down yes over a five-year period
how does that relate to the 500 million
dollars in funding so the 500 million
was an allocation made through the
infrastructure Bill the infrastructure
Bill said we're going to put 500 million
dollars into the state energy program
additional appropriation what then
occurred was the money got to usdue and
because this is an additional pot of
money
um
that states can use they decide to set
up uh take a portion of that allocation
for technical assistance so that's where
I'm talking about 75 million removed
from the allocation so that leaves us
with about 425 million left based on a
formula that was established by the
department that's where we come that's
where by the U.S department of energy
that's where they came down with our
allocation New Hampshire getting 3.5
million we get all of that money up
front and then we have to spend it down
over the next course of five years
follow up
follow up so so the the 500 million and
the 75 million that's nationally that's
nationally correct I thought that was
I'm sorry yeah I'd be a little I think I
might be a little bit more pleased if we
were getting 500 million but no it's uh
I didn't see your hand I'm sorry
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
I hate to be a curmudgeon but when I
think of uh the infrastructure act I
think of actual infrastructure sure and
I mean maybe it's maybe you're going to
cover it somewhere else but and I know
three million is not that a great amount
of money over five years but
what about other infrastructure needs in
New Hampshire sure and and just because
uh how do I want to say this is that
there are is about 1.2 trillion in total
spending
um in the infrastructure Bill I'm not at
Liberty to discuss what might be going
to say the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation for say Transportation
purposes what's going to the Department
of Agriculture for agricultural purposes
I think just for the purposes of my
presentation here today I'm just talking
about the energy related uh provisions
of that bill
representative Summers as a question
thank you Mr chairman to go off of
basically the question you just asked a
representative is uh we're talking about
infrastructure and we're we're at risk
of not having enough energy for the
North country or the part folks in New
Hampshire how much of this
infrastructure go I see these Staffing I
see the nhds but how much do we have she
have going to the actual electrical
infrastructure the actual electrical
grid for the state so I think I think uh
you're hitting on one of my slides uh
you'll probably in the slideshow the
grid resiliency grants which I will get
to um in a moment to talk more about the
so uh just talking a little bit about
our seed grant program this is a program
started by the former office of
strategic initiatives back in 2018.
um again this program is solely funded
with State energy program dollars and it
is a one-time competitive matching grant
program that's offered to public schools
and small communities for Energy
Efficiency improvements funded projects
really kind of have the Dual benefit of
providing a safer healthier learning
environment for students and staff while
also reducing a school's operating costs
providing a net benefit to local
property taxpayers in the past we've
funded Pro we typically fund one school
every year since 18 we have funded
schools as you'll see here our first one
was in Hill which is Jeannie D Blake
elementary school second one was lemster
Community School we've since also funded
New Boston Litchfield and we are
currently working with our fifth awardee
in Berlin
um so to date about 335 000 has been
allocated out of that program to schools
um and as I mentioned we're working with
um another funding opportunity that's
coming down through the infrastructure
bill is the Energy Efficiency revolving
Loan Fund capitalization grant program
um it's a lot of words
um this is a program that offers
um grants to states to establish
revolving loan funds uh those loan funds
would then offer loans to conduct energy
Audits and Energy Efficiency upgrades
and retrofits for residential and
Commercial properties as States
establish these revolving loan funds the
U.S department of energy is actively
encouraging states to have several goals
in mind such as maximizing Energy
savings leveraging private Capital to
the extent possible create jobs and
support the Biden administration's
justice 40 initiative
just for a little bit of background the
justice for the initiative is an
executive order issued by the Biden
Administration that establishes a goal
that 40 percent of the benefits of clean
and clean and of climate and clean
energy Investments flow to to
disadvantaged communities so they really
want to ensure that communities who have
received significant under investment or
disinvestment for a long period of time
you know start getting due consideration
as these dollars are dispersed the
formula for this program is quite unique
in that uh
higher grants are given to Priority
states that have high energy consumption
or high energy related carbon Emissions
on a per capita basis New Hampshire is
not considered a primary State under
that allocation so our allocation is
significantly smaller than those States
so it's leaving us with about eight
hundred thousand dollars in change to
establish a revolving Loan Fund under
this program
the next program is excuse me
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um regarding the energy audit and I'll
get up in a second
um regarding the energy audits um how do
you qualify who does them do they have
to be certified do they have to do some
kind of training or is there
something like that that qualifies who
can do an energy audit sure so that
that's something we're currently
digesting with uh got that with guidance
that's recently just come out on this uh
grant program
um Auditors do need to be uh certified
um and everything like that uh energy
audits under this program also must meet
certain criteria that the US Department
of energy would like to see such as the
audits using uh technical assistance
offered by the US Department of energy
or using certain metrics offered by the
U.S department of energy and then when
it comes to funding the upgrades and
retrofits the department wants to see
that those retrofits those upgrades were
conducted as a result of an energy Rod
it performed under this program or some
other similar looking audit
follow up
does this also include benchmarking uh
okay uh thank you uh next Slide the the
next another Federal funding opportunity
coming down through the infrastructure
bill is the Energy Efficiency and
conservation block grant program or the
eecbg program
um to the extent any of you were maybe
involved in municipal government back
during the Great Recession this program
might strike you as being uh somewhat
familiar because this is a program that
started out uh back in the uh Recovery
Act during the Great Recession and is
being revived again under this
infrastructure bill so this uh this
program offers 550 million dollars into
this program to be dispersed to States
units of local government and Indian
tribes to reduce fossil fuel emissions
reduce total energy use and improve
Energy Efficiency the uses of these
funds are quite broad they can include
energy audits lighting retrofits
renewable energy installations that type
of thing
um
with this 550 million dollar allocation
the U.S department of energy again came
in and took some money off the top they
took 20 of the allocation out for
technical assistance
um leaving with about 440 million
dollars to be dispersed uh according to
a formula to all these different
entities so New Hampshire's allocation
the state is receiving about 1.6 million
dollars direct formula grants are also
being made to each of the 10 counties in
the state as well as the 10 largest
municipalities in the state so that
includes Concord Dairy Dover Hudson
Londonderry Manchester Merrimack Nashua
Rochester and Salem we will all be
receiving their own direct allocations
we do anticipate that this funding
program will likely come online sometime
this month whereby people can begin that
application process we are eagerly
waiting to see when that guidance drops
from the US Department of energy if any
of you folks live or represent any of
those 10 municipalities values certainly
encourage you to hit them up as we have
to let them know that this money is
coming and that concludes at least that
program if you want to hit the next one
circling back to your question
representative summaries
um the uh infrastructure Bill certainly
makes a great deal of investments in the
nation's electric grid this is just one
of a handful of other programs but this
is just a form a formula uh program this
um this program seeks to make money
available to the nation's electric grid
to make it more resilient against
disruptive events brought about by a
changing climate so this section offers
grid resiliency grants to States who
would then sub-grant them out to
eligible entities per the program to
then undertake activities that would
Harden the grid against disruptive
events and those activities uh that can
take place under this program are quite
broad include the reconductoring of
power lines undergrounding of electrical
equipment weatherization Technologies
and Equipment Etc
there is supposed to be an annual
allocation coming out to every state for
the next five years within the first
year we are slated to receive about 3.3
million dollars in funding which we
would then likely set up in a
competitive grant program to then offer
to uh our new on the electric utilities
in the states and that also includes a
municipally owned Electric utilities
um considerations for this program at
least for the applications that would
come in
um
want to hit some of the priorities that
the that the infrastructure Bill wants
us to take note of such as prioritizing
disadvantaged communities reducing the
frequency of disruptive events and
leveraging the leveraging workforce
training programs and that type of thing
there are also other competitively based
electric grid type funding opportunities
which I can talk more about offline I
just didn't include them in today's
presentation I'm just talking about the
formula funding
um next slide if that's all right
uh next steps on the iija program
Guidance just continue to develop across
the programs I mentioned as well as a
lot of the other competitive
opportunities we continue to stay aware
of the latest program developments as I
mentioned there are a number of
competitive funding opportunities that
the department is continuing to review
and consider next steps with for you
folks here
um as resources we did establish a web
page on our website to kind of advertise
select Federal funding opportunities
through this infrastructure bill so if
your municipality is asking questions if
you've got a municipal energy committee
that's maybe discussing some of this
stuff that might be a good resource for
them to consider I've also included a
link on there to the U.S department of
Energy's a webpage about infrastructure
funding as well as a guidebook from the
White House with all the various funding
opportunities through the infrastructure
Bill and that includes transportation
agriculture related Investments and that
type of thing and obviously if anyone
has any questions feel free to reach out
anytime
representative barasni has a question
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question on the previous slide
um I can't remember
I'm sorry I'm sorry
um the I if it's all right with you
representative I can certainly follow up
with you the uses are quite broad but
they vary across the various programs
and I just don't know it off the top of
okay thank you
okay continue please
so
um finally just stepping on to the
inflation reduction act this bill was
signed into law in August of last year
um this is a 391 billion dollar
investment to lower energy costs
accelerate private investment and clean
energy strengthen Supply chains and
create jobs about 35 billion is invested
in clean energy Investments that are
managed by the U.S department of energy
for our purposes here I think I'm going
to focus largely on two Provisions that
authorize about 8.8 billion and two
rebate programs for home Energy
Efficiency and electrification projects
the first rebate program is the home
electrification rebate program this is
about 4.2 billion being made to this
program it would offer grants to States
who would then offer rebates for the
purchase or installation of High Energy
Efficiency home appliances and Equipment
New Hampshire at least is slated to
receive about 3 34.7 million over the
next 10 years we have that money all up
front we get to spend it down over the
next 10 years rebates are available
largely in uh rebates are largely
targeted toward low to moderate income
households for electrification
improvement projects so rebates May
apply to the purchase and installation
of EPA certified energy star appliances
electric loads service centers electric
stoves insulations Etc I do want to
mention from the outset and I'll mention
it again is that these rebate programs
have generated quite a bit of Interest
as you can imagine from residents and
citizens across the state but these
rebates are not available yet and they
will likely not be available until the
end of the year or early 2024 as the U.S
department of energy is still in the
early stages of developing guidance for
these rebate programs so if you do get
questions from constituents you know
it's great that they're interested but
unfortunately just wait be patient if
you want to go on to the next one
the last last rebate program is the
whole homes rebate program this is about
4.3 billion in Grants made to States
um again similar to the other one we get
the we get grants which we then rebate
out
um to eligible parties for
um and for projects that produce uh
Energy savings for from a home energy
upgrade New Hampshire's slayed to get
about 34.9 million out of that
allocation rebates are available to
households of any income but rebate
amounts will vary based on the projected
Energy savings of a given Improvement
the projects eligible for this rebate
are based on actual energy performance
savings and the rebate includes costs a
rebate can also cover costs associated
with the work performed for the
Improvement or the equipment needed to
install the upgrades and again to
emphasize this is a program that's still
developing guidance will likely not be
available until end of the year or early
2024.
and so next step
representative
oh representative nodder
thank you the air ceiling um is at um
the the product that smells like Elmer's
it it might I can't say I have any
personal experience with it or anything
like that so I'm sorry I couldn't answer
that directly or anything like that
representative Corman
thank you Mr chair uh regarding these
rebates and that they won't be available
for probably about a year
does that mean that the work has to be
done at least a year out I mean if
somebody had the work done this year
could they apply retroactively that is
something that is currently being
discussed in these discussions with the
U.S department of energy as they develop
that guidance whether or not somebody
say did an improvement this month
whether or not it would qualify for a
rebate that's available say next year
it's something that's continuing to
evolve and I I don't want to
I don't want to jump the gun on that
tell people that they that they will I
don't want to be accused of giving
somebody misinformation
um but I would just say I would just
encourage uh those interested to
certainly have some patience and wait
and see thank you yep representative
Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh quick question
I've looked through each one of these
grants and I understand each one of them
for winterizing and appliances and high
efficiency home Energy savings and stuff
like that but um is there any grant that
I asked earlier about the grid but is
there any grants or or reductions and
what actually the Crux of the issue
which is the pricing of natural gas and
heating oil or is it just trying to
We're just trying to rebrate an issue
out of the way yeah I mean I I thank you
for the question I think a lot of these
programs are largely going to projects
that could reduce costs for individual
commercial building owners whether
you're in municipality or business or a
resident if it's something to the effect
of say you know for example State energy
program Grant there is an explicit
prohibition there cannot be used to say
uh cover the cost of any type of rate or
pay anybody's electric bill or anything
like that
um I can't think of a specific program
that's focused on say natural gas or
anything like that out of this program
but I can certainly take a look at that
and get back to you if that's all right
so
representative muns
thank you Mr chairman
um on slide 77
it talks about rebates being available
for electric for electric load service
centers is that a fancy way of saying
smart meter again I
yes electric panels in your house I I
just again guidance for this is still
developing and you know the information
I received was from an FAQ on the U.S
department of energy website and so this
is what was on there I don't want to
give any more information or again cause
any misinformation or anything like that
fair enough thank you thank you
so next steps for the um inflation
reduction act as with the infrastructure
Bill the department will continue to
monitor various funding opportunities as
a result of this bill
um just by way of context the U.S
department of energies program guidance
for these rebate programs is still in
its early stages for context the
infrastructure bill which was signed
into long of November of 2021 is just
starting to Roll Out programs out of
that bill now the IRA was just signed
into law in August of last year so I
anticipate that the guidance will take a
little bit of time to develop I would
note that the IRA does contain many uh
tax related Provisions such uh maybe
some tax credits that may assist
homeowners with an Energy Efficiency
Improvement a renewable energy project a
clean vehicle purchase the department of
energy is not a tax agency so if anybody
hears from residents or constituents who
are interested in those types of
Provisions certainly encourage them to
consult with a tax professional and then
finally we do have some resources
available on our website that we will
continue to update regarding the IRA and
feel free to contact us with any
questions
great thank you
next presentation is on the state energy
strategy
so Mr chairman I do realize we've
already gone an hour already an hour and
a half over our presentation time I
didn't know if you wanted to defer
talking about the state energy strategy
to another time we do have I could go
through the slides and discuss it or if
you would prefer I'm happy to the the
activities to go last portion of the
presentation yes it is yeah
I think it might be worthwhile to defer
this then okay and do it as a separate
presentation because there's going to be
a lot of questions
so let's do this as a separate
presentation uh later in the year okay
that's how I know before we move on that
um the commissioner Mr jucoin and the
Deputy Commissioner Mr Elms have agreed
to stay and answer additional questions
if there are any
do any of the members here have any
additional questions for either the
commissioner or the Deputy Commissioner
but one quick one representative Thomas
Douglas Thomas thank you uh Mr chairman
uh really quick uh
we talked about fuels a little a little
while ago I had heard
some months ago that there was a fear
that there could be a shortage of diesel
fuel in the area here can you speak to
that if it ever materialized if we do
have it or what may be coming up down
the line sure thank you representative
that's a great question there was
um
uh there were concerns about a diesel
shortage
um we were not necessarily involved in
that conversation uh kerosene you may
have heard
um there was a kerosene shortage a very
real shortage
um where uh customers could not receive
deliveries uh from their fuel vendor for
kerosene that was a that was in October
and uh early November problem and
thankfully the supplies
um are are back and kerosene is uh
available
um on diesel I would have to get back to
you on where that's at but we've not
received any
um
I should say any Outreach from the
federal government for instance on that
issue
any other questions for the gentleman
from the Department of energy
who I'm sure will be back to visit us in
the future representative Bernardi
thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh so
when we divided the distribution and the
production
uh of activities of utilities
the distribution side obviously is still
maintained as a public Monopoly and we
we allow the uh you know those entities
to operate that way
the distrib the production side however
does not appear to be a public Monopoly
and so
ultimately who is responsible for making
sure there is sufficient production of
electricity in the state is it the doe
now is it I saw New England is it the
New Hampshire legislature or who owns
that ISO New England our regional grid
operator that is that is their
responsibility
thank you
representative Loki has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman I've asked this
question in other forums in other ways
but for me as a member of this committee
it would be very useful for me to have
an idea of how much energy is consumed
in the state in what forms probably on a
month by month basis just to have an
idea how much we're using for heating
how much of whatever fuels we're using
to generate electricity and so on and uh
you know I I'm certainly not asking for
an answer now I think but this would be
something very useful because we focused
on most of the time here on electricity
and you know just looking out the window
I can see an awful lot of energy going
up chimneys and how does that compare is
all the various forms and you know as I
say it's the kind of thing that would
probably take somebody some work to put
together rather than trying to do it on
the Fly
sure uh it's a great question there's an
awful lot of good data on the U.S
department of Energy's Energy
Information Administration website that
does have you know information on the
resource mix of our electricity
generation on you know building and
Transportation uh Energy Information our
team uh if you reach out to Griffin uh
he can you know help uh you know respond
to inquiries and also provide some of
those resources to you the iso New
England uh when they come in they might
also have a little bit more
um granular data or information that
they might be able to provide a lot of
what we see is uh on a longer time
Horizon say over the course of a year
but for those uh more specific
month-to-month flows they might have
some more resources or information
follow-up okay and you know I'm looking
more specifically at New Hampshire I've
looked at eia's site and it gives us
Nationwide data but uh
where New Hampshire not uh the whole
country and so knowing what the whole
country is doing doesn't tell us what's
happening in New Hampshire in a given
time period thank you okay
I believe the eia website does break it
down by state as well representative
Nutter has a question
what's more of a comment um Mr chairman
if that's all right
um the iso to go app is is on every good
nerd in geek's phone and it gives the
breakdown of the fuel being used right
okay additional questions
seeing none I would like to offer my
personal and professional thanks to the
Department of energy for an excellent
detailed presentation we appreciate all
the work that all of your employees put
in to put together this presentation
and we'll look forward to a presentation
on the state energy strategy at some
time in the future and I'm sure we'll be
getting visits from both of you as we
get into the bill hearing process going
forward so thanks again and we
appreciate you being here thank you for
the opportunity
we are going to uh press right into the
next presenter if that's okay with
everybody
rather than take a break it's getting uh
on in the day so we'd like to call on
the office of the consumer advocate
and Mr Donald crease to speak to us
about
his role in state government what his
office does and
I'm sure he will do so in a manner that
is extremely
entertaining for everyone
so I'll
we have a minute while he gets his
computer set up I'll remind everybody
that after Mr priest's crease is done
if we have time we're going to go over
some of the additional materials that we
started to give you this morning at nine
o'clock but ran out of time to finish
if we don't have time today then we'll
move forward with that at our next
session which will be on Tuesday
January
okay Mr crease it's all yours
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee it's a great pleasure
to be here with you today uh my name is
Donald crease I am the state's consumer
Advocate and my slide presentation as I
go through it we'll tell you almost
everything you need to know about who I
am what I do and what I uh what I think
um I had a similar honor two years ago
uh to sort of introduce myself to the
committee and uh give a sense of the
world according to me and and I started
out by insisting that everything I was
going to say was going to be completely
objective and factual and uh full of
actionable information and then I went
through my presentation and I recall uh
chairman vo saying at the end of it well
that's very interesting and insightful
but just so you know it's the uh it's
one person's View and I I think I might
have said some things about some of the
utilities that maybe some people
disagreed with this time I'm really
going to try to be as objective and
absolutely unassailably true as I
possibly can and I don't think I have
anything mean to say about any of the
utilities uh today okay I I just want to
sort of level set and uh maybe for the
benefit of those of you who are new and
might have been completely vexed and
confused by some of what you have
already heard today I just want to level
set a little bit by going through some
of the basic principles that drive what
what I do and what the Public Utilities
Commission do and what my friends at the
department of energy do and what my
friends at the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission do uh as you've already heard
uh public utilities are regulated
monopolies and the that's because these
Network Industries are considered
natural monopolies it would be very
economically inefficient and therefore
expensive to allow there to be two
electricity distribution grids or two
Interstate pipeline networks so we limit
them to one system and we don't let them
charge whatever they want because
monopolists can extract Monopoly rents
from the economy meaning they can charge
prices that are in excess of what's
economically efficient so we try to
regulate the terms and conditions of
service particularly the prices or rates
and at the state level the uh entity
that is delegated with that
responsibility from the legislature is
the Public Utilities Commission and the
idea is to set rates at exactly where
they would be if we actually had a
competitive market in those services so
by Statute the general court has defined
the puc as the Arbiter between the
interests of customers and the interests
of utilities and and by utilities I
think we really mean the owners or
shareholders of the utilities so so you
have the puc as this giant scale is the
way I think of it and I I can tell you
in case you don't already know that the
state's public utilities are extremely
well represented at the Public Utilities
Commission they have regulatory teams
and really awesome lawyers and other
experts the department of energy as
you've already heard this morning which
represents the executive branch and
therefore the state I guess as a
sovereign entity it also has a fair
amount of resources and the legislature
therefore decided that maybe it would be
a good idea to put a little weight on
the scale that Arbiter scale on the side
of uh customers and so therefore for the
legislature back in the 1970s created
what has now over time become the office
of the consumer Advocate there are
or there is such an entity of one kind
or another in almost every state not
every state there are a few that don't
have any but Most states do they're set
up a little differently in every state
uh my counterpart in Maine the public
Advocate is tasked with representing all
rate payers our office represents only
residential rate payers uh in the state
to the South whose name I won't mention
but whose initials are Massachusetts my
counterpart works for the Attorney
General Connecticut has an independent
rate payer Advocate like me so it it
varies but the the the concept is the
same uh a little weight on the rate
payer scale and given the solicitude
that I've heard for ratepayers here
today uh I I think of this committee and
really the legislature in general as an
ally in that task so uh that's a picture
of the Walker building in case any of
you have never seen it you hopefully
will all have a chance to come by and
visit us that is where the the Public
Utilities Commission the department of
energy and our office are all located
it's a really nice building my office
the OCA is independent of the Public
Utilities Commission I do not report to
the chairman of the puc we are
independent of the Department of energy
and you heard commissioner shacoin
correctly point out that I do not report
to him and as he also noted we are
administratively attached to the
Department of energy pursuant to RSA
21g10 that does engender some confusion
sometimes because people therefore think
that I'm part of the Department of
energy or part of the puc but
administrative attachment is really just
about those back office functions that
commissioner shacoin mentioned and they
are very helpful to us when it comes to
budget questions and money questions and
Logistics and you know all of that kind
of stuff but but really I really and
truly don't report to any of those
people and there therefore they don't
get any of the blame for what I do
either
a little bit about me since some of you
are just meeting me for the first time
I'm a lawyer and my statute says that I
have to be a lawyer admitted to the
practice here in New Hampshire I used to
be the general counsel of the Public
Utilities Commission I spent a a little
while as a hearing officer at the puc in
Vermont I have worked as a law professor
at Vermont law school and I still teach
there as an adjunct I'm very proud of
the fact that to my knowledge I am the
only person who has ever held my job to
have been nominated by a governor of
each of the two major political parties
and while I mentioned in Governors
Hassan and sununu I do want to say that
both of the governors those governors
have taken great care to treat me as an
independent actor neither of them and
certainly not Governor sununu have ever
purported to try to oversee me or tell
me what I ought to do or what I ought
not to do that's said we try to keep
very good relations with whatever
Governor happens to be in office and I I
do think that I have an excellent
relationship with the Department of
energy they've been very kind to
literally extend an open door to me so
my key card gets me right into the
Executive Suite at the department of
energy and uh I have been known to do
that from time to time so I was first
appointed in 2016 by Governor Hassan
that I was reappointed by Governor
sununu almost four years ago and my
current term expires in November and I
have recently announced to my Advisory
board that I will in fact be seeking a
third term when my current term expires
if you look up our statute you'll see
that The Advisory Board of the
residential ratepayers Advisory Board
serves as a kind of a gatekeeper in that
in order for me to be reappointed I have
to first convince them to so recommend
to Governor sununu so I'm hoping they
will do that sometime around mid-summer
and then it will be up to the governor
to decide and should he decide to
re-nominate me then of course my name
would go before the executive Council
I have a very small staff of five people
including me I have a legal assistant I
have a staff attorney who I just hired I
I the climate for state employees and
the by which I mean the job market is
very challenging these days so
essentially I lost my whole staff to
employers that offered more lucrative
terms and conditions than I could but I
just hired a new staff attorney and he
will be starting later this month and
I'm still looking for a director of
rates and Market policy and a director
of economics and finance and if you
happen to know anybody who would be good
at doing either of those two things
please let me know and I would be happy
to reach out to them that's a photograph
of my office which is extremely messy
and so therefore you can tell that I'm
super busy or I hope that's what the I
hope that's the message that you get
from the picture of my office
as you have already heard the standard
under state law law for where rates
should fall is the famous and
well-established just and reasonable
standard so that's what the statute says
but the Constitution by which I mean
principally the Federal Constitution
also has a lot to say about this because
there is a there is a flaw on how low
rates can go and that floor has to do
with the Fifth Amendment to the U.S
Constitution which has analogous
language in the State Constitution which
says that you cannot take the government
cannot take private property for public
use without just compensation and there
is established case law that says that
if you set rates so low as to deprive a
public utility of an opportunity to earn
a reasonable return on its shareholders
investment then you have set rates that
are quote unquote confiscatory meaning
it virtually confiscates their property
for public use without offering them
providing them with just compensation
and if you do that the utilities will go
to federal courts sue you and win I just
read in the paper today in fact that
there's a bill in the Connecticut
legislature to have the legislature
rather than their utility regulator set
utility rates for electricity at least
and uh that's fine because rate setting
Authority is a legislative act that's
delegated by legislatures but you if you
were to retain that Authority or reclaim
that Authority from the puc and you
decided that the utility rates were just
too expensive for your constituents to
sustain you you have to be aware that if
you set rates at a confiscatory level
the rates would be declared
unconstitutional likely in a federal
court so if you're a fan of Supreme
Court jurisprudence I recommend a look
at the Supreme Court opinion of 1944
called Federal power commission versus
hope natural gas company and that is
where the court opined about this Quest
version of what is a fair return on
shareholder investment for utilities and
as you can see the court said and I
think every Economist I've ever met
would agree that really return marches
in lockstep with risk so what does that
mean well it means that if you take your
next paycheck and deposit it at your
credit union you will probably
reasonably expect a very low interest
rate if you took that same paycheck and
invested it in a pharmaceutical company
that is working on highly experimental
but maybe breakthrough drug therapies
you would expect a much higher rate of
return because those Investments are
very very risky much of many of them
don't pan out utility risk is I guess
somewhere in the middle I tend to think
of utilities as relatively low risk
after all
they provide essential public services
and their customers are captive
uh we are fortunate in New Hampshire to
have given the world uh David souter the
former U.S Supreme Court Justice back
when he was a Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court in 1988 he
authored uh what I think is my very
favorite appellate opinion about energy
law and electric rates
and there it is appeal of Public Service
Company of New Hampshire 1988 and in
that decision he observed that just
because utilities are entitled to an
opportunity to earn a reasonable return
on shareholder investment it does not
mean
that the shareholders are entitled to
what he described as plenary
indemnification and you know there was
his reasoning the ultimate consequence
of automatically raising the return as
the prospects for recovering the
investment fell would be nothing less
than a shifting of the entire risk from
the investors to the ratepayers never a
truer sentence about utility regulation
has ever been written and I am
constantly telling law students that
they must read David suiter's opinion in
appeal of Public Service Company of New
Hampshire
uh you have heard other people explain
this to you already today and of course
my old friend Tom Frantz knows way more
about this than I do uh here's a
lawyer's view of what uh the current
method for setting utility rates is and
again these are these are regulated
rates so I'm not talking about default
Energy service because default Energy
service is a rate that is really driven
by what's available in the wholesale
Marketplace competitive I'm talking
about the other aspects of utility
service that actually are set by the puc
and the puc does that by determining
what the utilities annual revenue
requirement is meaning how much money
should that utility take in over the
course of one year and that amount of
money is a sum of the utilities
operating costs plus a
multiple a multiple of its rate base so
the present value of its capital assets
multiplied by its weighted average cost
of capital weighted average cost of
capital is just a blended average of how
much money they have to pay to their
lenders for their borrowed money and how
much return they ought to be able to
return to their shareholders you create
that weighted average you multiply it by
the net uh the present value of their
investment you get the return you add
that to operating costs you come up with
the revenue requirement that is only
stage one of a rate case the second act
is the rate design phase and that is the
process whereby you divide that Revenue
requirement among the various classes of
customers and that is something we get
terribly involved in because there are a
lot of important issues that get
resolved there the utilities conduct
cost of service studies to determine who
is responsible for creating which costs
that the utilities can uh incur uh rates
have in them both fixed and variable
charges so if you look at your electric
bill everybody pays a fixed customer
charge every month I think it eversource
it's about 13 a month for a residential
customer that's supposed to cover the
fixed costs that the utility incurs
regardless of how much energy you use
and then all of the other charges uh
vary by how much energy you consume so
it's an interesting uh it's an
interesting question to figure out how
to how to allocate costs between those
two ends of the electric bill
representative Nutter has a question
thank you Mr chairman what is social
equity
uh well social equity which is the next
bullet point there has to do with uh
whether it is appropriate in some
circumstances to Veer away from or
depart from the idea that rates should
be driven purely by cost causation so a
great example of that would be rates
that are designed specifically for
low-income customers to give them a
break on their bill because they simply
can't afford their electricity and we
don't currently do that instead we have
energy assistance programs that give
them essentially a rebate but you can
design rates that are especially for
low-income customers there might be
certain kinds of consumption that you
want to encourage or discourage for
policy reasons you can do that that's
what I mean by social Equity I I would
say we're relatively less inclined than
other jurisdictions are to apply a lot
of social Equity questions to our rate
design but it is an established rate
design principle
follow-up
thank you so I I was wondering if it was
synonymous with ESG
ESG stands for
um
thank you uh
potentially there is overlap between
those two concepts but I wouldn't say
that they're necessarily uh synonymous I
mean you know again it's just one factor
that can by the regulator be applied to
rate design decisions I again I don't
think we're doing a lot of that in New
Hampshire right now and I have never
heard the initials ESG appear or never
seen it seen those initials appear in
any order of rpuc I think the much more
significant issue in rate design has to
do with making sure that customers get
the right price signals so that we
encourage them to consume when it's
easier or cheaper to provide them with
service and we discourage them from
consuming when it gets more expensive
for them to consume so if you think
about electricity because demand for
electricity is very low in the overnight
it's generally very inexpensive to
produce electricity in the overnight so
inexpensive in fact that I've even seen
wholesale prices go negative in the
overnight so you might want to think
about designing rates that encourage the
use of electricity during those hours
and discourage the use of electricity at
5 PM why 5 PM well I'm pretty sure the
Sun is going to go down this afternoon
at about 4 30 which means all the solar
power will go offline everybody comes
home from work and or school and
everybody turns on all of their
appliances and their lights and that
creates a big bump in demand for
electricity and so the cost of producing
electricity goes up so again if we can
send people price signals that make them
think about that that is one approach to
rate design now that may not be a good
idea for residential customers because
how many of us at dinner time are in a
position to say oops we're going to shut
everything down but if you're a big
industrial customer
um it might make sense to send you price
signals because you might be in a better
position to adjust your consumption and
thereby optimize your Revenue stream by
managing your electric uh your energy
costs and thereby helping everybody save
money by using energy when it's cheaper
and using less energy when it is more
expensive
so this is a slide I love to show
because representative partial also has
a question before you move on okay yes
thank you chair for taking my question
and hello Mr crease
in order to meet that last price signal
does that imply that we did something
such as a smart meter in order to uh get
down to that level of management yes uh
we are uh doing our best at the OCA to
nudge the utilities into the complete
adoption of so-called smart meters and
and really when I say smart meters I'm
talking about what's referred to in the
trade is Ami which stands for advanced
metering infrastructure and what we're
really looking for essentially is meters
that can record what customers use on a
granular basis so that the meter knows
and reports back to the utility not just
how much energy you used over the course
of a month but how much energy you used
in any particular hour or you can even
go down to 15 minutes or even even five
minutes and since you mentioned meters I
would like to say that in my respectful
opinion the natural monopoly on meters
is no longer there and there is no
reason why our utilities have to be the
only entities that are allowed to meter
things there could be other providers of
meters and as long as the meters meet
the so-called utility grade standard
there's no reason why the utility has to
be the exclusive provider of that device
to you
um this is my favorite slide because I'm
sure that I can give you the entire
history of electricity in New Hampshire
in one slide uh the driving force and
the development of the electric industry
in New Hampshire and in much of the
country was a gentleman you may or may
not have heard of named Samuel insul he
uh back in the days before there was a
lot of regulation of such things he
built what was essentially a nationwide
electricity Empire it was called
Commonwealth Edison and it through a
variety of holding companies and that
sort of thing controlled every utility
in the country that had the words Public
Service in its name including Public
Service Company of New Hampshire uh in
the 1930s uh when Franklin Delano
Roosevelt was elected and we tried our
best to get the country out of the Great
Depression there was some legal reforms
in the form of the public utility
holding company act which busted up the
Commonwealth Edison Empire and made
the utilities independent of each other
again also importantly in the 1930s was
the rural electrification act investor
on utilities essentially refused to wire
up Rural America and so in almost every
state including ours a network of
customer-owned electric cooperatives
developed taking advantage of low
interest loans from the federal
government and that is why today we have
our fourth electric utility being the
New Hampshire Electric Cooperative and
they are very well worth keeping an eye
on even though they have their members
have exercised their statutory right to
file a so-called certificate of
deregulation with the puc which means
the puc doesn't set their rates the
co-ops elected board of directors does
so with the Arab Oil Embargo of uh 1973
came a big change in Federal Energy law
in particular and in 1978 President
Carter signed a statute into law called
purpa that's a great acronym stands for
uh public utility uh public utility
regulatory policies Act of
1978. so I was really glad to hear
representative Munns reminisce about his
time with wheelabrader because it turns
out that because Wheelabrator was based
in Portsmouth New Hampshire at the time
and because we had a senator named John
Durkin who I think was on pretty good
terms with the folks at Wheelabrator
they incorporated into purple a
provision in the statute it's section
210 of purpa that for the very first
time opened up the electricity grid to
non-utility generators of electricity
and those non-utility generators of
electricity were called qf's qualifying
facilities what did you have to do to be
a qualifying facility Well you had to
look a lot like what the plants that
Wheelabrator was operating look like
meaning you had to be less than 80
megawatts and you had to be using
certain uh newer technologies that
didn't rely on nuclear power or fossil
fuel and I really think that if it
wasn't for Wheelabrator and Senator
Durkin that we wouldn't have had section
210 of purpa and that is really what
kind of opened the barn door to the
generation of electricity by something
other than vertically integrated
utilities so you know a very very
important development in the history of
electricity in New Hampshire
it's sometimes popular to claim that
President Carter didn't accomplish
anything in his four years in office but
he certainly accomplished a lot in the
realm of energy policy and I think purpa
was a big deal
I'm in 1988 here in New Hampshire we had
what I like to refer to as the Big Bang
meaning uh January I think it was
January 26 1988 uh Public Service
Company declared bankruptcy because it
could not sustain the crippling burden
of having to carry its uh investment in
the Seabrook nuclear power plant uh that
is a plant that was originally supposed
to be what 2 400 megawatts of power and
it was going to cost 150 million dollars
when it was first rolled out it ended up
costing 7.2 billion dollars one of the
two units was canceled so we only have
one unit at Seabrook and Seabrook did
not go online until 1990 too late for
Public Service Company of New Hampshire
which sought bankruptcy protection in
1988. that big bang resonated not just
in the boardroom of PSNH and not just
here at the state house but it resonated
through the electricity bills of every
customer of PSNH because it turns out
that when your utility goes bankrupt it
is bad for both the shareholders and the
customers and in short order New
Hampshire had the very highest
electricity rates in the entire country
that in turn
led to the
state's electric industry restructuring
act adopted in 1996 which uh sort of
dovetailed with the Federal Energy
Policy Act of 1992 and those statutes
were designed to open up the electric
industry to competition the energy
Policy Act focused on wholesale
electricity and transmission and the
restructuring Act of course focused on
distribution and Retail Energy which is
what the state regulates
it so the energy Policy Act led to the
development of what we now know as ISO
New England an independent grid operator
and the restructuring act led to the
restructuring of our electric industry
and for reasons I'd be happy to tell you
even though it would take more than one
slide
restructuring took until 2018 to finish
so finally in 2018 our utilities owned
little or no of their own generation
capacity and when they sell energy at
retail to customers they have to buy it
from wholesale providers
without producing it themselves uh and
then I I think and you know this has
been alluded to as well a key
development in the history of
electricity in New Hampshire is actually
a bunch of things that didn't happen in
the last decade or so we did not build
Northern Pass so we are not importing as
much electricity from Hydro Quebec as we
could we did not build the Northeast
direct pipeline which would have brought
more natural gas up from uh Pennsylvania
essentially and we didn't build the
excess Northeast project which was a
similar project that likewise would have
helped import more natural gas from
Points West of New England
and then of course we have the latest
developments that are really
um what we've seen in the last year or
year and a half which is
soaring rates for default Energy service
especially this year uh we saw one of
our utilities have to go all the way up
to 26 Cents
uh when for a good decade we have rate
we had a default Energy Service rates in
the 789 10 cent range so it's been a
drastic increase and it has caused a
great deal of I would say suffering and
I'm sure that you've been hearing from
your constituents about that kind of
misery
um a question that you get to Grapple
with as state policy makers is what hang
on a second before you go to your next
slide representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman uh just a
quick question for you on the history
there based on it and I've been asked
this many times I think I pretty much
know the answer but please correct me if
I'm wrong even though New Hampshire has
its own nuclear power plant in Seabrook
is it the cause or the reasoning of iso
New England the reason why only 20 of
the power that comes from Seabrook
actually comes to New Hampshire
that's a really good question and I I
get asked a form of that question all
the time with with default Energy
service so high sometimes people ask me
well we we have Seabrook in New
Hampshire why don't we just use that to
serve our load and the answer is that I
think it was in 1992 the U.S Supreme
Court told New Hampshire that it could
not do that it could not Reserve its
in-state generation capacity for its own
use that that case actually had to do
with the dams on the Connecticut River
but the same legal principle applies to
Seabrook Seabrook is part of the
regional electricity Grid it's owned by
next era which is a company based down
in Florida they bought the controlling
interest from a Public Service Company
of New Hampshire they paid a Bargain
Basement price for it and now they sell
their output of Seabrook 1200 megawatts
into the overall electricity grid now as
it happens eversource is about to start
relying on next era for its residential
default Energy service so in a way we
are using Seabrook but the owners of
Seabrook are not a charitable Enterprise
and they participate in the market such
that they get a market rate for the
electricity that they generate so to the
point about what you what data you can
get from the Energy Information
Administration about the electricity
that we consume and produce in New
Hampshire we can do that and that is
available on the EI eia website but the
caution the thing you have to keep in
mind is that we don't only consume the
electricity that we generate in New
Hampshire so you'll see we produce a lot
of nuclear power in New Hampshire
because our biggest producer is Seabrook
but we don't rely on that as our
dominant source of electricity
unfortunately there really is for
purposes of the wholesale electricity
Market no such thing as New Hampshire
there's one big wholesale Market that
covers all of New England
okay so as I was about to say you as
state policy makers have to Grapple with
this question of what sphere belongs to
the states and what's fear belongs to
the federal government and the relevant
provisions of the Federal Constitution
are the Commerce Clause and the
supremacy clause the Commerce Clause
says Congress may but does not have to
regulate interstate commerce and the
supremacy clause says that when Congress
acts within its sphere of authority and
adopts law that law is the supreme law
of the land and any state law that's
inconsistent with federal law is in
legal parlance preempted so those two
concepts Drive everything that we do
with respect to Federal Energy law and
its impact on state energy policy and
law and on the electric side the
electricity is governed federally by the
federal power act a statute it really
dates in its present form to 1935 so
obviously the world's changed a lot
since 1935 the federal power act has
tried to keep up with that or Congress
has tried to keep up with that but in
some ways we're using a statute that is
very old to deal with problems we have
today so under the federal power Act
the Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
oversees wholesale electricity
and Interstate transmission of
electricity at high voltage and you know
wholesale is one of those terms of Art
in electricity law that is really easy
to understand it means exactly what you
think it means sale for resale so a lot
of This is complicated that part isn't
complicated and wholesale electricity
sale for resale is regulated by ferc
under the federal power act and then so
what do states do well states regulate
retail electricity uh it regulates what
generation gets billed within the
borders of any state so we still get to
decide that and we are still in charge
as States on uh of so-called resource
adequacy the question that got asked
earlier of like well who's really in
charge of making sure that we have the
generation we need to keep the lights on
and the answer you got from the
Department of energy was ISO New England
and that was a correct answer but this
states have willingly ceded that
authority to ISO New England make no
mistake and states can if they want claw
that Authority back and there are some
people I don't think I'm among them but
there are some people who think that is
something we ought to consider doing
so what is this thing ISO New England
it's a garden variety
501c
501c4 501c3 non-profit organization
Incorporated I think in Connecticut it's
based in Massachusetts it is a so-called
Regional transmission organization it's
regulated by ferc its job is to operate
the bulk power transmission system for
the whole region it oversees the
wholesale electricity markets meaning it
not only operates those markets but
determines what the rules of those
markets can be it's extremely
complicated it's in charge of power
system planning so what are we building
in the future by way of new transmission
and generation facilities and it has as
an adjunct this thing that I've heard
mentioned a couple of times today called
Nepal well knee pool originally I think
it dates from 1970 or so was a it stood
for a New England power pool and that
goes back to the great blackout of 1965
when the utilities decided you know
maybe we really ought to cooperate with
each other and run our systems jointly
so that when the system gets stressed
stressed we won't necessarily have
devastating blackouts so we'll create
one big control room in Massachusetts
and the entity that did that uh created
by the utilities was called knee pool
when ISO New England was created the job
of running the electricity grid and the
ownership of the control room in
Massachusetts passed ISO New England and
knee pool's life was extended as the
so-called stakeholder advisory body to
Nepal why did I put the
word advisory in quotes it is because in
my opinion knee pool is a lot more than
it Advisory Board it for various reasons
has uh almost veto authority over what
policies at least Market policies ISO
adopt so it's a very very very powerful
organization and for that reason my
office is actually a voting member of
Nepal we're part of the so-called end
user sector of Nepal Nepal has very
elaborate voting rules that are designed
to make sure that the Legacy interests
meaning the transmission owners and the
generation owners are basically
dominating the other sectors the end
user sector really should be the boss of
all of Nepal why because we pay the
bills we're the only wallet in the room
but nevertheless we're just one little
sector in Nepal and we are a voting
member of that sector so that's
different than the role that the
department of energy plays Commissioner
shacoin is our state's Nesco manager so
he represents the governor at Nesco and
Nesco represents the states as Sovereign
entities in dealing with ISO New England
we're actually a voting member of Nepal
and so what do I try to do I try my best
at all times and I think we're
succeeding all the time at coordinating
the positions that we take at Nepal with
the positions that commissioner shacoin
is taking as our Nesco manager at Nesco
so that we are all working together to
advance the public policy of our state
so I was so glad to hear representative
naughter extol the virtues of the iso to
go app you should definitely have that
app on your phone the governor likes to
uh boast that he does and well he should
I'm sure representative Nutter has it on
her phone uh and when you have it on
your phone you can watch what is
happening on the electricity grid minute
to minute and what you access when you
fire up the app is this map and these
are screenshots I took off of the app at
two different recent times on the New
England electricity grid and this is
just such an interesting little pair of
snapshots of uh what can happen in New
England uh last week as I was getting
this slide debt together I just decided
hey what's going on on the grid now and
so I took this snapshot on the left and
and you see what you're looking at there
is the locational marginal price meaning
the prevailing spot price for wholesale
sale electricity at each place in the
system where that price is separately
set so New Hampshire gets its own price
of wholesale electricity in any uh in
any uh it varies I think by five minute
increments and at that point it was 48
dollars and three cents well you can
translate dollars
per megawatt hour which is what that
number is two cents per kilowatt hour uh
quite easily forty eight dollars and
three cents comes down to 4.8 cents per
kilowatt hour so would the default
Energy Service were anything close to
4.8 cents per kilowatt hour but you can
see that uh for uh whatever reason that
price was really low at seven o'clock
P.M on January 5th but then if you
happen to fire up your ISO to go app on
Christmas Eve like I did why did I do
that well I was hanging out with my
relatives and I was bored and you know
you have to get away from your family
somehow so you start fiddling with the
apps on your phone I turned on my ISO
New England ISO to go app and lo and
behold I see this red map red is bad
even on Christmas and you know here in
New Hampshire the spot price of
2294.26 per megawatt hour again let's
translate that in into cents per
kilowatt hour you can't it it's too big
it's actually two dollars and ninety
four cents per kilowatt hour well if you
think paying 26 cents per kilowatt hour
is an outrageously high price imagine if
somebody sent you a bill uh for your
electricity at two dollars and uh 29
cents per kilowatt hour that fortunately
is not a price that anybody ever
actually pays at retail uh these
wholesale prices are designed to
essentially send again price signals
about the current state of the market so
the way our electricity Market is
designed the price of wholesale
electricity everywhere in New England is
actually capped at two thousand dollars
so your question might be well how is it
that the price is over two thousand
dollars then and the answer is that in
this scenario at that hour just about
dinner time on Christmas Eve there were
units that had agreed to generate and
had a capacity Supply obligation that
were not available and they were
penalized financially and the result of
that Financial penalty are those numbers
in excess of two thousand dollars so
this is not a monetary crisis that you
see on the right side this is a warning
that the electricity grid is too easily
pushed into a situation that in in which
it is stressed what was stressing the
electricity Grid at 525 on Christmas Eve
well a couple of things you may remember
that the weather was kind of wonky that
day right it was cold and in fact it was
colder than the weather forecast had
expected so instead and the temperature
maybe you remember plummeted drastically
in a very quick period of time well that
was not expected at exactly the time it
occurred and so therefore the weather
was colder than expected demand was
higher than expected for much of that
day that is a big part of what was
stressing the grid and then there were
some generators that weren't available
that promised to be available and the
next thing you know you have this crisis
and again I think the moral of the story
is that that happens a little too easily
I think you're going to have some
questions about that one uh
representative nodder thank you it's
just it's 37 34 at the moment
yeah so that's a that's great those are
the kinds of prices that we used to see
all the time you know two years ago and
you know now it's all together two two
common to see prices you know not in the
Red Zone but in the kind of yellow
orange zone of like 300 a megawatt hour
uh you know those were the forward
prices that we were looking at for this
month when we were hashing out the
question of what the price of default
Energy service was going to be this this
winter so it's really it's it's good to
just keep track of where that where
that's going on an hour to hour basis
and then it's great to kind of take a
step back every so often and say well
what happened yesterday you know and
where did load go compared to where it
was supposed to go and what what went
wrong and what caused what price blips
and it usually is uh some combination of
unpredicted it's usually it's
unpredicted events so unpredicted events
on the supply side unpredicted events on
the demand side the other thing I want
to say about that Infamous little crisis
on Christmas Eve is that a Mystic
station
which is the Region's largest generator
1400 megawatts and I have a whole slide
about them in a minute they were not
generating on Christmas Eve and I wrote
a column about this little event called
The Nightmare the electricity Nightmare
Before Christmas my column by the way
appears on the news website
indepthnh.org I was a journalist before
I was a lawyer and in some ways my legal
career is really just an outgrowth of my
journalism career so I tried I write
columns about my work as a way of
explaining all of this to people so I
wrote a whole column about that December
24th Nightmare and one of the things I
discovered is that Mystic station was
not generating now I made a point of
saying in that column that I didn't know
why that was and very quickly the owners
of Mystic station uh constellation new
energy send an email to my editor that
said we weren't generating because we
weren't dispatched we were ready to go
and we had fuel but we were not
dispatched I would like to know maybe
you would like to know why that was I do
not know and ISO New England won't tell
you I predict because they're very cagey
about what they reveal about who bid
what and who got dispatched and who
wasn't dispatched and why it it is a
problem so we will be sure to ask them
when they're here indeed indeed and I
hope I'll be sitting in the audience
when you ask that question on the 19th
representative Corman has a question for
you thank you Mr chairman what is the
mechanism by which these prices are set
there's some auction going on or
something like that and it's automated
or what is the actual mechanism to set
these prices that's a great question so
uh there is a set of elaborate Market
rules most power most electricity is
committed by contract well in advance so
what you're looking at on those screen
with those two price Maps that's the
spot price so that is where electricity
that is not committed is bought and sold
in real time most electricity
is resolved in the so-called day ahead
market so anything that's left over that
needs to be committed in order to meet
the predicted demand for tomorrow is uh
locked in at about 2 pm every day
through the so-called day ahead market
and then when tomorrow turns out to be
not exactly as we predicted to be today
that's what we use the spot prices for
so every generator that is available
makes a bid that is based on its cost of
generation and there's a market monitor
that makes sure that those bids are cost
baits based so there's no Enron esque
funny business and those bids are
entered and the control room in Holyoke
dispatches the available generation in
Merit order meaning it plugs in the
cheap stuff first and it keeps working
up and up and up and the last unit that
it dispatches is the most expensive unit
the one that makes the highest bid and
that bid that they're the marginal
provider they set the clearing price
that's how it works follow up follow up
so I'm still unclear who is making the
bids is this human beings or is it
software
it's human beings I think they're using
software but it is human beings that are
deciding what they are willing to bid on
behalf of the generation that they
control and own and again there are
there's Market monitoring so that when
that human being makes a bid
that person has to be able to verify
that the bid was based on the company's
actual cost of producing not some made
up number the the risk being that you'll
enter some bid that's way lower than
your cost or do some other funny
gamesmanship that will distort the
market we we don't like that because we
saw in California back in 2000 what
happens when you let that happen bad
so don to follow up on that question
the real-time price right now is 38
dollars and the day ahead price for
tomorrow is 39 dollars
how is the day ahead price calculated do
you know it's calculated the same way
everybody's making bids the bids are
made a day in advance and the uh the iso
sets the day ahead price for each hour
one day ahead and So based on the bids
that were put in versus the projected
demand for this hour tomorrow that was
the clearing price
and note by the way that there's a
separate locational price for each
region it's mostly goes by state but
they carved Massachusetts up into three
regions so uh those different prices are
supposed to take into account the
existence of transmission constraints so
that you know when power can move freely
through the region the locational
marginal price is the same or nearly the
same everywhere and that is mostly where
we are today we've spent billions of
dollars we pay the highest transmission
rates in the whole country and you don't
necessarily have to like that I
certainly don't but what we got by
paying those High rates is a
transmission grid that is essentially
congestion free congestion used to be a
much bigger problem in New England than
it is now and so now you see that e in
either the unstressed or stressed
condition the prices around the region
were pretty comparable
um
okay so I stole this slide from my
friends at eversource and the point
eversource is making one more
representative please thank you chairman
thank you for taking my question
um can you give it an idea of what
percentage of the total uh electricity
being used is on the market
so you said that some of it is purchased
through the six-month contracts right
that would be most of it I assume and
then there's some small amount that is
so this Market is actually covering just
that small portion
can you say how much that is thank you
uh well those are great questions to ask
the folks from the iso and the answer
depends in part on how into the weeds
you want to get about how the markets
really work technically it's all on the
market I mean everything has to be bid
in and everything gets the market
clearing price but if you've already
locked in a contract for some of that
power it essentially operates in Market
terms as a hedge against the market
price uh and so in effect you get the
benefit of whatever long-term contract
you have entered into I don't know if
that makes sense but that's the way it
foreign
representative Corbin thank you
the clearing prices as I understand what
you said there are different generators
and they are charging different prices
and those prices are going up as as the
bidding is going up
and then eventually we hit the clearing
price and everybody's getting the
clearing price that's right you said
they're charging different prices
they're not charging different prices
they're bidding different prices but
everybody gets the clear in price you're
just talking about that at lunch you
know trying to imagine what other
markets are designed that way and uh I I
think that's the way capitalism
generally works right like if you uh are
if you make Cheerios or if you make
cereal that people like to eat and you
figure out some secret way to make it at
half the cost of your competitor you
don't automatically pass that cost
savings onto your customer you keep the
benefit of your Innovation as best you
can as the producer because you're a
profit maximizing firm and that's what
these companies are and so the idea is
that we want to encourage generators to
be efficient and one way we do that is
by letting them keep that uh that extra
Revenue that they incur by basically
being able to produce at less than the
Okay so
uh so I stole this slide from eversource
and what it's really saying is that we
are because we went through a decade of
very low prices for natural gas we
became very Reliant in New England on
natural gas to produce our electricity
and those chickens have now come home to
roost uh one way of posing the question
of why our electricity rates so high
right now is to ask conversely why were
they so low for so long and the answer
is natural gas was cheap we're very
reliant on natural gas and when the
price of natural gas goes up our
electricity prices go up why because we
are participating in the global market
for natural gas so there was a huge
uptick in global demand for natural gas
the United States is an exporter of
natural gas to much of the rest of the
world we convert natural gas into
liquefied natural gas we put it on big
tankers and we ship it all over the
world and so we here in New Hampshire or
in New England are competing with
natural gas s users everywhere on the
planet and the results are the high
electricity the high natural gas prices
that we see driving High electricity
prices and you know 45 percent of our
portfolio being in natural gas
that's a lot
um and you know this graph makes the
point a different way the price of
natural gas on the uh on the on the
competitive market for natural gas in
either at the Henry Hub down in Texas or
at Dracut much closer to New Hampshire
no matter where you measure it the price
of electricity and the price of natural
gas
are totally totally correlated and I I
guess I'd like to make a uh I'd like to
express a hypothesis about the war in
Ukraine
some people blame the war in Ukraine for
the run-up in electricity prices and I I
think that the thing to blame on the war
in Ukraine is the volatility in prices
that we're seeing now I think that if
you look at where we were headed even
before our friend Vladimir Putin invaded
Ukraine you'll see that we were already
in a pretty significant upward Glide in
natural gas prices so I think the prices
might be a lot like they are today even
had there not been an invasion of
Ukraine but Ukraine is creating where
weird up and downs ups and downs in the
uh Global price of natural gas and
therefore the price of electricity that
we pay here in New England now I
mentioned Mystic station so when next
time you drive down to Boston and you're
going down I-93 and you're almost to
Boston you can see the Boston skyline
right in front of you look off to your
left look for the wind turbine which is
not part of Mystic station but right
behind it is Mystic station it's owned
by constellation new energy it is the
Region's biggest
generator unlike it's a natural gas
generator the three stacks on the right
side are retired coal units they're not
working the two stacks on the left are
the two uh gas generators at Mystic
station that produce a total of 1400
megawatts Mystic station is unique
because it's a natural gas generator but
it doesn't connect to the regional
Interstate natural gas pipeline it uses
liquefied natural gas that arrives by
boat and yes for reasons of the Jones
act and otherwise right now it's getting
its energy from Trinidad and Tobago
the owners of Mystic station announced a
few years ago that they were going to
retire the unit because they thought
that they couldn't make money operating
it anymore and in response to that
uh i7 New England proposed and ferc
approved a so-called reliability must
run agreement with Mystic station that
basically guarantees them their costs uh
both this winter and next winter uh
whatever those costs are and their fuel
costs are extremely volatile and we're
all paying them and it is a deviation
from the market-based principles that
ordinarily govern wholesale and Retail
electricity it's a reprise of the battle
days when you if you operated it you
were guaranteed to recover your costs so
that's what Mystic station is doing it's
getting these so-called RMR payments and
that of course begs and flat out raises
the question of why weren't they
dispatched when we had that blip on on
Christmas Eve while I was trying to get
away from my relatives this is a quote
that you can read at your leisure from I
think it's from the ferc order approving
that RMR agreement and there is where uh
ferc explained exactly what it is
okay
um it is well known to those of you who
have ever heard me talk about these
subjects before that uh my favorite
subject is Energy Efficiency in fact in
my view as consumer Advocate the best
thing that I can deliver on behalf of
the constituency whose interests I
represent is Energy Efficiency why is
that well it is because I respectfully
contend that so-called negawatts with an
N are cheaper than megawatts and they're
fungible if you can serve the next unit
of demand for electricity by basically
replacing that demand or backing off of
that demand then that has the same
effect of adding another megawatt of
supply to the supply demand mix so if we
can figure out ways to do the same
amount of work produce the same amount
of heat the same amount of light the
same amount of motive energy for your
industrial process but we can do it for
Less using less energy that's Energy
Efficiency and we want as much of that
as we can possibly manage to squeeze out
of the available technology so here in
New Hampshire we have rate payer funded
Energy Efficiency programs we all of us
through our electricity and natural gas
bills pay non-by-passable charges that
fund State Energy Efficiency programs
and they put a little bit of a thumb on
the scale I would say on the side of
Energy Efficiency and as I readily and
cheerfully concede in my second bullet
point that is a pretty big interference
in what would otherwise be what you
might call free market economics but
if you first of all if you think that
there is otherwise in a free market in
electricity and we can debate that
my contention is that the perfect
shouldn't be the enemy of the good
because these are things that would not
happen on their own
and so we encourage them by making them
more
desirable for businesses and residential
customers to implement those measures
in their homes and businesses so why is
this a good idea because we have worked
really hard in New Hampshire to develop
a cost benefit test
that is keyed to our state's public
policy and has been approved by the
Public Utilities Commission and has
proven time and again that when we
invest money in Energy Efficiency the
benefits exceed the costs so
that's why I'm so confident about
spending
a lot of rate payer money on Energy
Efficiency now I am obsessed these days
with discount rates why am I obsessed
with discount rates because Energy
Efficiency measures last usually for a
really long time if I come along and
weatherize your home and make it super
energy efficient those weatherization
measures are probably going to last 30
years well that's 30 years of Energy
Efficiency for your house but
what do I do with those Energy
Efficiency benefits in year 30. what are
they worth today well they're not going
to be worth today exactly what they're
worth in the future because why they're
in the future so you have to figure out
how to move the benefit or the value of
that 30 years of Energy Efficiency you
have to be able to develop develop a net
present value for those benefits and the
way you do that is you apply a discount
rate well what discount rate do you
apply
and you know you can argue about that a
lot one suggestion I hear from time to
time is let's apply the discount rate
that's equal to the utilities allowed
return on equity and you heard earlier
speakers say that in New Hampshire I
think Tom Frantz said that's usually
around nine percent these days well if
you applied a nine percent discount rate
to Energy Efficiency benefits funded by
our Statewide Energy Efficiency programs
almost none of them would be cost
effective and we wouldn't have a
Statewide Energy Efficiency program
anymore because they wouldn't be cost
effective and we don't want to spend
money that isn't cost effective but if
you think nine percent as I do is too
high a discount rate what's the right
one and the answer is we don't really
know so it's a bit of a judgment call
and so that makes it a policy call and a
big part of me thinks that what you
ought to consider as a committee
is maybe setting that discount rate
yourself letting people come in here and
tell you what they think it should be
and then you is the elected
representatives of the people maybe you
should make that decision I'm likely to
come in here and tell you it should be
somewhere around one percent
um and you know the utilities are
somebody else could come in and tell you
that it should be 10 and then you can
make the decision because you won't make
the decision based on science there
isn't any science not even economics
it's just a policy call so I think it's
a decision you should consider making so
where do we stand with Energy Efficiency
in New Hampshire that above at the top
of the slide is the logo of NH saves
that is the trade name of our state
Energy Efficiency programs uh they're
administered by our Public Utilities
that's a little weird when you think
about it it's sort of like paying Dunkin
Donuts to help people lose weight but it
works
so we have our utilities develop the
program in 2016 the Public Utilities
Commission approved an Energy Efficiency
resource standard for New Hampshire the
idea there was to set savings goals and
then once we set the goals develop the
budgets and adjust the Energy Efficiency
charges accordingly uh pursuant to that
bit of public policy the First triennial
Energy Efficiency plan was approved by
the puc in 2017 and it ran for those
three years of that plan during 2020 the
utilities collaborated with us at the
OCA and other stakeholders on developing
the second triennial Energy Efficiency
plan which the puc ended up rejecting
316 days into the triennium on November
12th of 2021 and not only did the puc
reject the triennial plan
it said we're done with the Energy
Efficiency resource standard that's not
our policy anymore and in fact we're
going to phase out rate payer funded
Energy Efficiency altogether over the
next three years well
to quote John Milton at that point all
hell broke loose and meaning that from
really across the Spectrum people began
to point out rather emphatically the
devastating consequences of doing that
and as a result of that on February 28th
uh Governor sununu signed Senate Bill
549 into law Prime sponsor
representative Vose that I think created
a more sensible approach to Energy
Efficiency for New Hampshire in that the
programs were enshrined in statute but
there were some limits placed on how
much money how much rate payer money
we're going to spend on them through
non-bypassable rates that was House Bill
a house bill excuse me did I say Senate
bill so does your presentation apologies
it was House Bill 549 and representative
Vose was the lead sponsor thank you
um
okay so where are we now well the next
triennial plan is due on July 1st uh the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board is the official forum for
stakeholder input into that triennial
plan uh the puc meanwhile is conducting
a big investigation into what we do
about Energy Efficiency in New Hampshire
and the big nagging problem that we're
grappling with is the so-called 65
electric savings problem and that is
because in House Bill 549 it says that
when we take money from Electric
customers via the system benefits charge
and spend it on Energy Efficiency at
least 65 percent of the savings that we
achieve by spending that money have to
come from electricity savings rather
than other kinds of savings meaning
unregulated fuels so the puc read that
and it decided to add a couple of words
into the statute and say that that's 65
threshold applies both to annual savings
and life lifetime savings and it turns
out that the lifetime savings if that is
in fact the standard makes most home
weatherization programs no longer
eligible for funding because they don't
meet that threshold why is that well
it's for the same reason I gave before
weatherization measures last a wicked
long time usually about 30 years and if
I weatherize your house unless you're
using electric heat chances are most of
the savings that you achieve will be
through something other than electricity
and so those weatherization programs
would knock the whole system out of
kilter with respect to Lifetime savings
and so what the utilities will do is
they will stop proposing home
weatherization unless we do as has been
proposed in a bill that you will hear
this session and we put the word annual
in the statute so we make clear to the
puc that we don't want them to apply
that threshold to Lifetime savings okay
just a little advertisement here or
maybe an example of what we mean by rate
payer funded Energy Efficiency this is
the Oyster River Middle School
in um Portsmouth
opened last year it is a net zero
building that was funded by the or its
Energy Efficiency measures were funded
by NH saves and it is designed to
basically produce at least as much
energy as it consumes so how does it do
that well it's really energy efficient
and it has a bunch of solar panels that
the faculty get to park underneath or
visitors do
and the way that the deal is structured
they actually have to produce the
savings or they don't get half the money
so there's basically the school district
has 148 thousand dollars bet on the fact
that this project will in fact produce
what it is supposed to produce and that
program is called Net Zero it's an
eversource program and that is their uh
I guess I would call it their signal uh
Net Zero project in New Hampshire we
have a statute called least cost
integrated resource planning I think
it's a really important part of our
public policy in New Hampshire it says
that we expect our electric and Natural
Gas Utilities to develop and file plans
that meet the state's energy policy
which is right there in the statute on a
basis that is least cost from the
standpoint of customers it requires the
utilities to talk about and the puc
ultimately to review how the utilities
have assessed options not just capital
projects but any options because there
are all kinds of things the utilities
can do to meet their service objectives
without necessarily investing in more
toys you know and rate design is an
example of that so we expect the
utilities to file these least cost
integrated resource plans we expect the
puc to review them for consistency and
consistency with the statute but for as
long as I've been involved in this the
puc has been misapplying the statute and
has been essentially treating least cost
integrated resource plans as if they're
kind of book reports well I can
understand why the puc has done that
least cost integrated resource planning
is a creature of the pre-restructuring
era of Public Utilities but I think that
we can we can adapt least cost
integrated resource planning to meet the
current legal and technological
realities and so what we have is a model
that says the utilities file their lease
cost plans they tell the epuc what
they're gonna do then they file rate
cases to tell the puc what they did do
and if they did it prudently and if they
built assets that are used and useful
they get rate recovery and so if we're
vigorous about the least cost planning
process we can provide more certainty
for the utilities which their
shareholders will like and also more
accountability which hopefully the rest
of us will like so there is a bill in
the legislature this term it'll be a
house bill that calls for the outright
repeal of the least cost integrated
resource planning statute I I
unabashedly hope to convince you to
replace that with a rewrite of the lcirp
statute that makes it actually work
a signal initiative of my office is the
Statewide utility customer data platform
I'm sorry that I can't honor
representative McGee because she's not
in the room but she was the champion of
Senate Bill 284 that was a Senate bill
this time but representative McGee
championed it here in this committee it
was adopted by the legislature it said
to the puc we think this data platform
idea is a good one and why is it a good
idea because if we allow customers to
share their energy data usage with
providers of unregulated innovative
Retail Energy Services they'll save
money and become more empowered uh and
freedom oriented I guess you could say
users of the electricity grid and the
natural gas system
so the bill said that that was a good
idea told the puc to open a docket to
consider it we reached a settlement
agreement with all the stakeholders even
the utilities I was sure the utilities
were going to try to kill this whole
initiative I was wrong they're actually
very enthusiastic about it so they're
working with us we created a governance
Council so that the utilities don't get
to do whatever they want they have to
live with or work with stakeholders and
stakeholder input and the statute says
the puc can stop the project if it
determines that the costs are excessive
thereby providing a measure of
protection so that it doesn't doesn't
become a blank check
okay just briefly I just want to tell
you what I'm going to be hoping to see
happen in the legislature this year as I
said earlier I'd like to see reform not
repeal of the least cost planning
statute I'd like to solve that 65
lifetime electric savings problem I
would like to tell the puc and there
will be a bill starting in the Senate
that does this to tell the puc that
regulating the data platform project is
not the same as managing it and I'm
sorry that we have to remind the POC of
that but that will be necessary
I know that the legislature is very keen
this year on reforming the facility
citing process and I am an enthusiastic
supporter of that initiative why because
it's obvious that no matter what policy
outcomes you favor in order to meet the
energy needs of this state's ratepayers
in the future we need more
infrastructure of any number of types
you know whether you think the answer is
more transmission so so that we can move
more electricity in from Canada or
whether you think we should be building
nuclear power plants if they're cost
effective or whether you like wind
turbines no matter what it is that you
think is the cool technology that you
favor we need to be able to build those
things here in New Hampshire and right
now that is very very very difficult to
do such that the companies that would
have to put Capital At Risk to do that
don't want to do that well that's bad so
we need to figure out ways to make it
possible to build these things and I'm
really glad the legislature is going to
take a look at that and you can look to
me to be an enthusiastic partner in that
process and finally I think it's time to
start exploring this concept called
transactive Energy and that just means
turning retail energy into something
that looks a lot like wholesale energy
so imagine if Just the Way Wholesale
producers can trade and sell electricity
and have it be bought by wholesale
pliers imagine if we could do that at
reach detail so that you could sell your
electricity that you're producing on
your rooftop or in your backyard or
through some other means to your
neighbors and vice versa I think we need
to explore that to be frank I'm not sure
exactly how we need to do that but it's
an important policy initiative to look
at implementing and then our regulatory
priorities what do we want to see happen
at the puc I want to see the puc approve
a robust triangular Energy Efficiency
plan after it's filed in July I would
like to see the utility customer data
platform move forward without too much
puc interference
I do think that we are finally in a
position to come up with a permanent
formula for how we compensate producers
of distributed energy meaning metering I
think that we have to apply the lcirp
statute correctly rather than just as a
mechanism to require utilities to file
book reports every three or four years
we clearly need to take a hard look at
how we procure default Energy Service
how do I know that well the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op just reduced
its default Energy Service rate down to
13 cents
it was already way ahead of everybody
else at 17 cents I thought for a while
that rate's not long for this world but
lo and behold they turned around and
said that as of January 1st we're
reducing it to 13 cents that's half of
the rate that one of the other utilities
is charging so clearly the Electric
Co-op is doing something that the puc
should be telling the investor on
utilities they should be doing in Maine
the default Energy Service rate that
just went into effect it's called
standard offer over there is either 16
or 17 cents depending on which of their
two big utilities you're talking about
so even the investor on Utilities in the
state that's nearby and most like ours
they're also beating our utilities I
just want to stress because I know there
are utility representatives in the room
this is not their fault
the utilities are only doing what the
puc has told them to do we need to
figure out what we can tell them to do
that will be different and better and
the puc has an open investigation for
doing that and when the puc comes here
you should encourage them to act on that
as vigorously and effectively and
quickly as they can because these
default Energy Service rates are too
high of course we need to make sure that
people who are having trouble paying
their electric bills and their natural
gas bills have a way to do that we have
energy assistance programs for both
electric and natural gas customers we
have to make sure that those remain
vibrant and although I didn't put it in
my slide deck uh I do think that this is
going to be the year of community power
aggregation uh if done correctly it may
very well finally deliver to residential
customers the benefits of restructuring
for which they have paid hundreds of
millions of dollars in stranded costs
it's not a guarantee but I think it
might happen and I think we should keep
a careful eye on how those projects work
uh and I also have Federal and Regional
priorities that basically involve
opening up to more sunlight the uh both
ice and New England and Nepal and I
think I'm going to gloss over those
right now in the interest of time
because I know everybody must be getting
tired but I'll be happy to come back and
talk about those whenever you want
because those are really important why
is it important because that's really
where all the money is these days in
these wholesale energy and transmission
realms
and finally I'm an architecture buff so
I decided to throw this slide in and ask
you to tell me which of these four
pictures shows a building that is not
this is apropos of absolutely nothing
but I will tell you that the building
that is not located in New Hampshire is
the one in the upper left that happens
to be a building called The Chateau it's
located at my alma mater Middlebury
College in a different state it's the
most traditional looking thing there
everything else is located in New
Hampshire on the lower left is that new
bridge that they built across Portsmouth
Harbor on the lower right is a public
housing project in Manchester and in the
upper left is the coolest building in
New Hampshire the library of the
Phillips Exeter Academy designed by the
best American architect of the 20th
century Louis Khan we're very fortunate
to have it here and on the bottom of
that slide deck and also on the first
slide of the slide deck is my contact
info I love talking to legislators and
here's a promise that I'll make to you I
love helping legislators do what they
want to do I love drafting bills I will
help you do whatever you want to do you
can call me up and say Don I need help
drafting an amendment or a bill and even
if it's something that I know is wrong
that I just flat out disagree with I
will still help you do it because even
if you adopt public policy that I think
is wrong-headed I still want it to be in
statutes that are clear well written
with standards that we can apply
thoughtfully and sensibly and frankly
correctly and so I'm committed to
helping you all do that I think that's
everything I have to say and then some
I'd be happy to answer any more
questions that you want to offer if the
Chairman's willing to call in you to ask
them yes we'll take a couple before we
leave Don and thank you for a fantastic
presentation as usual representative
Wendy Thomas has a question thank you
very much you said that you're the
advocate for the residential consumers
oh I was going to move I think it's time
for me to move I didn't I've been
getting up out of your chair too much oh
that's okay is there a comparable office
for cni and who advocates for the
municipalities that's a really great
question and the answer is no there is
not uh again you know in Maine the
public Advocate has all customers to
think of and take care of I think the
theory when our office was constituted
as the residential rate payer Advocate
is that the big cni customers tend to be
able to take care of themselves we see
less of that lately it used to be that
some of the big commercial and
Industrial customers used to appear at
the puc to kind of flex their muscles
and assert their interests I've been
encouraging the business and industry
Association to take a more active role
at the puc and I I think they're open to
that we have a very good relationship
with the new leadership at the Bia and I
I hope to see more commercial and
Industrial consumer advocacy at the puc
one question that comes up occasionally
is do you amend the OCA statute so that
we have that Charter and that's
something to think about
um we could talk about that
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair I'm intrigued by the
default Energy service and and when you
mentioned the fact that the Electric
Co-op for instance has rates that are
half of what our utilities are are
charging uh per kilowatt and I just
wanted to know what your opinion is is
really an opinion question uh do you how
confident are you in the puc
puc's ability to look into that in an
effective manner when they issued their
report
um I I don't have any lack of confidence
in the puc's ability to vigorously look
at what all the available options are
um do you want me to opine on what I
think we should do well I'll just say
this first of all it's true that we've
seen default Energy Service rates up to
26 Cents eversource is about to move
theirs down to 20 cents so I think
really the good comparison might be 13
to 20. that's still a pretty big Delta
what's the difference well the Electric
Co-op is actively managing its
electricity portfolio what we've told
our investor own utilities to do is to
put out an RFP every six months and the
price that you get is entirely based on
what bidders are willing to propose on
whatever day their bizer do and if your
RFP if the responses are due in a bad
week you get really bad prices that's
how we got 26 Cents so if you luck out
and hit the market on a good week then
you get better price it shouldn't come
down to that kind of good or bad luck so
I think we need to find ways to get our
utilities to manage their default Energy
Service portfolio more
aggressively and vigilantly but we could
adopt a whole different uh um we could
adopt a whole different Paradigm as Tom
Frantz mentioned we could use a live
descending clock auction and there are
reasons to think about doing that that
have to do with the economics and I
guess the psychology of of bidding so
representative muns thank you Mr
chairman just a quick question to make
sure I heard you correctly the co the
co-op is not regulated by the puc is
that correct that's correct back in
about 2001 I think it was the
legislature passed a bill that said that
the membership of the Cooperative could
vote to file a so-called certificate of
deregulation with the puc and the
membership of the co-op voted to do that
and so it's not and the reason I'm
particular about this is It's not that
the co-op is no longer regulated it's
that the members of the co-op who own
and use that utility have exercised
their right to remove most of their
utility from puc oversight they could
change their minds
um there are in Vermont for example
Vermont has two electric co-ops they are
regulated exactly the same as investor
and utilities are
quick follow-up follow-up so that would
mean that the so the only two utilities
then are Unitil and eversource correct
well yes but they all have different
subsidiaries depending on which industry
there are so there are actually
four there's
well there's five there's eversource
there's Liberty's electric affiliate
there's a Liberties natural gas
affiliate and then there's a electric
and natural gas affiliative Unitil and
then of course we have water companies
as well that are regulated I was
referring thinking mostly of electric
representative Nutter has a question
it's actually for you Mr chairman um I
have to leave because I have an
appointment
um I just wanted to apologize for the
times today that I made comments that
were not actual questions and that goes
against the rules that you set at the
beginning of the meeting
um so I ask for your forgiveness and
goodbye for today you are forgiven and
thank you but before any of you leave I
would just like to correct an oversight
from earlier today when I neglected to
introduce our committee researcher to
everybody who's assembled here she's
back there in the back if you'll stand
up Christy this is Christy offreser did
I pronounce that right
she's our new committee researcher and
we're glad to have her here so stop by
and say hi to Christy on your way out
the door and I'm sure we'll be taking
advantage of her expertise as the
session rolls on
and see no other questions for the
consumer Advocate I would like to thank
you heartily Don for a wonderful
presentation thank you all for being
here today and remind the members that
we will meet here again on Tuesday the
17th of January at 10 A.M for further
presentations
and until that time
I wish you a good week and I'm going to